WELCOME EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE RAISING GENTLEMAN-
FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THE STATE
CAPITAL ON THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE WE HAVE A
PRETTY BUSY DAY IN FRONT OF US
THAT WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TWELVE WITH
AUTHORS- PRESENTING IN THREE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ALL THE
AUTHORS THAT WILL BE PRESENTING
TODAY WILL BE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO THROUGH THE RUN A SHOW IF
YOU WILL THE TALK ABOUT
HOUSEKEEPING MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN TODAY'S
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE HEARING CENTER DORADO
WILL BE PRESENTING SENATE BILL
FOUR OH THREE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GONZALEZ WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR THEY'RE ALL GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE BILLS
ITEM THIRTEEN ITEM FOURTEEN.
AND ITEM FIFTEEN. THAT HAVE A
FEW BILLS THAT ARE ON TODAY'S
DOCKET THAT WILL GENERATE
CONSIDERABLE CONSIDERATION. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE SURE THAT
FOLKS KNOW DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. WE'VE HAD TO MAKE
TWO IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS FOR
THE HEARING TODAY. NUMBER ONE.
THE COMMITTEE'S GONNA START
WITH A SPECIAL ORDER A SPECIAL
ORDER FOR THREE BILLS. THIS IS
ON YOUR AGENDA ON YOUR AGENDA.
SB NINE WILL BE TAKEN FIRST I'M
GOING TO PRESENT SB NINE ON
BEHALF OF PRESIDENT. OF THE
SENATE ATKINS VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN ARE AMAZING VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE WILL THEN RUN THE
MEETING. WILL THEN TAKE UP SB
TEN BY SENATOR WIENER. AND
FINALLY WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. IN SENATOR DODD.
AFTER THE COMMITTEE CONSIDERS
SB FIVE FIVE SIX WITHIN GOING
TO PROCEED WITH OUR REGULAR
AGENDA. NOW THAT REGULAR AGENDA
WILL THEN START WITH SENATOR
DODD PRESENTING SB EIGHT
TWENTY. SO TO RECAP. FOR BILLS
THAT WERE TAKING FIRST NINE. SB
NINE FIFTY TEN SB FIVE FIVE SIX
NUMBER FOUR. BUT WILL- WITHIN
THAT B. S. B. EIGHT TWENTY.
AFTER WE HEAR EIGHT TWENTY WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A
SLIGHT AMENDMENT. IN HERE SB.
FIVE FIVE TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. BECAUSE OF THE TODAY
JUST TO. ON THE LINK THE TODAY
HEARING IN THE LEAVE ENOUGH
TIME FOR MEMBERS TO DEBATE AND
DISCUSS BILLS. WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO SLIGHTLY LIMIT
TESTIMONY ON THREE OF OUR
SPECIAL ORDER BILLS AND OTHER
BILLS IF NECESSARY. THOSE
LIMITS I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
ARE GONNA BE EQUALLY APPLIED TO
THE SUPPORT INTO THE
OPPOSITION. EACH BILL SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT OUR- TESTIMONY FOR
OUR SPECIAL ORDER BILLS AGAIN
OUR SPECIAL ORDER BILLS. ARE SB
NINE SB TEN IN SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. SO FOR SB NINE TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES WILL BE PROVIDED TO
EACH SIDE SUPPORT IN THE POST
FOR SB TEN. FIFTEEN MINUTES
WILL BE PROVIDED FOR EACH SIDE.
FOR SB FIVE FIVE SIX TWENTY
FIVE MINUTES. WILL BE APPLIED
FOR EACH SIDE. I HAVE A TIMER
WITH ME WILL BE KEEPING TRACK.
AND AS WE GET CLOSE TO THE TIME
LIMIT. WE'LL MAKE SURE GIVE
FOLKS A HEADS UP. NOW THAT TIME
LIMIT STARTS WITH OUR FIRST OF
TWO. PRIMARY WITNESSES BOTH
OPPOSITION IS WELL SUPPORT IN
OUR TELEPHONE TESTIMONY. SO WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE
EQUAL TIME FOR BOTH SIDES FOR
SPECIAL ORDER BILLS. WE REALLY
ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU IN
TODAY'S HEARING. SO SPEAKING
THAT LAYS IN GERMAN WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
PHONE NUMBER MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THIS HANDY TODAY WE ARE GONNA
BE TAKING TESTIMONY IN
COMMITTEE ON A TELECONFERENCE
LINE. YOU CAN CALL IN ANYTIME
WE'VE ACTUALLY ADDED LINES
TODAY THAT PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE HEARING. COLLEGE NOW.
877-226-8152 OUR MODERATOR IS
STANDING BY THE CODE TO BE ABLE
TO GET IN IS FOUR FOUR FIVE.
SIX TWO OH SIX AND THAT IS
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN NOW.
SO BEFORE WE GET INTO ANY
ADDITIONAL- HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR TODAY.
MR CONNEL GOOD MORNING SIR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU IF YOU COULD
PLEASE JUST AFTER QUORUM BY
CALLING THE RULE SENATOR
MCGUIRE AIR WIRE PRESENT
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESIDENT SENATOR ALSO. YEAH
TORONTO PRESIDENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERE HERTZBERG
PRESENT SENATOR WIENER. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM AS YOU GEMMA
QUORUM IS BEEN ESTABLISHED WAY
FOR MEMBERS IN THE ROOM
INCLUDING OUR VICE CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MISTER VICE CHAIR WANNA
REMIND FOLKS YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO THREE WAYS THAT YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN TODAY'S HEARING HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
THE STATE CAPITAL WE ALSO HAVE
AN OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
YOUR TESTIMONY VIA OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THAT'S.
877-226-8152 IN RESPONSE TO THE
COPA NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE NORMAL PRACTICES THAT WE
PRACTICE HERE. IN THE CARE
CAPITAL TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
TESTIMONY IN EITHER ONE OF THE
TWO ROOMS IN THE CAPITAL AND OR
ON OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE WHEN
WE MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'RE GONNA BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO REMIND YOU
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE LINE IF YOU
DON'T MIND CAN YOU PLEASE MOVE
MUTE YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THAT THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
THAT'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELP
KEEP THINGS MOVED INTO REDUCE
FEEDBACK IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
AN INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE FOR
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
ALL RIGHT SO THE LASSEN MISS
DAISY'S WE GOT A BUSY DAY WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THINGS SLOW STEADY
WE'RE IN THIS TOGETHER FOR
LOOKING FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR TUNING INTO
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE HEARING. IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE MEDIA LEADER
MOTION BY MAJORITY TO. THE CASE
COUNTER MISTER. CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
ADOPTED CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR MCGUIRE. HI WIRE FIVE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN A
SENATOR. DORADO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG BY WHICH BURGER FI
SENATOR WIENER. BORDER ZERO
FIFTEEN COUNTER CURRENTLY HAS A
FOUR ZERO VOTE FOUR ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
TO ALLOW CENTER WIENER TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON ALL RIGHT. NOW
GIVE ME MOVING INTO OUR SPECIAL
ORDER HEARING- SB NINE SB TEN
IS WELL AS SB FIVE FIVE SIX
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
I'M GOING TO BE TURNING IN THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VERY CAPABLE
VICE CHAIR. TO BE ABLE TO RUN
THE MEETING ON SB NINE PROBABLY
PRESENTING SB NINE ON BEHALF OF
PRESIDENT ATKINS I GIVE THIS AT
THIRTY SECONDS AS WE MAKE THE
TRANSITION. HELLO SIR. THE
PERFECT WHEN READY MISS THURMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR INTO MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE OUT OF
PRISON SENATE BILL NINE ON
BEHALF OF PROTEIN. TODAY FOR
MANY VIEW THIS BILL IS GOING TO
BE FAMILIAR IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE SAW LAST YEAR WAS
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE SOME VERY KEY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE A TO TALK ABOUT HERE TODAY.
ALONG THE SAME LINES- ON BEHALF
OF THE PROTEIN I'D LIKE TO GET
EXCEPT THE TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
MINUTES OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND APPRECIATE THROUGH
THE GREAT WORK BY MR NOW IN THE
ENTIRE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
TEAM SB NINE PROMOTE SMALL
SCALE NEIGHBORHOOD DRIVEN
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR A
HOMEOWNER TO CREATE A DUPLEX.
OR SUBDIVIDING THE EXISTING LOT
IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS UP TO FOUR
UNITS SB NINE REALLY STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL AND
CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PRODUCTION
OF SMALL SCALE DEVELOPMENT THAT
WE SO BADLY NEED TO COMBAT THIS
ACUTE HOUSING CRISIS THAT
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER
TO PROTECT EXISTING TENANTS
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IN COSTA
REQUIREMENTS SB NINE
ESTABLISHES A SPECIFIC LIST OF
QUALIFICATIONS. THAT MUST BE
MET AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
SAFEGUARDS IN THIS CRITICAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION I LIKE TO
WALK THROUGH THOSE NOW. FIRST
OFF HISTORIC AND LANDMARK
DISTRICTS THEIR EXCLUDED FROM
THE BILL. THE COASTAL ACT IT
STILL APPLIES. THE BILL CAN BE
USED ON FARMLANDS FLOOD ZONES
FAULTLINES HABITAT FOR
PROTECTED SPECIES IN OTHER
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
AREAS. IN THE BILL GUARDS
AGAINST SPECULATION AND
GENTRIFICATION IT ALSO IS VERY
FOCUSED ON TENANT PROTECTION.
SB NINE LIMITS INDIVIDUALS FROM
RECEIVING MINISTERIAL LOT
SPLITS ON ADJACENT PARCELS THE
BILL TO PREVENT- INVESTOR
SPECULATION WHICH HAS BEEN A
CONCERN FOR SOME IN THE PRO
TEMAS PROACTIVELY BEEN FOCUSED
ON THAT. AND PROFITEERS FROM
EVICTING OR DISPLACING TENANTS
BY EXCLUDING PROPERTIES WHERE A
TENANT HAS RESIDED IN THE PAST
THREE YEARS. THREE YEARS
MEMBERS. SB NINE NOW ALSO
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
AUTHORITY TO ENACT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION PROVIDES FOR FOUND
FAMILIES TO HAVE MORE OPTIONS
TO BUILD. MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSING AND BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL WEALTH WHICH IS SO
KEY AS WE KNOW FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THEIR HOME IS
THEIR NUMBER ONE INVESTED IT'S
THEIR NUMBER ONE MISTAKE AND
THAT'S WHY INTERGENERATIONAL
WEALTH IS SO IMPORTANT. IT'S A
CRUCIAL TO COMBAT INEQUITY IN
CREATING SOCIAL MOBILITY
ESPECIALLY IN NEIGHBORHOODS OR
OUTDATED ZONING LAWS HAVE
CREATED BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND HAVE LED TO
OVERCROWDING NOW THIS BILL
PROVIDES HOMEOWNERS WITH
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE RENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER WORKING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
TO FIND A HOME IN THEIR PRICE
RANGE OR WHO AY BE LOOKING FOR
THEIR OWN PATH TO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP. BILLS
AND EXPAND OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS
AND FAMILIES ALIKE WE KNOW THAT
THIS HOUSING CRISIS IS AN ISSUE
SO LARGE THAT THERE IS NOT A
SINGLE SOLUTION NO SILVER
BULLET. BUT THAT'S WHY SB NINE
IS PART OF THE SENATE HOUSING
PACKAGE. BUILDING OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL I WANT TO THINK SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR TIME AND COMMITMENT
SENATOR WIENER WHO IS AUTHORED
KEY PIECES OF LEGISLATION IS
HOUSING PACKAGE. AND OF COURSE
TO SENATOR DORADO SENATOR
ARTHUR WAS BEEN WORKING FOR THE
GREATER PART OF TWO YEARS ON
THE HOUSING WORKING GROUP. IN
ON BEHALF OF THE PROTEIN WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
FOR YOUR DEDICATION REALLY
DRIVING HOME SOLUTIONS TO THIS
HOUSING CRISIS. THE PROGRAM IS
TRULY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE BY THE ENTIRE
SENATE ON THIS HOUSING PACKAGE.
THIS PACKAGE MAKES HOUSING MORE
POSSIBLE EVEN WHILE WE CONTINUE
WORKING THROUGH THE NEW
REALITIES IN UNCERTAIN TIMES OF
THIS PANDEMIC. SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT ERIC PHILLIPS IS
COMING WITH US INTO IT WE ALSO
HAVE A LEASE PUKE WITH UNITED
WAY LA ON THE LINE. IN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER VICE CHAIR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
AGAIN VERY GOOD- HAVE OPENED.
DO YOU HAVE MISTER ERIC
PHILLIPS HERE PRESENT.
TESTIFYING SUPPORT YES
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. YOU CAN
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR OF MORNING- MY NAME IS-
PHILLIPS REPRESENTING FACT
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
SPENDING ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO JOANNE SENATE PRO
TEM ATKINS- THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORT OF SB NINE AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
BOTH ON THIS BILL AND THE
SENATE HOUSING PACKAGE IN
GENERAL. AS WE ALL KNOW HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
CONTINUE TO BE AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
CAUSES OF THE HOUSING CRISIS I
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS SOME OF
WHICH CLEANERS HAVE CREATED
QUITE A PART. FOR EXAMPLE UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTIAL AREAS CAN ONLY BE
USED TO CREATE SINGLE FAMILY
DWELLINGS. OBVIOUSLY THIS
LIMITS HOUSING SUPPLY BUT IT
ALSO EXCLUDES LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FROM HOUSING AND
THIS DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. SB NINE
CAN BE PART OF THE EFFORT TO
EXPAND HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT SB NINE DOES NOT PROHIBIT
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES OR ZONING
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT IN
THOSE AREAS PROPERTY OWNERS
MUST ALSO BE ALLOWED TO CREATE
SMALL MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
OPTIONS. SB NINE CREATE A BY
RIGHT MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR THE CREATION OF TWO
TO FOUR HOMES IN SINGLE FAMILY
DOLLAR. IT ALLOWS PARCEL MAPS
THEY CREATE TWO LOTS FROM ONE
AND PERMITS THEM TO HOMES PER
LOCK. SHE LIVES WITH TWO HOMES
AT EACH DATA SET AB YOU LAWS
ALREADY ALLOW UP TO THREE UNITS
PER LOT SO THIS IS ONLY AN
INCREMENTAL CHANGE IN INTENSITY
BUT THE PARCEL MAP PROVISIONS.
ALLOW NEW HOMES TO BE SOLD
WHICH CAN HELP CREATE HOME
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES BUT ARE
NOT ALWAYS AVAILABLE UNDER
OTHER HOUSING. PRODUCTION AND
STREAMLINING BILLS. I DON'T
ALTHOUGH THE APPROVAL IS IN.
THE MAJORITY OBJECTIVE PLANNING
STANDARDS WILL CONTINUE TO
APPLY TO NEW DEVELOPMENT SB
NINE EVEN INCLUDES A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THE ADOPTION OF
NEW IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS.
AND THIS APPROACH WILL HELP
BALANCE STATE AND LOCAL
INTEREST. SB NINE DEFINES
MINIMUM PERFORMANCE TARGETS
THAT APPLY STATEWIDE BUT IT
LEAVES ROOM FOR LOCAL PLANNERS
TO DEFINE AND APPLY CONTEXT
SPECIFIC STANDARDS FOR THOSE
TWO TO FOUR UNITS PER LOT.
FINALLY IN CONCLUSION OUR HOPE
IS THAT INCREASING HOUSING
CHOICE AND SINGLE FAMILY ZONES
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES MORE INCLUSIVE. BUT
THIS CANNOT COME AT THE COST OF
DESTABILISING EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT IS WHY WE
SUPPORT THE BILLS SEEK GUARDS
TO PREVENT THE LOSS OF EXISTING
HELPING AND DISPLACEMENT OF
VULNERABLE TENANTS- I THINK
AGAIN WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
SB NINE. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING. WE ALSO HAVE
LISA BLAKE THE UNITED WAY LOS
ANGELES. LISA ARE YOU ON. Q.
HERE. I AM THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR AND I WANNA THANK ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MY NAME IS THE LEAST
AND THE PRESIDENT CEO OF UNITED
WAY OF GREATER LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING A CONSTITUENCY OF
TEN MILLION PEOPLE WE ARE HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT IN
SB NINE WE KNOW THAT LAND USE
POLICY THAT SPECIALLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE DRIVEN
RACIAL RACIAL SEGREGATION OF
WEALTH DISPARITIES FOR DECADES.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM OUR DEEP
PARKING HOME WHAT DOES THAT OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS DRIVING OUR
HOMELESS CRISIS THANK YOU MEANS
THE COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING THAT
HURDLE WE BELIEVE THAT SB NINE
WILL HELP TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HOUSING ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED AND
HAVE EXCLUDED BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE DRIVEN THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS AND BLACK AND BROWN
HOUSEHOLD. WE FEEL THAT SB NINE
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
ABSOLUTE MENTIONED AND
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL BUT
ALSO CREATING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SMALL SCALE NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT BENEFITS NOT ONLY
THE BROADER COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
OUR WORKERS WHO ARE GETTING
PUSHED OUT OF THE REGION IN
TERMS OF BEING CLOSE TO THEIR
JOBS WE KNOW THAT SB NINE WILL
NOT SOLVE OUR FORCING OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
HUNDRED SANDWICH AND WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD
ON ALL FRONTS FROM INCREASING
RUNNER PROTECTION. TO
INCREASING PUBLIC FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO TOUCH DIED HOUSING
FOR WORKING AND MIDDLE INCOME
WORKERS WE ARE PROUD TO BE
WORKING ON THOSE ISSUES WITH
MANY OF YOU ON THAT COMMITTEE
UNITED WAY OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES TRANSLATORS WHO ARE
WILLING TO REJECT THE STATUS
QUO AND ENVISION A FUTURE WHERE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA HAS
TAKEN STABLE HOME WITH THE
ABILITY OF PRIDE WE ALSO WANTED
BANG SENATE PRO TEM ACTION FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE TO ENERGY
THE BILL AND FOR EACH OF YOU
HIS WILLING. TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY AND THE FUTURE AND WE ARE
CHEN I'D TO DAY THANK SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TRUST. AND
WE WILL I'LL- OTHER PEOPLE TO
IN NOW YOU HAVE THE NUMBER
EIGHT NINE NINE TWO CHAU. AB
ONE TWO AND YOU CAN GO INTO G.
MINOR. ASKED FOR PEOPLE FELT
GALLAGHER THE OUTPUT TO A
ANYONE IN FOR TWO OH THREE.
SPORT AND SO NINE AND. TWENTY
FOUR. ANYWAY IN TWENTY FORTY.
NO ONE PERSON HERE TO TESTIFY.
NO SO WE WILL THEN GO THE LAW.
WORK. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE THAT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN
Q. OR TRYING TO ARRIVE IN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER AFTER
WALKER WITH NOTHING AND ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE BOARD OF.
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
RIGHT TO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
SPEAKING SUPPORT IN THE WHICH
IS THE MORNING CARE BY STERN OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAM WITH CAL.
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VITAL AND SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS OCCUR I'M CALLING TO
REPRESENT MEMBERS OF SAN CRUZ
YOU. AS WELL AS CRUZ FOR.
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS. NINE
THANK YOU READY TO SIX. PLEASE
CALL. HOLLY FOR MANY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC.
REPRESENTING AND ALL HIGH AND
FORTY THE BILL TODAY INCLUDING
HER HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. CAN
BE PART ACROSS THE THAT
COALITION CAL HISPANIC OF THE
BAY AREA COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING IN THE AT THIS. THE
HOUSING ACTION COUPLE AND JAY
PARK CALLING THE PARTY THAT TO
LOOK. UP IF YOU JUST A MOMENT
HAVE AN HERE MISTER AT THE END
OF ROOM FORTY TWO THREE TO.
MISTER PRAYER WILL YOU PROCEED
AS FAR THAT'S THAT'S MY
BUSINESS FOR BUT- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLY CHAMBER COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT BACK TO
THE. BEHALF OF WEST SIDE FOR
EVERYONE- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS JORDAN
GRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
SOME IN SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE. THANK YOU RIGHT TWO OR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL NAME IS
THE BEGINNING I LEAVING YOU
CITY AND THEN WITH A CRAPPIE
ONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
TWENTY SO PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO
ARE CHAIR AND MEMBER OF EMAIL
HEIGHTS REPRESENTING THE CAL
CAN LANDS TRUCK NETWORK WITH US
AND TO AND WE DEEPLY THINK THAT
TEMPORE FOR CAN THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST MODEL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
THIRTY SIX FILL OUT. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS JANET
PATTON FROM COULD CALLING AND
SUPPOSED TO BE. THANK YOU TO
OUR THREE GO AHEAD. ACOSTA
CALLING IN FROM CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWO OR
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DO THE
CORN FROM- OAKLAND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE BROKEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU. THANK YOU I WON
FIFTY THREE GO AHEAD. BY ONE
FIVE ONE CALL. HELLO THIS IS
RAMAN NOODLES A POWER OUTPUT.
HELLO THIS IS OUR OWN HARMON IN
ST BERNARD OF THE SENATE
DISTRICT REPRESENTING URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KARLEY
ATLEE AMERICANN COLLEGE GRAD
OUT OF LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
BEAT NINE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI ALISON- PART OF STORY ON THE
FRONT LINE AND HOW ALL WORKS
HARD FORWARD IN WHAT ANGELA
THAT. IT THE FOR ITS JOB AT THE
MIND YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. MATTHEW
LEWIS I AM A SINGLE HOME ON IN
ROCK SOUTH PARK NOW BURKE CA
BUT I CALLING IN STRONG. SB
THANK YOU RYAN TO- OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING THE
GROUP CALLING ABOUT THE CAN DMV
FROM ZAMBIA. BUCKLING SUPPORT
OF NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE EIGHTY FIVE THREE GO AHEAD.
BY EIGHT FIVE PLEASE CALL. WELL
AS IS EVANS OKAY FROM START TO
CAL IN SUPPORT OF AS BEING.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE EIGHT
PLEASE CALL. I IS RICHA SO
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF ESPINO. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THREE CALL. HI THIS
IS ALL I'M FROM THE RALLY.
CALLING ON THE OF INTER
GAMBIANS SUPPORT OF AT NINE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO TWENTY
THREE PLEASE CALL. HI MY NAME
IS EBONY DINNER I'M NOT AND THE
THIRTY OF AUSTIN AND I SO SB
NINE. SHE SH THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE EIGHT NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MR DAY CALLING ON
BEHALF THE LOWER HERE DANCE
SUPPORTER ESPINO THANK TO
PROTECT TO BRING A FORWARD.
THANK YOU RIGHT WHEN I GROUP
FILL OUT. MY NAME IS ARE BOUGHT
AND CALLING FOR BOSTON ON OF AT
THE LA AND CALLING IN ORDER WE
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
RIGHT NOW FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS AMARAL CALLING FROM
YOU CAN. AND I'M THE HAPPEN
COMMUNITY WERE. OR SHE SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE MONTHS GET MORNING.
ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL INTO COLLEGE TERRACE
AND ALLOWED SO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAVID WALKER NUMBER OF SOUTH
STADIUM BEING BEING STRONG
SUPPORT. SB. NINE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY ONE TRAINS GLAD.
COMPORT THE STATE EVERYONE I
ENJOY REPORT YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING MARK THE
CALIFORNIA BE. ARE STRONG
SUPPORT PRESS NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
STEVE MUSHROOM I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M WITHOUT SAID
FLOORED AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROSS
BUCKLEY ON CASTLE SACRAMENTO
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG
INSTRUCTS FOR ABOUT. THREE
NINE. THANK YOU RYAN TO FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALFORD TO AND IN
BERKELEY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS M. PAULSON
FROM LOCAL HOMEOWNER IN LOS
ALTOS STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE PHILADELPHIA CRANE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME AND THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU READY TO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING YOUR
NAME ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING INCOME SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT INTO FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
SAN DIEGO AMERICA GLORIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS THE NIGHT WITH
ABUNDANT HOUSING LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHARLATANS SAN
FRANCISCO YOU MARC ON THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE LONG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND WE
THANK ALL OF YOU WHO TESTIFIED
I KNOW THE SERVICE IS FREE FOR
BUT WE HAVE A VERY LIKE YOUR
GENDER. SENSITISATION BEING A
LITTLE BIT SHORTER ON OUR-
REMARKS. THE OPERATOR COULD YOU
NOW CALL FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT BE
IN OPPOSITION. THE LEAD IN THE
NATIONALLY WITH UPS. WE DIDN'T
DO THAT THE YES WE HAVE TO
WITNESS ARE BUT IN UP. IS THAT.
SO NOT. IT'S NOT NO LIKE NO
WITNESSES SO A LOT PER AND THE
FALL FOR OPPOSITE. CALLING AND
ALL DOES TWENTY TWO HAVE AN
TWENTY FOUR. AND WE HAVE NONE
IN. TOTAL TWENTY FOUR AND. TWO
THREE. IN NEW YORK. NO I DON'T
THE IN THE BACK OF ARE YOU A
OPPOSITION MA'AM. NO OKAY. WE
HAVE NOBODY IN OPPOSITION THAT
OKAY SO. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU IF WISH TO
SPEAK AFTER OF S. B. NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE NOW AND THEN
THE AT TIME. THE THIS IS. AND
WE HAVE A SIX IN Q. FOUR TWO AT
SIX REMINDER HAVE COULD BE VERY
JUST IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND
STATE FOR WE HAVE A TWENTY FIVE
MINUTE LET ON THE SEC. AS WE
HAVE ON. SUPPORT SIDE WELL.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS BEING
HATCHING SAP READY FOR POLICY
GROUP- CALLING IN ON. I'LL BE
OF FOSTER'S THE CITY OF PALM
THE CITY USED AVAIL THE CITY.
THANK AND WE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY
IN Q. IT OR JUST BE ONE MORE
FOR OUR NEXT Y. RIGHT EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO. GOOD MORNING MR
VICE MISTER AND MEMBERS THE
REST I MEAN DOES ON BEHALF OF
THE TRI VALLEY THE DUBLIN
LIVERMORE PLUG TANTAMOUNT AND
THAT OF DOWN. AS WELL AS THE
CITY'S APOLLO ALTO- LAGUNA
BEACH AND AGORA AND RESP OF THE
TO BILL THANK YOU. SOME OF YOU
WHO ARE IN QUEUE COULD THE-
COLLAB. IN SOME WAY PUT
POSSIBLE TO JUST TO JOINT
ANNOUNCE FOR OF THE ONE ONE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE KIND WITH
THAT MANY IN THE QUEUE I'M
AFRAID TO DO IT ALL IN TWENTY
FIVE MINUTES. YOU YEAH THE
WE'LL DO THE BEST WE CAN FIX
PER SE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WILL BE DUMB ENOUGH TO-
A MEMBER OF THE ALLIANCE FOR A
BETTER BRENT WHAT WITH FOURTEEN
HUNDRED CONTE CONTRA COSTA
RESIDENTS AND STRONG OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY ONE NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
MAINTAINING STAFF AND- ON
BEHALF OF UNITED ASSEMBLY
THEY'LL UNITED NEIGHBORS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE WE ARE ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW TWENTY
RENTALS FROM CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CANDLES FROM
CITY OF LAFAYETTE AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA LINES OF LOCAL
ELECTED WE ARE WE ARE ALL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORE MATURE MEMBERS
CITIES AROUND THE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE HAVE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS MATTER. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KAREN OBEYED IN PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA TO ORGANIZATIONS ONE
IS GREAT LAWN AVENUE NEIGHBORS
FOR QUALITY OF LIFE THE SECOND
IS YET TO BACKYARD TREES TO
COMBAT GLOBAL WARMING AND AIR
POLLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARE ABOUT THE BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF SAN MARCOS AND
BURBANK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND ON BEHALF OF THE BRAND
COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCILMEMBERS WHAT THE HELL
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE OKAY
REPRESENTING BRANCHES SANTA
MARGARITA COUNCIL ON THE THREE
FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
OPPOSITION AT THE NINE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SUSAN KIRSCH FROM CATALYST
GOING. TO FEDERAL NOT. GET
AFFILIATE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
CITIES FROM CAN. HOW AND YOU
KNOW NEIGHBOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
PERISHABLE. A HUNDRED CLIENTS A
REALTOR WHO'S AMERICAN DREAM IS
GOING TO BE RUINED. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE
FLAT. HELLO CHRISTY CORALINE
AND I'M WITH CATALYST IN UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE WANT TO STATE THAT
IS BACKING ASIAN IMPORT FACED
WITH THE WILDFIRE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHT NINE
PLEASE CALL. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS MARTY KAMDEN FROM FAMILY AND
HOME SAN JOSE DISTRICT FIFTEEN
AND- UNITED PAPER TO LOCAL FOR
AND I AM STRONGLY OF WE ARE
FROM OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONCE NINE PLEASED
AHEAD. YEAH THE LOWER OF
MONTGOMERY- WITH YOU KNOW THEY
WERE THAT LOCAL CAL. AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSE TO SENATE BILL
AND I WAS I IN DID THIRTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YET
LIGHT WANT TO CALL. THIS IS
RECALL WITH LIVABLE CAL- SB
NINE IS NOT SOLVED THE
AFFORDABILITY. AND WILL
DISPLACE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
IT IS NOT A DUPLEX BILL SIX
UNITS BY RIGHT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. BY NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
MY NAME IS NOT A FRIEDMAN I'M A
HOMEOWNER- IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO DELETED
WITH UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND I DO NOT
THINK THAT SB NINE IS A
SOLUTION TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CARLOS OF IDEA AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARCHITECT AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PEOPLE OF LONG
BEACH I STRONGLY OPPOSE HAS
BEEN AYE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE ROOT PROBLEM OF
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
OR THE RACIAL DISPARITY OF
PARKS AND OPEN SPACE CREATED BY
INCREASED DENSITY. THANK YOU.
OUR THANK YOU BYE ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER HOLDEN I AM A
MEMBER OF A POLITICAL
CALIFORNIA- UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND OF THE MANGAN PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I AM
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB NINE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
STACY CELINTA I'M REPRESENTING
CANYON AND WE ARE A MEMBER OF
THE UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M HERE IN BRING YOUR ONLINE
BURBANK CITY COUNCIL AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE ALREADY
OUR NAY OUR RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUNG FAMILIES
RESIDENTS OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME CANNOT COMPETE WITH
INVESTOR CASH OFFERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
I'M SORRY MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
HENRY AND I AM A HOMEOWNER IN
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING ST LAFAYETTE I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA. AND AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND I AM VERY ME VERY
MUCH STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE
AND S. B. TEN. H. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TRYING TO THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BRANDON
BURKE AND I OPPOSE AS BEING
NINE IT DOES NOTHING FOR RACIAL
EQUALITY IT SOLD AT MARKET
RATE. AND- IT TAKES AWAY THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND-
PRESIDENTIAL WHAT WHAT THE
THIRTY HERE WHAT DO JONES OUT
THERE WORKING FOR EVERY DAY HIS
OWN HOME AND ALL A SUDDEN HE'S
GOING TO HAVE AN APARTMENT
BUILDING NEXT DOOR TO SEE WHAT
HE'S PAYING OFF AND HOME- JUST
AND TENDER TO APPLE TAKE YOUR
POSITION YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE TWENTY FIVE GO OUT. TWO
FIVE IS GOING. IF YOU'RE AND
YOU. PLEASE ANSWER QUICKLY IF
YOU'RE A Q. Q. DELAY THEN
YOU'RE TO HER SOMEBODY THE
OTHER WE HAVE A LIVE TIME
PLEASE PLEASE TELL RIGHT ON.
RIGHT TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
CALL AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
BRENDA DOMAIN NUMBER I
REPRESENT FAMILIES AND HOMES
JOSE AND I'M SENATE FIFTEEN AND
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU ARE INTO FIVE PLEASE AHEAD.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD. YES HELLO.
YES GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MY AND
I AM IN TO BE A C. CA AND I'M
OF. THANK YOU RYAN TO SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARIA CAL I'M SURE OAKS HOME
THE BILL. A MEMBER AND FOUNDER
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE IT IS AND
BIG AND WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
OF THE FIVE THE BEAUTY BEING A-
AND WE- MA'AM WE HONOR YOU
RIGHT. ONE SORRY RIGHT ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
ONE THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TURKISH FROM PEDDLING CAL. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL PROVE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WILL JUST GO. RIGHT OF THE
SINGLES. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE FIFTIES POINT GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING HAPPY EARTH DAY.
BY MOTHER NATURE OKAY WILL
SUSTAIN LAW OUR AND WE- OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M TWO THIRTY TWO GO OUT. HI
THIS IS IBM OUT OF HIM- IN MY
ANGELES LIVE CALIFORNIA AND YOU
NEGRO AND THE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO ONE CALL. YEAH THIS IS
TERRY ON PLAN COMMISSIONER
TURKEY. TOGA RODILLA IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL SB NINE.
IT'S GOING TO DOUBLE THE PRICE
OF HOUSE. BECAUSE WITH MAIN
KERR HOW IS A OF THE THAT IT'S
ON THE END OF. THANK YOU FOR A
TEST Q. RIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN
TO EIGHTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. HI
YOU ON ANY DAY WAS ANGELES WITH
FRANKEN OKAY TO MAYBE UNLIVABLE
CAL WE ARE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED
TO WE HAVE AN HOW CRISIS THIS
IS NOT ADDRESS WHAT'S. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ON THIRTY SO
THREE GO OUT. HI WE WANT I'VE
GOTTEN NUMBER IT'S OKAY MOVE ON.
TRYING TO ALL THREE PLEASE GO
OUT. HI THIS IS VALERIE FROM TO
LAWCENTER AREA AND STRAW OUT
THE THERE S NO FOR HOW STOCK
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
YOU TO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ON E. L. O. D.
CHAU AYE CURRENT LIVE IN- SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA ON THE BAND AND
I AM IN. SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE
HAVE A AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS AND IT ABSOLUTELY. THAT
WE TAKE. ALL EARNERS. STEPS IN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MY GRANDMA FROM THIS
HOUSE EIGHT YES ONLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE IS BEING NINE THESE.
THAT NEW POWER HE SENDING YET
TYPE OF BUSINESS. RIGHT AWAY
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIRELIGHT IS HERO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS PETER GROUP
FROM THE SAN JOSE I'M OPPOSED
TO S. B. NINE I DON'T THINK THE
STATE SHOULD BE OVERRIDING
LOCAL ZONING. THANK YOU I'M TO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I'M GLAD SHERMAN OAKS
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS OPPOSED TO SB
NINE. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
SURELY LOW WITH IN DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH GROUP'S
CATALYST LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
CALLIE UNITE MEMBERS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEP ACROSS AND I REPRESENT
BERKELEY TOGETHER AN
ORGANIZATION THE BERKELEY
TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK
YOU RIGHT NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES THIS IS DEBBIE PRICE
BUT KILLS TWO THOUSAND FRIENDS
OF THE HILLS OF LOS ALTOS HILLS
ACCOUNT LOS ALTOS HILLS AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA WE VERY MUCH OPPOSED
SB NINE AND TEN. THANK A SECOND
CONSOLIDATING LINES THOSE
POSITIONS AND WE'D ONLY TEN
MORE MINUTES SO KEEP IN MIND
THOSE WHO WERE WAY FURTHER DOWN
IN THE QUEUE IF YOU DON'T GET
ON TODAY THIS BILL WILL HAVE
OTHER COMMITTEES TO BE HEARD
AND IN THE FUTURE AND YOU WILL
HAVE THAT ALL THE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES PLEASE PROCEED.
OPERATOR THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
TERRY DIPPEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LOS YOUR GUINNESS MALIBU
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS IN
SENATE DISTRICT. TWENTY SEVEN
AND WE OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOHN WELBORN
REPRESENTING THE WINDSOR SQUARE
IS SO SEE ASIAN AND NINETY SIX
YEAR OLD ASSOCIATION SPLIT
BETWEEN- SENATE-DISTRICT TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY SIX AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OVERLOOK LEAD
FROM INSIDE BUILDING LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL BECAUSE OF THE DAMAGE
IT WILL DO TO QUALITY OF LIFE
IN MY CITY AND BECAUSE LAND USE
DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE INTO TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ARTURO RECALL
REPRESENTING RESIDENTS CROSS
CITY SANA MONICA AND THE WEST
TO LOOK LIKE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION BOTH AFFILIATES OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IS SHAUN
BAILES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BELLAIRE ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF OUR TWO THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS
IN FIFTY FIVE A STUDENT VERY
POLITICALLY ACTIVE RESIDENTS
WERE STAUNCHLY OPPOSED SB NINE
APPLICATION THEY'LL FIGHT IN
HIGH FIRE SEVERITY DON'T
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS LINDA
GONZALEZ HOMEOWNER IN
SACRAMENTO ELMHURST
NEIGHBORHOOD AND I AND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF BOTH SB
NINE SB TEN I BELIEVE THEY ARE
NOT SOLUTIONS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ARE INSTEAD DRIVEN
AN INVESTOR DRIVEN BILLS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMY GOODMAN
THANK REPRESENTING OUR FRIDAY
IN LOS ANGELES PUT BETWEEN
SENATE DISTRICTS TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY FIVE THERE ARE ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PAUL GAINES OF LONG
BEACH DECIDE VOICE IN SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY THREE AND
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY DON'T
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
ZERO TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CALIFORNIA. MONTERO
FOUNDER OF LATINO ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WITH
MEMBERS IN THE FOLLOWING CITIES
COUNTY EAST LOS ANGELES
HUNTINGTON PARK MONTEBELLO
TORRANCE INCLUDE HERE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME FIVE MINUTES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAN WE
SELL AND I AM IN SENATE
DISTRICT FIFTEEN REPRESENTING
THE MAJORITY OF HOMEOWNERS AND
COMMON VALLEY AND SAN JOSE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE BOTH NUMBER
NINE AND TEN PLEASE DON'T RUIN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS- FAMILY HOME.
TO MAKE PROFIT FOR DEVELOPERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHRIS LONGER TENANTS
FROM EAST SIDE BOYS FROM LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE F THE
DAMAGE IT WILL DO TO THE
QUALITY OF LIFE IN MY CITY THAT
BECAUSE LAND USE DECISIONS
SHOULD BE MADE ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS WALTER
DOMINGUEZ SOUTH COURT THEY
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION IN THE
MID WILSHIRE DISTRICT AND
SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY SIX AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE- SB NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HOLLY
OSBORNE I'M A REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER IN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT OF UNITED
OF REDONDO BEACH MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS. BY STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE THANK. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
RASMUSSEN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF BURTON VALLEY NEIGHBORHOODS
GROUP FOR BEGINNING A THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AND
DEPORTABLE AREA OF LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL ANALYST FOR
THE WEALTHIEST HOMEOWNERS
COUNCIL WHICH IS REPRESENTING
FIFTY HOMEOWNERS GROUPS
THROUGHOUT LAFAYETTE. AND WE
ALSO- IMMUNITY WITH C. UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE MIND OKAY WE
HAVE FIVE ONE MILLION. NINE ONE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DORIS I RESIDE IN PALO ALTO
CALIFORNIA I'M A MEMBER OF
CALAIS LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS OR NOT TO
FOLLOW THE EMBARCADERO
INSTITUTE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND IT WILL HURT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LOWERS
OKAY SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS AND
IT- VIOLATE LOCAL LAND USE.
ZONING THANK. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
BURNES ON THE MONITOR THIRTY
ASIAN SENATE-DISTRICT NINETEEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO
PROVIDE EQUAL PROTECTION HIGH
FIRE HELLO FIVE PRODUCTION AN
PROVIDE FOR AFFORDABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE IN ITS
CURRENT FORM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY TO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PRETTY SURE MEMBERS
INJURED ANTS WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI- IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ARE YOU
TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS TRICIA CRANE I'M
CHAIR OF NORTH EAST NEIGHBOURS
OF SANTA MONICA OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR CITY COUNCIL UNANIMOUSLY
OPPOSED SB NINE AS AN ASSAULT
ON LOCAL CONTROL OVER OUR SONY.
TV DOES A GOOD JOB OF
GENERATING HOUSING WE DO NOT
NEED TO BE NINE. THANK YOU ARE
YOU ONE TIME TREES GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS A SOUGHT TO
MOTIONS I'M WITH THE HYDE PARK
ORGANIZATIONAL PARTNERSHIP FOR
EMPOWERMENT THE COMMUNITY THAT
IS OVER 50% BLACK AT THIS TIME
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS A MAJOR
CONCERN BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS ALREADY ALLOWING OVER
FLOOD OF HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT IS NOT
AFFORDABLE AND WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
OWN HOMES AND AT THE CURRENT
RATE MARKET RATE HOUSING THIS
WHAT WERE WE NEED TO ASK. ANY
UNDERSTAND YOU OKAY. THANK YOU
GO ON A- THANK YOU READY TO SEE
EIGHT PLEASE CALL. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES INDEED
FEINBERG CALLING IN THE SANTA
BARBARA AREA AND I AM OPPOSED
TO SENATE BILL NINE I DO NOT
BELIEVE IT ACTUALLY. THANK YOU
I NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT'S ME HI THIS IS LAURIE
ANGEL I'M IN LONG BEACH A
MEMBER OF LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND ON BEHALF OF MY
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION WITH
OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED HOMES.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL WE
HAVE. THANK YOU I'M TO SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
JOSEPH OUR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND MANY MORE WILL
INFRASTRUCTURE BE MULTIPLIED BY
SIX FOR THAT NEW POPULATION
WHERE WE DEVELOPERS BE WHEN OUR
SEWERS EXPLODER SINCE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS DECLARED A DROUGHT
WHEN WE RUN OUT OF WATER PLEASE
READ THE BILLS I DARE YOU TO
FIND THE WORD OF. THANK YOU
OVER TO ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
DOUGLAS CASE OF FORMER CITY
COUNCIL CANDIDATE AND CURRENT
TOGA I'M REPRESENTING LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB NINE AND TEN ESPECIALLY.
THANK YOU OVER THE LINE TO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OH MY APOLOGIES I'M ACTUALLY
CALLING IN SUPPORT- SORRY I'M
IN THE WRONG HERE MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN I'M CALLING FROM PALO
ALTO- ON BEHALF OF CONTENT BUT
FOR EVERYONE CAN BE ACTION IN
TERMS COURT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE OR MORE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
STUART IN THE FERNANDO VALLEY
I'M A MEMBER OF THE VOCAL
CALIFORNIA I'M ON THE BOARD
ANGELENOS FOR TREES THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IS A HEAT
ISLAND AND THE QUADRUPLING AND
SIX TO CLING SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES INTO SMALL UNITS IS GOING
TO BE. AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER. SURE. YOUR EDITORIAL
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
MY NAME IT'S ABOUT THE LAB WITH
THEM ON THE PHONE AT THEIR
RANCH YEAH I'M CALLING
OPPOSITION SB NINE AND TEN.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BOY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF REDONDO
BEACH IN OPPOSITION. THANK
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT JIM Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR AND THANK YOU ALL
OF YOU WHO HAVE CALLED IN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THE LIMITATIONS OF OUR TIME.
WE WILL NOW PROCEED WITH THE
HEARING AND THE FENDER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GIVE A CALL FOR
CENTER ADVERSE. WE GET- YEAH
THAT'S TAKEN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND OUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF OUR MEMBERS. VETR DORADO. IF
I GOT EMOTIONAL OKAY THE NUMBER
IS MOVE AND I I'M I'M ASKING
ABOUT WHAT OKAY I GOT A SERIES
QUESTIONS. ON BEHALF OF THIS
MEASURE- THE SURE. ARE THERE
WANT TO CLARIFY YOU KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A LONG DISCUSSION AS
YOU EXPRESSED IN YOUR OPENING
OFF ON THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS AND
OUR EFFORTS TO BUILD HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE DONE A LOT OF
THINGS NOW A WITH WITH ISSUES
OF ON ADAPTIVE RE USE LISTENER
KERR HEROES. BILL AND ALMOST
OTHER THING IN THE KNOW I WORK
ON THE IDEA OF BUILDING HOMES.
DEALING WITH THE. RICH PART OF
OUR AND TRYING BUILD MORE HOMES
THIS IS A LAW OF IT IN THAT
REGARD BUT I'VE A LOT QUESTION
IF I CAN JUST SURE. BECAUSE
I'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF ACTIVITY
FROM THE COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT THAT ARE QUITE
CONCERNED AND THE POINT ABOUT
AMBIGUITY SO I JUST YOU KNOW
YOU SAID THIS AN OPENING BUT IF
I COULD MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST
MAKE SOME CLARIFICATIONS ONE.
HISTORIC OVER LOSING OVERLAYS
OWNS ARE EXEMPT IS THAT A
CORRECT STATEMENT. MARK ZONES
IN LANDMARK DISTRICTS ARE
EXEMPT OKAY THANK YOU THAT WAS
SOMETHING IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT PORT SECOND. FROM
THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT ARE
RECEIVED FROM FOLKS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT WERE CONCERNED
THAT THERE WAS AMBIGUITY IN
THIS MEASURE THAT ALTHOUGH IT
WAS REPRESENTED ONLY LIMITED
FOR THAT IN FACT THERE COULD BE
EIGHT UNITS THERE WAS SOME
EXPERTS THAT WERE OPINING IN MY
UNDERSTANDING IF IT'S CORRECT.
THAT THE LANGUAGE THE
AMENDMENTS I SAW HERE CHANGE IT
AND MAKE IT CLEAR EXPLICIT THAT
THERE CANNOT BE MORE THAN FOUR
UNITS IS THAT FAIR TO SAY.
YOU'RE 1100% CORRECT AND THEN
CONSIDER BEEN PRESENTED MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THERE CAN BE NO MORE
THAN FOUR UNITS ON ONE- WILL
DEPART ON A SPLIT ESTATE ONLY
GET TO THOSE QUESTIONS
AGGRESSORS FOR SECOND NEXT
QUESTION. UNDER OUR CURRENT
EIGHTY YOU LAW RIGHT THE
CURRENT LAW IF NOTHING CHANGED
TODAY IN SINGLE FAMILY ZONES.
THE REALITY IS WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL IN A SINGLE FAMILY
LOT COULD BUILD A JUNIOR EIGHTY
YOU WHICH WOULD ATTACHED TO
THEIR HOME. AND THE SECOND
EIGHTY YOU THAT THEY COULD
BUILD A RADIO SEPARATE EIGHTY
YOU TAKE A GARAGE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WAS DETACHED FROM THE
HOUSE AND THEN YOU UNDER
CURRENT LAW. MY UNDERSTANDING I
WANT CLARIFICATION FOR THIS FOR
THE RECORD THAT YOU HAVE THREE
UNITS CORRECT. AT A PARTICULAR
PARTIAL. CHECK GREATLY. OKAY
AND NOW WHAT DONE IS RES OF THE
HOMEWORK HERE IS YOU SHOULD BE
SUBSTANTIALLY. MERYL THIS
EARLIER DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD
IN SB FIFTY AND ALL THOSE OTHER
ISSUES SO BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS EXPANDING FROM
THREE TO FOUR CORRECT. 101%
CORRECT IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IF I UNDERSTAND THIS ALL THE
AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL THAT
THERE ARE BASICALLY THREE
CHANGES IN PARTICULAR THREE
PARTICULAR CHANGE ON A MAKES A
COUPLE OF THE CHANGES. IN THIS
MEASURE AS IT NOW HAS BEEN
AMENDED AND DISCUSSED AND
AMENDED DISCUSSION AMENDED
DISCUSSED AS TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY HE'S ONE. WE GO FROM
THREE TO FOUR HONOR SKIRT
CURRENT LOT TO. THAT THE LOT
CAN BE LOT SPLIT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT BEFORE BY RIGHT
THAT HE COULD HAVE A LOT SPLIT
AS LONG AS YOU MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND THREE. SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS CONFORM TO THE
EIGHTY YOU SET BACK
REQUIREMENTS TO FOUR FEET
BECAUSE IN MY COMMUNITIES I
HAVE FIVE ON THE SIDE AND
FIFTEEN IN THE FRONT BUT YOU
CAN GO TO FOR SO IT'S IN THE
SIDE CHICK IT'S REDUCED BY ONE
FOOT THOSE ARE. THE PRINCIPLE
CHANGES IN ADDITION THE THING
THAT PORTANTINO CENTER
PORTANTINO AND I WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT I BELIEVE HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED HERE. IS THIS
CORPORATIZATION THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY WAS MENTIONED IN
THE- THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
LIKE WELL TO QUOTE DOWN CAN'T.
YOU CANNOT CHANGE THE GOOD THE
COSTS ARE COULD NOT COME AT THE
COST OF DESTABILISING EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS SO THE CONCERN
AND A COUPLE OF THE OPPONENTS I
LISTENED TO THE- OPPOSITION.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
DEVELOPERS CORPORATE TIES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THAT I READ
HERE I COULD GO TO THE
CITATION. THAT THE PERSON HAS
TO OWN ONE OF THE PROPERTIES.
HAVE TO BE OWNER OCCUPIED IS
THAT CORRECT. THE NEW
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE. A COUNCIL
OR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO PUT
AN OWNERSHIP CLAUSE IN
ORDINANCE INTO PLACE YOUR 100%
CORRECT OKAY AND THEN IN
ADDITION. THE OTHER ISSUE WAS
WHEN WE LOOKED AT S. B. FIFTY
THAT I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED. LAST
YEAR. ON THE CITY OF SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND WHICH DOES
INCLUDE YOUR COMMUNITIES BUT
CERTAINLY INCLUDES THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
SENATOR ALSO REPRESENTS. YOU
COULD HAVE HAD IF YOU'RE WITHIN
A QUARTER OF A MILE OF THE
MAJOR TRANSIT STOP A FIFTY FIVE
FOOT FOUR STORIES TO FIVE
STORAGE UNIT. WHICH IS NO
LONGER THE CASE UNDER THIS BILL
IS THAT FAIR TOSAY. TO SAY AND
IT'S NOT JUST A MAJOR
TRANSISTOR UNDER SB FIFTY IT
WAS ALSO GOING TO BE A BUS STOP
ORIGINALLY SO. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE IS NO
LINK TO ANY TRANSIT IN THIS
BILL. OKAY A COUPLE MORE
APOLOGIST SO MUCH WITH THIS IS
IT REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT I DON'T
SPEND MUCH TIME ON THE STUFF.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME ON THESE
ISSUES. SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
POWER IN THIS TO THIS ISSUE
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING AND
WE'VE DEALT WITH THIS ON SO
MANY ISSUES OVER THE YEARS I
WAS ASKING THE NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL ONCE YOU SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL. BUT I DO ACCEPT THEIR
CERTAIN ISSUES OF STATEWIDE
CONCERN YOU CAN'T DISCRIMINATE
LOCALLY AND SAY WELL. I'M NOT
GOING TO THAT AND WE'VE HAD
THESE ISSUES DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES HAVE RESPONDED TO
IT DIFFERENTLY WE'RE TRYING TO
MEET HOUSING REQUIREMENTS. AND
WE SET UP A HOUSING ELEMENT
MANY DECADES AGO AND IT HASN'T
WORKED VERY WELL. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THIS THE
GOVERNOR CAME UP WITH AN IDEA
IS WE'RE GONNA TAKE YOUR
TRANSIT FUNDS IF YOU DON'T MEET
OR WORK AT ALL. GREAT ABILITY
FOR A COURT TO CREATE AN ORDER
WE'VE BEEN DEBATING. HOW TO WE
QUITE A WE DEAL WITH THIS
DYNAMIC BETWEEN TRYING TO
CREATE HOUSING WHICH IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO STATE. AND THE
IMPORTANT POWER OF THE LOCALS.
TO ME WHEN I WHEN I LOOK AT
THIS THING THE BIG ISSUE THAT.
I SEE REMAINING. IN TERMS OF
THAT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THERE IS.
FROM GUY. IN THIS THING. AND
BUT BUT FOR ME IT'S- BUT WHAT I
FIND IN THE POINT WAS RAISED
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE STILL
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION ON
THIS. IS THE ISSUE OF THE FOOT
PRINT THE ISSUE OF THE ENVELOPE
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IS THAT
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THE PROPERTY
SO NOW I'M IN A SITUATION
WHERE. I HAVE MY PROPERTY MY
HOUSE LET'S ASSUME IT'S TEN
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET IS THE
LAND OF I'M ON. AND I COULD
SPLIT IT FOUR THOUSAND SIX
THOUSAND OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE
AND THE SECOND ONE I NOW MAKE A
LOT THAT I COULD SELL
SEPARATELY BECAUSE IT'S NOW
SEPARATE PARTIAL RIGHT. UNDER
THE CURRENT ENVELOPE TERM. OR
FOOT PRINT TERM. MATCHES TO MY
HOUSE FOR EASE OF EXAMPLES TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET. SO AM I
LIMITED IN THE BUILDING OF A
NEW PROPERTY AND I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THIS I'M NOT SURE
YOU DO BUT I. THE BOTTOM LINE
IS I WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS. TO TWO THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET OF NEW STRUCTURE OR IF THE
FOOTPRINT IS. TEN BY TEN JUST
FOR EASE OF EXAMPLE. COULD I GO
THREE STORIES HIGH ASSUMING THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALLOWED ME.
THAT ACTUALLY GO. THREE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET INSTEAD OF A
HUNDRED IF IT WAS TEN BY TEN.
RIGHT WATER ONE OF THOSE
FACTORS IN DETERMINING THE
DEFINITION. BETWEEN SQUARE
FOOTAGE. IN ENVELOPE OR
FOOTPRINT DO YOU HAVE ANY HELP
YOU CAN HELP ME ON THAT YEAH.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL TO BE ABLE TO
DEFINE. WHAT IS STILL IN PLACE
WITH THIS BILL. THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONCERN. THAT FLOOR AREA
RATIO WOULD RISE FOR NOW. SOME
CONCERN THAT HEIGHT LIMITS
WOULD BE RIGHT TURN OUT A LOT
OF CONCERN IT BACKS UP. IT ALL
REMAINS. IT ALL REMAINS. SO I'M
GONNA GIVE AN EXAMPLE OKAY- MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. WE LIVE ON A
QUARTER ACRE LOTS. OKAY UNDER
THIS BILL- IN THE CITY THAT I
LIVE IN. FOR DUPLEX. YOU COULD
NOT BUILD A THREE STORY DUPLEX
IT WOULD BE OUTSIDE OF THE NORM
THAT WOULD BE ALLOWED UNDER
ZONING. IN THE CITY THEY RESIDE
IN SO IF YOU CAN ESSENTIALLY
BUILD A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
BEHIND YOUR HOME THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO BUILD THE
DUPLEX- BUT AGAIN THERE IS NO
DOUBLE DIPPING IF YOU HAVE A
JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU AN EIGHTY YOU
ON THERE ALREADY YOU CAN'T
BUILD A DUPLEX BOTTOM LINE
CORRECT. AND THE LAST PIECE OF
SPACE LOCAL REQUIREMENTS STILL
APPLY- AS LONG AS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T PRECLUDE A
DUPLEX FROM BEING BUILT. FLOOR
AREA RATIO. SET BACK HEIGHT
REQUIREMENTS ALSO APPLIES IN
THIS BILL. BUT SO COULD A
COLLEGES I AM SORRY I DID I WAS
VERY GOOD AT EXPLAINING MY
QUESTION SO YOU BEEN APPRECIATE
THE YOUR ATTENTION TO DETAIL ON
THIS. SO IF BY NOW HAVE A TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOUSE OKAY.
THAT BOND HAS A CERTAIN SIZE
FOOT PRINT- ENVELOPE WHATEVER
THE TERM WAS AM I LIMITED TO
BUILDING TWO THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET TOTAL SOME OF THE PEOPLE I
TALKED TO THE COMMITTEES ARE
REPRESENTING DETAIL THEY'RE NOT
SO WORRIED AS MUCH ABOUT ME
THEY THEY THEY TALK ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT I. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DYNAMIC THERE CRUISING HOUSING
SUPPLY I HAVE FOURTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHTY USE IN MY COMMUNITY-
ALREADY SO LARGEST NOT GROUP OF
FORTY YEARS IN THE WHOLE STATE
A AND A PARTICULAR THING OF
COMMITTEES IN NORTHEAST SECTION
IS BEEN PHENOMENALLY SUCCESSFUL
AND WITHOUT COMPLAINT AND WORK
EXTREMELY WELL WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS MOVING TO SPEND TO
TASTIC. SO I DON'T THINK IT WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE EIGHTY
USE THE ISSUE IS IF IT IS A
REAL FEAR OF CORPORATE IS ATION
AND CHANGING THE CHARACTER OF A
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD AND
IF YOU HAVE A TEAR DOWN OR
SUBSTANTIAL TEAR DOWN HOW BIG
COULD THE BILL BACK IT'S THIS
WE SEE IT MENTIONED IS ATION IN
THE SLIGHTLY BUT COUNCIL I MEAN
THESE NEIGHBORHOOD COMMITTEES
AS WELL. HOW BIG CAN A BILL
BACKED BY THE LIMITED BY SQUARE
FOOT LIMITATION IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE
REBUILD OF A SUBSTANTIAL TEAR
DOWN OR ARE THEY LIMITED JUST
BY THE ENVELOPE AND THEN OKAY
THE LOCAL ORDINANCES WILL WILL-
REGULATE THE HEIGHT ACTUALLY
SOME GUIDANCE ON THAT
COUNCILMAN CLEAR ABOUT THAT AND
I APOLOGIZE NO YOU'RE YOU'RE
GOOD MR MAJORITY LEADER SO THE
POSITIVE PIECE OF THIS BILL. IT
STILL MAINTAINS LOCAL CONTROL
FOR EXAMPLE AND I DON'T MEAN TO
BE SQUISHY BUT IT'S GOING TO BE
DEPENDENT ON THE CITY OR COUNTY
ORDINANCE SO FOR EXAMPLE. IF
THE CITY. ALLOWS FOR THAT
SINGLE FOR HOME- DO ABLE TO BE
BUILT FOR A DUPLEX BE ABLE TO
BE BUILT. THAT CITY OR COUNTY
CAN IMPOSE REQUIREMENTS AS LONG
AS- AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE THE BUILDING OF TWO
TWO UNITS. SO IT'S UP TO THE
CITY. WHICH IS THE POSITIVE
PIECE OF THIS BILL. SO THEY
COULD DO HI RESTRICTIONS THE
GUY WAS TALKING
AMERISOURCEBERGEN BUT THIS IT
IS IT WAS YOU KNOW GATHERING
DATA AND TRYING TO GET YOU HELP
ME UNDERSTAND THIS BETTER AND
HE WAS SAYING YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE DOING
IS LIMITING HEIGHT RESTRICTIONS
IN THEIR CITY THAT THEY'RE
LIMITING THE DESIGN
RESTRICTIONS YOU CAN'T BUILD A
MONSTROSITY BEHIND YOUR HOUSE
THAT LOOKS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT- HOUSE THAT HAS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE DESIGN SO
IT DOESN'T UPSET THE- INTEGRITY
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT STANDARDS WHAT
YOU'RE TELLING ME. IS THAT YOUR
INTERPRETATION OF THIS BILL IS
THE DATA AUTHORITY STILL RESTS
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS
LONG AS THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE
THEY HAVE NO ABILITY TO SAY NO
TO A DUPLEX BIG THAT YOU CAN'T
HAVE. YOU COULD YOU CAN'T GO
PAST FOUR SO IF YOU HAVE A OP
YOU'RE SINGLE FAMILY HOME WITH
THE JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU AND THEN
YOU DO A LOT SPLIT YOUR DUPLEX
IN THE BACK THAT'S IT AND THAT
TO ME IS CLEAR BECAUSE I SAW
THAT THERE WAS A LACK OF
CLARITY BEFORE. IT'S BEEN
RAISED BY PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY. WE AGREED WITH THAT
AND FIXED IT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT ALSO- DESIGN RESTRICTIONS
ON THESE UNITS STILL APPLY OKAY
SO IT'S COOKED IN BUILT INTO
THIS BILL. ONLY TWO PER PARCEL.
A TOTAL OF FOUR SO IF I'M USING
MY EXAMPLE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
RIGHT. I COULD TRANSITION ONE
TIME MY SINGLE FAMILY TWO
DUPLEX. AND I COULD PUT TWO
UNITS BEHIND MY HOME IF I
WANTED TO. IN FACT ALL THE SAME
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD- WE HAVE
DUPLEXES IN EIGHTY USE GT USE
ALL THROUGHOUT AND IT HAS BEEN
DONE OVER TIME BUT- I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT THE DESIGN
REVIEW. IN DESIGN RESTRICTIONS
ALL STILL APPLY WITH YOUR CITY
AND THAT'S THE POWERFUL PIECE
OF THIS BILL. OKAY SO THIS LAST
POINT I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND ALL THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS JUST
TAKE AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
TIME AND ATTENTION THE
COMMITTEES ARE PRESENT. IN
TRYING TO. BRING THEIR POINT OF
VIEW TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE FRUSTRATIONS THAT THEY'VE
EXPRESSED AND IT'S OFTEN IT'S
HARDER HERE'S THE AUTHOR OF SB
FIFTY THAT YOU KNOW MISTER
WINNER JUST WALKED IN AND YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY STILL SEES THIS
IS THAT AND IT'S COMPLETELY
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT. OKAY I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT HERE
PARTICULAR SQUARE FOOTAGE
VERSUS. VERSUS ENVELOPE IN THE
LIKE WE GET BUT I'M JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE HAVE CLARITY ON
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
LAND USE LAWYERS AND OTHER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FORTY OPINIONS
AND THEY'RE CRAWLING ALL OVER
THIS AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS UNDERSTANDING THAT IT
GOES FROM THREE TO FOUR WHICH I
KNOW IT DOES BUT THE BIG ISSUE
IS IF THERE'S A TEARDOWN IS THE
BIG QUESTION ARE SUBSTANTIAL
TEAR DOWN WHAT IS THAT
REPLACEMENT LOOK LIKE AND WHAT
ARE THE LIMIATIONS THAT ARE
IMPOSED UPON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WITH RESPECT TO THAT TURNED
OUT. THAT TO ME IS THE CRUX OF
THE REMAINING QUESTION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE RAISE THE
QUESTION ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THERE ARE MANY OTHER
AVENUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLY TAKEN WITH RESPECT
TO THIS LEGISLATURE THAT'S
GOING TO. DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE YOU KNOW AND-
CHALLENGING SITUATIONS WITH
RESPECT AFFORDABILITY AND WILL
BE DEALING WITH THAT THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT HUESO WITH THAT I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
FOR BEING SO PATIENT. MR
MAJORITY LEADER LOOK I THINK
THE MAJORITY LEADER BRINGS UP
SOME. VERY VALID POINTS TODAY.
BUT I WANNA RE. WHERE WE WERE
IN WHERE THIS BILL WOULD GO.
THE RESTRICTIONS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STILL APPLY WITH
THIS BILL. THE ONLY THING THE
CITY CAN'T DO IS BAN DUPLEX.
IT'S ALSO CRITICAL TO SAY RIGHT
NOW IN STATE LAW YOU CAN HAVE
THREE UNITS ON YOUR PERSONAL
SINGLE FAMILY HOME. A JUNIOR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT AN
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. THIS
ONLY ADDS ONE. FLOOR AREA RATIO
HEIGHT RESTRICTIONS ALONG WITH
SET BACK STILL APPLIES OTHER
GUARD RAILS THAT HAVE BEEN
EMBEDDED IN THIS IS THAT IF AN
INDIVIDUAL WANTED TO BUY TWO
PARCELS THAT **** UP AGAINST
THE PARCEL WE'RE GONNA PUT IN
EIGHT TWO DUPLEXES YOU CAN'T DO
THAT. SO THE SPECULATION
OPPORTUNITY IS TAKEN OUT OF
THIS BILL AND THE- OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF ALL THIS YOU
ALL IS THAT THERE IS NOW AN
ABILITY TO HAVE A HOME
OWNERSHIP CLIENTS AGAIN THE
PROGRAM IS AND REALLY FOCUS ON
LOCAL CONTROL. IF THE CITY
DECIDES TO PUT A HOME OWNERSHIP
BECAUSE INTO THE BILL BY
PASSING ORDINANCE THEY CAN DO
IT THIS BILL NOW ALLOWS THEM
THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HER TO BE ABLE TO BUILD THAT
MULTI GENERATIONAL WEALTH. WE
KNOW RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THOSE HOMEOWNERS THE NUMBER
ONE MISTAKE THE NUMBER ONE
INVESTMENT THAT FOLKS HAVE IS
HOME OWNERSHIP. IN THIS IS
GOING TO HELP BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL WEALTH IN THE
STATE THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
IS THIS LET'S TALK ABOUT
AFFORDABLE- THEIR BEEN STUDIES
SHOW THAT- ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS ARE ARE MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN YOUR TYPICAL
RENTAL SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
EAST BAY. IT'S ABOUT SOMEONE
MAKING 62% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME CAN AFFORD AN ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT RENT WHERE THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD. A LARGE CONDO
OR SINGLE FAMILY HOME WE KNOW
THAT THESE UNITS ARE GOING TO
BE MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE WHEN
IT COMES TO MORE AFFORDABLE
RENTS ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. BY THE
SKYROCKETING. RENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SEVERAL DO NOT
CENTER TO ROGER YOU HAVE MADE A
MOTION TO DO WE SHOULD HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES
PLEASE MISTER CHAIR DEVICE
CHECK- IF YOU COULD SUMMARIZE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE CENTER
HERTZBERG'S QUESTIONS HE'S HE
REALLY GOT INTO SOME SPECIFICS
THAT HELP ME UNDERSTAND FURTHER
UNDERSTAND BUT IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE- THE ISSUES THAT
TENANTS COULD BE FACING THE
KINDS OF. PROTECTIONS THAT OF
FOR OUR TENANTS I HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE
OF RENTERS IN THE STATE SEVENTY
SEVEN PERCENT. AND THERE'S
ALWAYS OBVIOUSLY THE FEAR AND
THE THREATS OF GENTRIFICATION.
OF IN THE IN OUR DISTRICTS AND
THESE ARE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD ON. RENTING
AND SO THEY'RE MUCH MORE
SUBJECT ARE VULNERABLE. TO
GENTRIFICATION AND SO I IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS THAT- DO THIS
BILL THANK YOU IT'S A GOOD IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION CENTER DRAWS
ON THANK YOU FOR THAT SO THIS
BILL PREVENTS- PROFITEERS IF
YOU WILL FROM EVICTING TENANTS
IN FACT INVENTED IN THIS BILL.
IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE TO PLEASE
DISPLACING TENANTS. IN AN
EXISTING STRUCTURE FOR THREE
YEARS. THREE YEARS MEMBERS BUT
THIS HAS STRONG TENANT
PROTECTIONS AND IN FACT IT
DOESN'T ALLOW- THE CONVERSION
WHERE TENET HAS RESIDED IN HE
PAST THREE YEARS WERE TEN
ACTUALLY RESIDED SO LOOK IT'S
CRITICAL IT IS STRONG TENANT
PROTECTIONS EMBEDDED IN THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF- THE CONCERNED
IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP BY THE
MEMBERS OF THIS CAUCUS WHO SAID
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TENANTS ARE PROTECTED- AND
THERE IS A THREE YEAR TENURE
PROTECTION BECAUSE- INDEBTED IN
THE BILL. THANK. THE OTHER LAST
DIESEL SAY IS WHEN IT COMES TO
SUPPORT ACROSS THE STATE I KNOW
THAT WE HAD AN INDIVIDUAL SAID
THAT- THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES
THAT WAS OPPOSED TO THE BILL I
HE IS NOT IN FACT HE HAS NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ON THE BILL WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE THAT CLARIFIED THAT HE IS
NOT TAKING. A POSITION ON THE
BILL. MISTER CHAIR IF IT'S
ALRIGHT I'D LIKE TO BE A CLOSE
YEAH. SO I'D LIKE TO BE TO SAY
THIS. STATE LAW CURRENTLY
ALLOWS FOR THREE UNITS. THIS
WOULD ALLOW FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
UNIT. WITH A FOUR PLEX NUMBER
ONE. OR TO. THERE'S A
HOMEOWNERSHIP CLASS NOW IN THIS
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL WEALTH ON THAT
PROPERTY. NUMBER THREE. FLOOR
AREA RATIO HI IS WELL AS SET
BACK ALL CRITICAL WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RESIDENTIAL. PROPERTIES IN THE
STATE ALL STILL APPLY YOU
CANNOT DOUBLE DIP. WE HEARD
SOME SAY THAT YOU CAN BUILD SIX
UNITS YEAH YOU CAN'T DOUBLE DIP
WITH THIS BILL IF THERE IS A G.
EIGHTY YOU AN EIGHTY ON A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME ALREADY ON
THE PARCEL YOU CAN'T PUT IN A
DUPLEX YOU SIMPLY CAN'T. AND
IT'S CLEAR AS DAY IN THIS BILL
YOU ALSO CAN'T COMBINE PARCELS
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD A SMALL
SUBDIVISION IT PRECLUDES THE
ACT. IT ALSO NOW APPLIES TO
HOMEOWNERS SO IF THE CITY
COUNCIL WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
PUT A HOMEOWNERSHIP COSTS ON TO
THE PROPERTIES THAT WANT TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
ONE TIME CONVERSION THEY NOW
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO SO
THAT YOU HAVE HOMEOWNERS
LIVING. IN THOSE PROPERTIES IN
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS THIS.
HOUSING LEGISLATION IS HARD. WE
HEAR TIME AND TIME AGAIN PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE CRISIS WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
TACKLE THAT CRISIS AND IS THIS
A SILVER BULLET NOW BUT IS THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE TO PRINT PROVIDE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA DURING THE SECURE
CRISIS THAT'S IMPACTING WORKING
FAMILIES AND SENIORS YES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIR. GERMANY
DIDN'T ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS
EARLY ON THAT THE TELEVISION
AND RETENTION TECHNIQUE AND
MAKE YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE HIS
SENATOR NIELSEN HIGH. HEELS AND
A SENATOR DRAWS ARE. ZERO ZERO
HI SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HI SEVEN WIENER. WIENER HI.
FIVE ZERO. FIFTY YOU SO MUCH ON
BEHALF OF PRETENDING YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
ON THE ISSUE OF SB NINE OUR
FIRST ITEM ON OUR SPECIAL ORDER
IT CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES
THAT BILL IS OUT RECALLS IN THE
ROLE. WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE VICE CHAIR FOR HIS WORK ON
THAT. BASINGER ON THE COMMITTEE
IS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE IN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE A SLIGHT CHANGE IN
OUR SPECIAL ORDER HEARING. I
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TEN WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
IT AS ITEM NUMBER THREE SO WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO AND
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW FOLKS. A
COUPLE MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
QUEUE UP. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ITEM FIVE FIVE SIX ITEM FIVE
FIVE SIX NEXT. SO IF YOU WERE
CALLING ON SENATOR DODDS SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. PLEASE QUEUE UP
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THAT
HERE IN JUST A COUPLE MINUTES
WE'RE GONNA ALLOW FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO QUEUE UP. THE PHONE
NUMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE TO BE SURE TO
PROVIDE COMMENT ON SP FIVE FIVE
SIX EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO COMMENT ON SB FIVE FIVE SIX
PLEASE DIAL NOW. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO THE CODE IS. FOUR FOUR
FIVE SIX TWO ZERO SIX. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK TWO MINUTE
RECESS ALLOW FOLKS TO BE TO
QUEUE UP IN LINES AND WE'RE
COMING BACK TO TALK SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. IN TWO MINUTES THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT REYES AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA BE COMING BACK I'D
TO SENDING GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE WELCOME
YOU BACK. THEY TO GENERATE AS
WE DISCUSSED HERE JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS HAD AN
APPROPRIATE HEADS UP WE HAD TO.
DO A SLIGHT AMENDMENT TO THE
ORDER OF OUR- SPECIAL ORDER
HEARING. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TAKE SB FIVE FIVE SIX. AND THEN
AFTER SB FIVE FIVE SIX. SENATOR
DODD HAS ONE ADDITIONAL BILL
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE. IT'S A
COMMITTEE BILL FROM- THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO GO. TO- S. B. TEN. WITHOUT
FURTHER DELAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER FROM THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM NAPA
DEVELOPERS IN SB FIVE FIVE SIX.
PERCENT OF THE FOR SURE SIR. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE ON THIS
REQUEST. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD
BRING CALIFORNIA ITS
CONFORMANCE WITH EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW. SEEKING
TO ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS PERTAINING
TO THE STATIC STANDARDS AND
TIMING AS THEY WERE DISCUSSED
LAST MONDAY ON THE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
HEARING. DEMAND FOR RELIABLE
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY HAS NEVER BEEN
HIGHER THAN IT IS TODAY. THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS ONLY
ELEVATED THE EXTENT TO WHICH
BROADBAND ACCESS HAS BECOME
ESSENTIAL FOR PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY IN EVERY ASPECT. OF
MODERN SOCIETY. ACCESSIBLE AND
RELIALE BROADBAND NETWORKS ARE
NOW MORE THAN EVER CRITICAL IN
OUR DAILY LIVES YET TO MANY
HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE STATE
CAN'T ACCESS BROADBAND BECAUSE
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE WHERE THEY
LIVE. LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WORLD POPULATIONS AND WORKING
FAMILIES WHO LACK BROADBAND
RISK FALLING FURTHER BEHIND.
THAT'S LEARNING HAS SHIFTED
ONLINE STUDENTS MAY STRUGGLE TO
KEEP UP. ADULT IN COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT INTERNET ACCESS MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO SEARCH AND APPLY FOR
JOBS WORK REMOTELY START
BUSINESSES OR ACCESS
EDUCATIONAL SOCIAL AND OTHER
RESOURCES NEEDED TO THRIVE IN
THIS DIGITAL ECONOMY. SB FIVE
FIVE SIX WILL ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS BY CONFORMING CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FCC FEDERAL REGULATION
IN ORDER TO EXPAND. YEAH FIVE
G. DEPLOYMENT IT CONTRIBUTE TO
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LOCALITIES
TO GIVE ACCESS TO THEIR STREET
LIGHTS AND TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES
IN ORDER FOR TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES TO ATTACH THEIR
WIRELESS FACILITIES. THE BILL
FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT THE
ACCESS TO THOSE POLLS IS
PROVIDED AND IT NON
DISCRIMINATORY. BOSTON BASED
RATE. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE FCC ISSUED AN
INFRASTRUCTURE ORDER THAT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE THAT COST BASED RATE
FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO ATTACH WIRELESS
FACILITIES THE STREET LIGHT AND
TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES. THE FCC
ESTIMATED THAT THAT PRESUMPTIVE
RATE NOT DISCRIMINATORY RATE AT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLARS.
HOWEVER MANY LOCALITIES ARE
INTERPRETING THAT FEDERAL ORDER
INCONSISTENTLY. THERE'S BEEN
WIDESPREAD RESISTANCE NOT
COMPLIANCE IT CONTINUED
LITIGATION OVER THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ORDER.
THERE'S BEEN WIPED. S. B. FIVE
FIVE SIX WILL CREATE UNIFORMITY
WITH THE FCC ORDER BY FIRST
OFFERING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
OPTION TO CONFORM TO THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLAR FCC
PRESUMPTIVE RATE. THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES FOR LOW GOVERNMENT WHO
DO NOT WISH TO APPLY THAT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLAR RATE THE
OPTION. TO USE A CAR BASED
ATTACHED RATE FORMULA THAT IS
MODELED AFTER AB TEN TWENTY
SEVEN PASSED. IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. THAT BECAUSE BE FOR ME
BEEN YOU BY PUBLICLY ON
UTILITIES FOR YOU. IT HAS BEEN
APPLIED BY THE CPUC TO INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND TELEPHONE
COMPANIES AS WELL. TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS IS REALLY A
SAFE HARBOR FOR LOCALITIES TO
CHOOSE NOT TO APPLY THE FEE
CALCULATION. THERE IS NOTHING
IN THE BILL PROHIBITING THEM TO
COME UP WTH A HIGHER RATE
AFTER THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR
COST STUDY. FINALLY AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS MOVED SUBSTANTIVE
LANGUAGE OF SB FIVE FIVE SIX IT
TO A STANDALONE PUBLIC UTILITY
CODE SECTION TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS OF THE P. O. U. S. AND
THE CABLE ASSOCIATION. AS WELL
AS A LIGHTING LANGUAGE ON
REASONABLE COST WITH THE
LANGUAGE OF THE FCC- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ARTICULATED. BY THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES. GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE AMONG STAKEHOLDERS IN MY
TEAM. WHILE THE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS. I KNOW THERE IS
MORE WORK. TO BE DONE AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT. ON THE PHONE TODAY IS
BARBARA. THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE NAPA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IT IN THE HEARING
ROOM TODAY ALSO IS RUDY RADIUS
FROM VERIZON HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DIED
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
INTO THOSE WHO ARE ON THE LINE
IN HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE PROVIDING EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. EQUAL TIME FOR
BOTH SIDES- AS SOON AS OUR TO
LEAD WITNESSES BOTH FOR
SUPPORT. IS WELL AS IN
OPPOSITION GET STARTED THAT'S
WHEN THE TWENTY FIVE MINUTE
CLOCK STARTS TO TICK. SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO WELCOME
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS FOR
THE COUNTYNAPA. BOURBON INFO
ON THE LINE. BETTER
SUPERINTENDENT YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT HERE NOW
AND COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY I'VE BEEN THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND NAPA FOR. MY TWENTY
YEAR. AND WE HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD OBVIOUSLY WANT THE
PANDEMIC HIT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS. HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THAT WE WERE
PROVIDING REMOTELY. WE WENT OUT
WE BOUGHT DEVICES WE BOUGHT HOT
SPOTS WE ENSURED EVERY STUDENT
HAD. BUT A DEVICE ON A HOT SPOT
THAT HAS NO. TO CONNECT TO YOU
IT DOESN'T HELP THEM TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO
DO. WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE COME
BACK IN THE FALL EVEN AS WHO
WILL CONTINUE TO RE OPEN THERE
ARE GOING TO BE MANY FAMILIES
WHO ARE AFRAID TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL. SO THE
NEED TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
CONNECTED TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER.
AND NOW WE'RE BEING ASKED NOT
ONLY TO MAKE UP FOR THE
LEARNING LAW BUT HEARD OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF BUT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKED TO DO MORE TO
PROVIDE IN RICHMOND
ACCELERATION. AND THE MOST
ENGAGING AND MOTIVATING LESSONS
ARE THOSE THAT ARE DONE THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY. WE URGE CLEAN. IT
IS UP. NOT IN THE- VISION OF
EQUITY THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
STATE THAT ONE IN HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA STILL LACK ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND. WE HAVE
GOT TO PROVIDE THAT FOR EVERY
STUDENT IN EVERY SCHOOL AND
PARTICULARLY THE ONES WHO DON'T
HAVE. AN ARE IN AS AN UNDERDOG-
AND FOREST AREAS OF THE STATE
THE WHITE- URGE YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT VOTE ON. THE. FIVE
FIVE. THANKS DODD FOR THE BILL.
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S PERMANENT CO
SUPER IN SCHOOL SO THEY CAN OF
NEW LATER GERMAN CAN WHERE NOW
GOING TO GO TOWARDS FOR WE-
INTO OF SB FIVE FIVE SIX HIS
NAME IS RUDY REYES WITH VERIZON
YOU MISTER RAISE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOUR THREE MINUTES I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MCGUIRE VICE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S WONDERFUL TO BE
BACK IN SACRAMENTO AND TO BE
STANDING. BY SENATOR DODD
SOCIALLY DISTANCE AS WE ARE. TO
EXPRESS VERIZON'S AND THE
INDUSTRIES. AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AS STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR THIS LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
ACCELERATE AND EXPAND. FIVE G.
CONNECTIVITY ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
THE SENATOR LAID OUT VERY WELL
WHAT THE BILL DOES- I THOUGHT I
WOULD SPEND A FEW MOMENTS-
PUTTING IN CONTEXT OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY. AND
THEN A LITTLE BIT ON WHAT THE
BILL DOES NOT DO- THIS BILL UP
HOLDS FCC REGULATIONS AND LONG
STANDING TELECOMMUNICATIONS
POLICY. ABOUT HOW WE BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND GET THAT
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
CRITICALLY OVER THE LAST MILE
WHICH IS ALWAYS BEEN THE
QUINTESSENTIAL PROBLEM IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY HOW
DO WE GET THIS BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO THE LAST
MILE. AND SO THIS BILL WILL
BRING CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
REGULATIONS THAT WERE ADOPTED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY THE FCC.
THAT REQUIRE THAT PROHIBITS
LOCALITIES FROM DENYING
REASONABLE NON DISCRIMINATORY
AND COST BASED ACCESS TO THEIR
POLL INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR SMALL
WIRELESS FACILITIES ATTACHMENT
THESE SMALL CELLS ARE CRITICAL
FOR DEPLOYING FIVE G.
TECHNOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA- I CAN
ADDRESS FIVE G. IN QUESTIONS OF
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL IT'S THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WIRELESS
TECHNOLOGY GIGABIT LEVEL
CONNECTIVITY. EXTREMELY HIGH
CAPACITY AND VERY VERY LOW
LATENCY IT'S CALLED THE FOURTH
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION BUT I
THINK THE KILLER APP. EVERYONE
KEEPS TALKING ABOUT FOR FIVE G.
IS SIMPLY BROADBAND GETTING
MORE BROADBAND TO OUR HOMES AND
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SENATOR WENT THROUGH A BIT
ABOUT WHAT THE BILL DOES AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- THAT THE CHAIR
ALLOWS ME TO TAKE- BUT THAT THE
SENATOR NOTED THAT WE THAT HE
HAS TAKEN NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS.
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT- I
STAKEHOLDERS- JUST A COUPLE TO
POINT OUT THIS BILL RETAINS ALL
LOCAL CONTROL AND AUTHORITY
OVER SAFETY. THE PLACEMENT OF
THESE SMALL CELLS AND
AESTHETICS THIRTY SECONDS- THE
BILL HAS A GRANDFATHERING
CLAUSE TO PRESERVE EXISTING
AGREEMENTS AN EXISTING
DEPLOYMENTS. AND FINALLY I
WOULD SAY THAT- THE PROBLEM OF
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS REALLY A
THREE LEGGED STOOL ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND ADOPTION THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THE FIRST
CRITICAL ASPECT OF THAT OTHER
BILLS THAT WILL COME BEFORE YOU
WILL ADDRESS OTHER ASPECTS LIKE
PERMIT STREAMLINING AND
AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE HONOR TO SPEAK
TODAY MR CAMERON AND MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. WITH REYES THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS RAISES WITH RISING
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY BILLS ARE TO LEAD
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THREE
MINUTES EACH WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR PHONE LINES IN A
MOMENT THAT WE LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE HERE IN
THE CAPITAL FORTY TWO OR THREE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT HEARING
SEEN KNOWN IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
OVERFLOW ROOM. THAT'S IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THIRTEEN SEEN
KNOWN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES NOT A MODERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE Q. WHAT PLEASE KEY WORK
NOW ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE SIX THE FLOOR'S.
YOURS MATAMATA READER. THANK
YOU IF YOU JUST IN. OF S. B.
FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SEVENTEEN
IN QUEUE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICIA BRUNO NINETY CAN ON
BEHALF OF THE LAWCENTER CHAIR
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE SIX
WHICH WILL FINALLY ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA REMIND
ALL CALLERS JUST BECAUSE WE
WANT TO PROVIDE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY WE'RE GOING TO ASK
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND AGAIN
WE JUST WANT EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOTH SIDES NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MINIMIZE WRITER. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN RIGHT. THREE FOUR FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FORTY SEVEN READ MORE SEVEN.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT. HI MY NAME IS GERRY-
JOHNSON I'M IN OFFICE AS TO THE-
I WE NEED HARPER. ARE YOUR
INJURIES NINE THREE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
HIGHER FROM THE VALLEY
LEADERSHIP ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT
IMPORTANT THANK YOU A FOR YOUR
CALL JUST IN MEXICO PLEASE. BY
SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LOOK AND I AM AN OFFICE
TO BILL ON BIG DIRECTOR OF G.
PER CAL. L. DOES NOT TO ADDRESS
THE DIVIDE IT'S REALLY CURRENT
ON A HEALTHY HEART. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IN A AS WE SAID IN A OF
THE BURKE TAKE IT AS WE GET IT
YOU MAY SOME WHO ARE NOT. IN
THE SUPPORT KIND OF. YOU MAY
HEAR SOME FOR WHO ARE IN AND
OPPOSITE CATEGORY. AGAIN
EVERYONE HAS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TIME WE YOU DO MOVE
REALLY PREACH YOUR FOR WORK
WITH US YOUR FIRST AND LAST.
YOUR IN YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT. EIGHTY PLEASE AT.
NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE YEAR
COMMITTEE. NEXT CALLER.
PINETREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LISA
CAL I WITH TO ANY CALIFORNIA I
AM STRONGLY TO THIS BILL EVERY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALICIA WE'VE
YOUR CALL. METAMORA NEXT PLEASE.
BY THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO OUT.
BY THE IS LINDA LAVENDER WE THE
EAST LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THE SELF YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR FONG
IT'S GOING OUR NEXT CALL. THANK
YOU FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EVERYONE MY IS ALFRED Q.
UNDERSTAND ORDINAIRE CAL AND IN
BURKE CALIFORNIA STRONG OF THE
BILL THANK YOU ALFRED SO MUCH
FOR NAY NAY COLORFUL. THREE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS P. MEHR OF THE SLEEPY
HOLLOW HOMES ASSOCIATION IN SAN
ANSELMO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
JONATHAN HERE BELL ON BEHALF OF
CTIA THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF.
FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU SO
MUCH JOHNSON APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT R. SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HARD LARA LARAMIE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESS FOR IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB FIVE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN TODAY FROM SEVEN
CALIFORNIA LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. RIGHT ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
ANOTHER BOOK BETTER CITY OF
CAMPBELL I SUPPORT SB FIVE BY
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ANIS THING
ON YOUR REPRESENTING THE LAW
THAT'S THE MONEY ITS BUDGET
MARKED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT
A. THANK YOU FOR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TRYING TO REACH PLEASE
GO OUT. OKAY ALL LAWLER
LAWCENTER YEAH THANK FOR
THINKING. THANK YOU SO MUCH
JOHNSON VERY GREAT LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
SIX GO AHEAD. LINE EIGHTY SIX
DURING COMMITTEE- OAK HEY I DO
I LINE EIGHTY SIX YEAR AND CAN
BE PLEASE FOR. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YOUR INCOME SERVED
PROCEED. BUT AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS ARE BEING HATCHING WAS
WITH THEIR ANY PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP IN OPPOSITION. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BELMONT CARLSBAD
DR CITY THANK YOU. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
WE'RE GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU I'M
THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERSERK ON A WOOD
COUNTY PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF PLACENTIA
GLORIA DEL MAR IN CHINO HILLS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE ANIMALS UNION CITY
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
DUE TO THIS DOESN'T CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND DUE TO NO
FIRE HAZARDS IN NEIGHBORHOOD
FIRE DEFENSIBLE ZONE THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE TIME TO GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
STEPHANIE THOMAS FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY- PART OF FLORIDA'S
RADIATION EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO FIVE FIFTY
SIX BECAUSE OF FIRE DANGER AND
NOT GIVING DIGITAL ACCESS TO
EVERYONE THANK YOU SEVENTY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE ARRIVING PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I DIDN'T ACT BOWLING GOING
ALAMEDA I MET WHILE LOOKING AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
TO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWO TO FIVE URINE COMMITTEE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT CALL
AMANDA MODERATOR. PINE THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEXT CALL AMANDA MODERATOR.
THREE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SO OF ON THE US OF THE
CROWN CASTLE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH SALAS
APPRECIATED NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
PRICE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SIXTY FIVE YEAR AND
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NINE
SIXTY FIVE. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MATTER MODERATOR.
RIGHT ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JOHN MEMBERS
KILLING THANK YOUNG ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX WE APPRECIATE THE
OTHER WORKING WITH US BUT STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MUCH RESENTMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS CAROL OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY BUT STOCKTON AND A LOT
OF EACH AND THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
ALL IN OPPOSITION THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY CAN WE GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE BOTH IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU FOR A PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THREE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. YES THIS IS CONNIE
ANDERSON FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AFFILIATED WITH THE
WIRED STRONGLY OPPOSE DUE TO
HIGH FIRE HAZARD AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST PEOPLE
WITH ELECTRICAL SENSITIVITY AND
MANY OTHER HEALTH PROBLEMS
THANK YOU COUNTY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY PLEASE SHE CALLING IN.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND- THIS IS JENNY MILLER AND
CUTE COUNTY WHERE THE GROUP
TOWARDS AN INTERNET OF LIVING
BEING. AND THIS BILL IS AN
INCREDIBLE HIGHER RISK FROM
OVERLOADING POLLS IT'S ALSO A
TREMENDOUS HEALTH RISK THAT
YOU'RE A LADY NEEDS TO
INVESTIGATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA DO A LOT OF THAT IS
OPPOSITION WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ME FROM
YOU COUNTY TODAY WERE VERY VERY
APPRECIATIVE. PLACING JIM
COMMITTEE WE'VE ABOUT NINE
MINUTES NINE MINUTES LEFT ON
OUR FIRST TWENTY FIVE MINUTES
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT
SUPPORT A FIVE FIVE SIX BUT IF
YOU WERE CALLING IN OPPOSITION
AND END UP BEING IN THE SUPPORT
QUEUE WE'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM
YOU ANYWAY AND WE'LL DO THAT.
VICE VERSA ONCE WE TAKE
OPPOSITION SO WE HAVE ABOUT
NINE MINUTES LEFT NOT A
MODERATOR. HOW MANY FOLKS WE
HAVE ON THE LINE. I CURRENTLY
HAVE LESS Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MIRAMAR THE THAT'S- WITH OUR
CALLERS. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS SUSAN TO WAIT FOR MORE ON
THE CREEK AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE PRESERVE LOCAL CONTROL
BY VOTING NO ON THE MISGUIDED
WIRELESS IS BETTER THAN FIBER
OPTICS TO HOME BILL. SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIS AND APPRECIATE THAT
THE ROOF OVER YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS AN ACRONYM ON
FORMER TWO TIME MAYOR AND
COUNCIL MEMBER OF NEVADA CITY
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIVE FIVE SIX FOR THE FIRE
DANGER WHAT THE LOCAL AUTHORITY
HEALTH ISSUES LACK
REPRESENTATION OF AN ORAL IT'S
GOT ALL THE COLOR TELECOM POWER
GRABS CALLER PLEASE. BROADBAND
NOT AND A MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER THANK YOU SO
MUCH HI LAZY GENTLEMAN WHO ARE
ON THE LINE REALLY APOLOGIZE
WHICH IT SAYS LIMITED TIME SO
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU IF YOU
COULD PLEASE WORK WITH US FIRST
AND LAST NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION OF THE BILL
AND WE WELCOME BOTH OPPOSITION
AS WELL SUPPORT SO MADAM
MODERATOR. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOR ALL FOUR GOING. HI MY NAME
IS KIMBERLY POND JHALAK FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX
REALLY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
VERY TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO SIXTY SIX DURING
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THE MODERATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT TO LAYS IN
GERMAN WE ARE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL SO I WANT
TO REMIND FOLKS JUST OVER
GROUND RULES AND IT'S EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES FOR THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED AS YOU JUST
HEARD WE MAY HAVE SOME FOLKS
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION THAT
SPEAK IN THE SUPPORT CATEGORY
AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT SPEAKING
THE OPPOSITION CATEGORY IT'S
ALL GOOD WERE IN A PANDEMIC AND
WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
BUT WE HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WE SPEAKING AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS WHO'S GOING
TO BE ON THE LINE. AND THEN WE
HAVE MISTER GRAHAM WHO IS GOING
TO BE IN COMMITTEE HERE WITH US
TODAY SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
LET'S GO TO BRIAN ROBERTS
REPRESENTING THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO MISTER
ROBERTS YOU HAVE TO EXCEED YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES THREE
MINUTES OUT HERE IN OPPOSITION
A. FIVE FIVE SIX MISTER ROBERTS
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
BRIAN ROBERTS WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO. THE
BILL. SIX WELL WE SHARE THE
INTEREST IN INSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS ENJOY THE BENEFITS
OF THE PANTS WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE. SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE. SIX FAILED TO
ADVANCE THIS GOAL AND WOULD
PERMANENTLY UNDERMINE EFFORTS
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ACHIEVE. CRITICAL DIGITAL
EQUITY OBJECTIVES. SENATE BILLS
FIFTY SIX IS FINDINGS POINT TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF BROADBAND
INTERNET FOR A VARIETY OF
EQUITY RELATED REASONS
CONCERNING ACCESS TO EDUCATION
TO ALLOW WOMEN CLIMATE.
UNFORTUNATELY AS EXPLAINED BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFFS EXCELLENT
RECORD THE BILL IMPOSES NEW
OBLIGATIONS ON PROVIDES NO
INCENTIVES. FOR WIRELESS
CARRIERS DURING IN LEARNING
OVER- A- TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
SO TO LOW AND CAN. THE FUND
DIGITAL EQUITY SUPPORT PROVIDE
ANY OTHER PUBLIC BENEFITS. YES
FIVE FIFTY TWO PERMITS TIME
CALIFORNIA TO ACCOUNT AT LEAST
ORDER BY THE FORMER S. C. AS-
THE BILL WILL MEAN THIS EVEN
THAT. YES HE ORDER WERE BY THE
CAR FC OF BY SUPREME COURT OR
THE SUBJECT OF NEW CHARTER
LEGISLATION. WHEN YOUR WAS
ADOPTED THE CURRENT- CHAIR OF
THE FCC. READ A STRONG. CENTER
IN PART SUPPORTING LOCAL
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS DIGITAL
EQUITY. RECOMMENDED THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL BE
SUNSET YOU'RE GOING TO BE UP TO
SEE CHANGES IT'S INTERPRETATION
OF FEDERAL LAW UNDER LINE.
FEDERAL LAWS CHANGED OR THE
SUPREME COURT REVERSES EUGENE.
FURTHERMORE WHILE- SB FIVE
FIFTY SIX. NEARLY I'M TRYING
GENERAL REQUIREMENTS CREATED BY
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AT CC
ORDER IMPOSES A GREATER BURDEN
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE DAM
THAT ORDER- AND HERE'S SOME
SPECIFIC CONCERNS IT WOULD
REDUCE THE SHOT CLOCK FOR
PROVING REQUEST REPLACEMENT OF
YOUR WIRELESS FACILITIES. FROM
SIXTY DAYS THE FORTY FIVE DAYS
REQUESTING SURE THAN THREE
HUNDRED POLLS. WOULD REQUIRE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO. BASICALLY
APPROVE ALL OF HOLDS- JOKES A
CUMBER FOR EXCLUDING THEM YOU
CAN THAT THERE SO I DON'T STATE
THREATS THIRTY CLASSES OF POOR-
THANKS IT PROPOSES A CAR THAT
THAT DOES NOT OCCUR. TO CROSS
BETWEEN CARE SOME OF GOVERNMENT
POLL AND- SO WE URGE YOU CLEAR
HER INSTILLED IT FAILS TO
ADDRESS THE CRITICAL EQUITY
ISSUES OR LOW INCOME AND RURAL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT'S BRIAN ROBERTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY FROM
THE CITY COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THAT WAS THREE
MINUTES A LITTLE LESS- BUT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME MARK
GRAHAM MARK GRAHAM IS
REPRESENTING KEEP CELL ANTENNAS
AWAY FROM OUR L. GROUP HOMES
THAT WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT HE'S
HERE IN PERSON TODAY. AGAIN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL WE
FIRST HAD OUR SUPPORT WITNESS
ON THE PHONE OUR FIRST WITNESS-
IN OPPOSITION WAS ON THE PHONE
AND THEN WE HAVE IN PERSON
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO A THREE BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. MR GRAMM WE WELCOME
YOU SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL HAVE YOU
COME RIGHT UP TO THE PLEXIGLAS
SHIELD YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
SIR AND I'LL GIVE YOU A. THIRTY
SECOND FROM THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS MARKRAM ON BEHALF
OF KEEP CELL ANTENNAS AWAY. IN
BEHALF OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. PLEASE ASK ME
QUESTIONS AFTER THAT MY
PRESENTATION HAPPY EARTH DAY
SENATORS. ACCORDING TO THE
BILL'S ANALYSIS THE AUTHORS
CLAIMS ABOUT THIS BILL ARE NOT
TRUE AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
SAID PAGE SEVEN SECTIONS TWO
ONE THREE. THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ONE CRISIS TO
CREATE ANOTHER. THE PRESENT
SYSTEM IS WORKING. TELECOM
COMPANIES ARE APPLYING FOR CELL
ANTENNA PERMITS AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE ISSUING THOSE
PERMITS ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE SAFE WAY TO PROVIDE
WIRELESS HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACCESS THAT IS FASTER MORE
RELIABLE MORE SECURE AND MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT IF WITH FIBER
OPTIC CABLES TO THE HOME OR
OFFICE. THAT'S WHAT THE STATE
SHOULD BE BEHIND. THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE STATE HUGE LIABILITY
FOR INJURIES CAUSED BY EXPOSURE
TO HAZARDOUS MICROWAVE CELL
ANTENNA RADIATION. THAT'S
ACCORDING TO ATTORNEY JERRY
LIMON I REFER TO MR LEEMANS
LETTER TO THE ENERGY COMMITTEE
DATED. APRIL FOURTEENTH. THE
LIABILITY WOULD ATTACH TO LEGAL
THEORIES THE DOCTRINE OF
FIXTURES AND JOINT VENTURE
SHIP. CITIES AND COUNTIES WOULD
BECOME UNWILLING PARTNERS OF
THE TELECOM COMPANIES. HERE'S
THE BIG PICTURE SENATORS MANY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE WOKEN UP TO
SUDDENLY FIND THE CELL ANTENNA
MOUNTED ON THE STREET LIGHT
POLE OR UTILITY POLE IN FRONT
OF THEIR HOUSE. THE CELL
ANTENNA EXPOSES THEM TO TWENTY
FOUR HOURS MICROWAVE RADIATION.
THEY SUFFER FROM CONSTANT
HEADACHES INSOMNIA AND RINGING
IN THE EARS. MANY ARE LITERALLY
DRIVEN OUT OF THEIR HOMES
FORCED TO SELL AND MOVE. WE
RELY ON OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PREVENT THIS. THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. THIRTY
SEVEN U. S. C. SECTION THREE
THREE TWO SEVEN EIGHT AND THE
FCC ORDERS CURRENTLY PRESERVE
LOCAL ZONING AUTHORITY. HAS
RECENTLY CONVERTED CONFIRMED BY
US. FIVE COURT APPEALS FOR THE
NINTH CIRCUIT IN THE CASE OF
CITY OF PORTLAND V. UNITED
STATES. THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
POWER TO DO THAT. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL GO TO
SUBSIDIZE THE INDUSTRY. ARE YOU
WILLING TO SUBSIDIZE UNDER
OTHER INDUSTRIES EQUALLY.
SENATORS HERE'S AN EXPERIMENT
FOR ONE WEEK TURN OFF YOUR WIFI
AND YOUR CELL PHONE AT NINE.
YOU WILL SLEEP BETTER AND HAVE
MORE ENERGY THE NEXT DAY. THAT
WILL BE YOUR PROOF THAT THE
WIFI AND CELL PHONE RADIATION
HAS BEEN HARMING YOU. CITIES
MUST RETAIN THE ABILITY TO
COMPATIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
REASONABLE BALANCED PROTECTIVE
AND FAIR ORDINANCES AND
AGREEMENTS SUCH AS THOSE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE CITY OF ELK
GROVE. MILL VALLEY PALUMA
FAIRFAX IN SENATORS. VOLATILE
AND OTHERS IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PUBLIC FACILITIES AND ADDRESS
THE SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE NEEDS
OF A LOCAL COMMUNITY. THERE'VE
BEEN THOUSANDS OF STUDIES
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THAT HAVE
SHOWN LONG TERM EXPOSURE TO NON
IONIZING MICROWAVE RADIATION
CREATES MANY HEALTH HAZARDS
REFER TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH STUDY FROM
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
THE INTERNATIONAL EMF SCIENTIST
APPEAL FROM MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THIRTY SECONDS WHICH
SAID THAT THIS RADIATION CAUSES
LEARNING AND MEMORY DEFICITS
AND STRUCTURAL AND FUNCTIONAL
CHANGES OF THE REPRODUCTIVE
SYSTEM. THERE WAS A SIMILAR
RESOLUTION BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN DECEMBER
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN. THIS
IS WHAT THE STATE SHOULD MAKE
IT A PRIORITY. NOW THERE IS AN
OVERRIDING STATE INTEREST HERE
AND IT'S NOT THE END PUTTING
CELL ANTENNAS ON FRONT OF IN
FRONT OF PEOPLE'S HOMES. EIGHT
OF STREET LIGHT POLE OR UTILITY
POLE IS A TERRIBLE PLACE FOR A
CELL ANTENNA. THE STATE
INTEREST HERE THE COMPELLING
STATE INTEREST IS TO THE
PRESERVATION AND PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR ASK YOU TO
COMPLETE YOUR- IN THE WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO LEAVE THE POWER
CURRENTLY LIES AND THAT'S IN
THE HANDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
INSTAGRAM- AND WE WELCOME YOU
AS YOU SAID THE STATE IF YOU IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MISTER GRAHAM WILL
BE WITH US WE MISTER RAISES
WELL ON THE SUPPORT SIDE- SO
BOTH ARE HERE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS A COMMITTEE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. TO LAYS
IN GERMAN WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE CHECKING IN WITH ANYONE ELSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION A FIVE
FIVE SIX HERE IN ROOM. FORTY
TWO OR THREE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME KAREN SCENE NOW AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE IS COMING FOR
DURING TWENTY FOURTEEN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALL
RIGHT. AS WE SAID EARLIER THAT
WE'RE GONNA ASK EACH INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S CALLING INTO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION OF
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TAKING OPPOSITION BUT
JUST AS WE TOOK SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION MORE IN THAT
CATEGORY WE'LL TAKE ANYONE AND
EVERYONE. BUT WE ARE GOING TO
BE GOING TO OPPOSITION SO MADAM
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. OF SB.
FIVE FIVE SIX NOW. THANK YOU IF
YOU WERE TO SPEAK OP. OF B.
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AS THE
MODERATORS QUEUING UP
INDIVIDUALS WE WANT WE WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS TO CALL US IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO THE CODE
IS. FOUR FOUR FIVE SIX TWO ZERO
SIX NOT A MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ARGHA SCARMAN. SAN BRUNO
THIRTEEN SENATE-DISTRICT ON
HERE- HAPPENED TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL NETWORK ENGINEER
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE SAME APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING TODAY THAT SAID GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE MINIMIZE
READER. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD WE-
MISTER JERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOB. THE CITY OF IT ABOUT THE
VISION THANK YOU SO MUCH
JOHNSON APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIDE
FOR A ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
YOUR TURN MEMBERS FILL THE A
POLICE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SYLVIA NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOR EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT THERE ARE SOME WIRE AMERICA
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE SIX THE
CHILD ENDANGERMENT WIRELESS I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH YOUR PHONE
CALL SIR WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN ITS GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COLOR YOUR IN COMMITTEE. YES
SIR MY NAME IS MARSHA FREER I
AM IN A POSITION FOR THIS BILL
PROFESSION ARCHITECT ARE
LEAVING HIS BURKE CALIFORNIA GO
WIRELESS FACILITIES THANK YOU
SAY WE REALLY APPRECIATED THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOLKS FOR NAME
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION WE
HEAR YOUR IN OPPOSITION SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO CALL IN ITS CORE
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOHANNA FINNEY I REPRESENT THE
NEVADA CITY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ORDINANCE PUBLIC WORKING GROUP
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSED BY FIVE
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALLS NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEFF LERNER I AM IN FAIRFAX
THE CONSTITUENT SENATOR MCGUIRE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
STAND WITH THE TOWN OF FAIRFAX
COUNTY COUNCIL WHO ALL OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GLAD. PROBABLY NAY BURKE
REPRESENTING ELECTRICALLY
SENSITIVE AND WIRELESS DANNY'S
FRIENDS DESPERATELY OPPOSING SB
FIVE FIVE SIX REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU
FOR CALLING THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M THREE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FIFTY FOUR YEAR AND
COMMITTEE. CHARLENE HOPING
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND BUDGETS PRETTY CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BY FIVE
SIX BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RANGE FOR FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KAREN
OBEYED WITH PETALUMA CALIFORNIA
I STAND WITH THE PEOPLE IN THE
CITY COUNCIL ALSO I'M
AFFILIATED WITH WE DON'T SELL
OUT CITIES FOR VERIZON AND
CROWN COUNSEL PROFIT AND
INSURANCE PROFESSIONALS AGAINST
THE UNINSURABLE FIRE RISK OF
FIVE G. IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
WON FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAREERING COMMITTEE ALL. YES
DANIEL CARVER- TO STABLE
AUSTRALE- OPPOSE THE ONLY
PREFERRED YOU'RE FIRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE
PHONE CALLS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAREERING
COMMITTEE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
ENTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
RIGHT THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO OUT. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE LONNIE
GORDON REPRESENTING MALIBU FOR
SAFE TECH .ORG AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MONEY FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR- SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES URINE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SYDNEY
**** I'M CALLING WITH SAFE TECH
FOR SANTA ROSA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE SIX AND I'M
CALLING FROM MY HARD WIRED
PHONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH IN THE PRECIADO IT IT'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
I'M SORRY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MICHAEL ADLER WITH TO
PAY YOUR PEACE ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING OVER A THOUSAND
PEOPLE FROM THE TO PAYING AREA
HI FIRES YEAH AND I AM
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS STATE OR **** EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH TRUST AND YOU HAVE OUR
LETTER DETAILING THE SCIENTIFIC
REASONS WHY WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL IN FOR YOUR
CORRESPONDENCE IT'S GOOD OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS RAY LORBER FROM SAN
RAFAEL NYE OPPOSE BILL FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE CALL FOR MARIN CANDIDATES
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU ARE IN FOR TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JODY NELSON REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE
TECHNOLOGY DOT ORG WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE CELINE OF OUR LOCAL
AUTHORITY UNDER SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY WITHABOUT EIGHT
MINUTES LEFT EIGHT MINUTES LEFT
ON OUR OPPOSITION EACH SIDE HAS
BEEN GIVEN TWENTY FIVE MINUTES
BUT THAT'S PLEASE PROCEED. WITH
OUR PHONE CALLS. BETTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY
TWO. BY FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY FORTY LEADER
GLAD. ALL RIGHT MAN MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO WE HAVE ABOUT
ELEVEN FOLKS REMAINING IN THE
QUEUE LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY
PLEASE CALL AT. CALLER URINE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT-
PHONE LINE PLEASE MADAM HONORED.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
SEVEN URINE COMMITTEE. MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT LINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN FOUR OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM YOUR IN COMMITTEE
LOUD AND CLEAR PLEASE PROCEED.
AB ORGANIC THE BE A FEW USE
SOCIAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE WE
JOINED THE NINETY SEVEN OTHER
CALLERS. OPPOSING FIVE FIVE SIX
BECAUSE IT'S A HUGE FIRE DANGER
AND IT DOES NOT CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IT WIDENS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY YEAH THAT'S GOING TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON URINE COMMITTEE MIND
RIGHT MY NAME IS NICOLE
MCGINLEY AND I'M CALLING FROM
MALIBU CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED I REPRESENT
OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
RESIDENTS THANKS TO CALL
PRECEDED VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ARE INTO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANDREW HAVE TWEETED
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
OPPOSED SB FIVE OR SIX BOB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANDREW NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
FOR TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO MA'AM THIS IS
GONNA BE FINAL CALL YOU ARE
CURRENTLY IN COMMITTEE WE CAN
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR PLEASE
PROCEED. CAN YOU HEAR ME. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA AT MADAME
MODERATOR WHY DO WE PUT HER ON
HOLD- INCOME BACK TO THAT LINE-
IN ITS PRE PLEASE PROCEED WITH
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT YOU WERE
IN COMMITTEE NOW PLEASE PROCEED.
MY NAME IS MAILING STASSEN FROM
SUNNYVALE I OPPOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME I
SUSAN CAMPBELL AND I AM A
NUCLEAR ENGINEER BY EDUCATION
AND PROFESSION AND THERE'S NO
PUBLIC SAFETY LIMITS FOR THESE
WE CONCEIVED AND NO TESTING AS
A OPERATE ALL TOGETHER AT THE
SAME TIME AS THE LOCATION. OF
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY WE'RE
GONNA LOG THAT IS OPPOSITION
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
BUT THANK YOU VERY THREE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS. TAYLOR I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE WEST TO LOOK A LAKE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION LOS
ANGELES STRONGLY OPPOSED ON
BEHALF OF ALL RESIDENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDER
PERSONNEL GIANNITSA LANTER PAYS
PETALUMA PARENTS FOR SAFE
TECHNOLOGY AND FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR SAFE TECHNOLOGY
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP A
DEEMED THE CURRENT SAFE LEVELS
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR HUNDRED OF
TIMES WHEN THEY WERE ASKING FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
FIRST LAST NAME POSITION ON THE
BILL. AS WELL AS YOUR
AFFILIATION LINDA THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT. FOUR THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANN
KIRKPATRICK I'M WITH BY JEFFREY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER RIGHT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING MODERATOR- WE ARE
NOW GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE I TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ONE
REMIND INDIVIDUALS OF
COMMITTEE- WE HAVE OUR
TECHNICAL WITNESSES WHO WILL BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IF THERE'S ANY
TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS IT CENTER
DODD WOULD LIKE TO READ A
PASSED TO MR REYES IN SUPPORT
MR GRAMM IN OPPOSITION- BUT WE
IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU CENTER
DIED WE LIKE TO HAVE OPEN UP
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO CENTER WINNER
PLEASE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- AND- YOU KNOW
THIS. THIS IS ALWAYS A HARD
ISSUE AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT. HE
FOUR AND ANOTHER A FEW OF US
HERE THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS. FIGHTS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE IN TERMS OF THE
CITING OF- OF CELL SITES IN
INTERNET INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE
WOULD HAVE APPEALS- AT THE-
FORTY SUPERVISORS RIGHT SIR WE
WOULD. I WAS IN VARIOUS
COMMUNITY MEETINGS WHERE WE
WILL BING NEIGHBORS TOGETHER
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
THE PURPOSE CITING SO IT'S NOT
OUTSIDE OF SOMEONE'S. BEDROOM
FOR EXAMPLE. WHICH IS ALWAYS
HARD ISSUES AND IT'S ALSO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THE INTERNET IS AN INTERNET
BROADBAND ACCESS INTERNET
ACCESS IS AT THE HEART OF. SO
MUCH OF MODERN SOCIETY FOR
BETTER FOR WORSE AND THIS
PANDEMIC HAS CERTAINLY-
CERTAINLY- REMINDED US OF THAT
AND I FEEL VERY FORTUNATE THAT-
YOU KNOW IN MY- HOME I HAVE
REALLY YOU KNOW STRONG-
INTERNET ACCESS AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIKE HAD I HAD CRUDDY- YOU KNOW
BROADBAND ACCESS. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IN PARTICULAR AND I
KNOW THAT TRAGICALLY THERE ARE
A HUGE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO DO FRANKLY HAVE CRUDDY.
BROADBAND ACCESS IT IS VERY
VERY DAMAGING IN TERMS OF
WHETHER IT'S REMOTE LEARNING
OR- HELP PEOPLE WORK OR ANY OF
THE OTHER MANY WAYS OF PEOPLE
RELY ON THE INTERNET FOR.
ESSENTIAL SO WE'RE TRYING TO
STRIKE THIS BALANCE- TO SAY WE
NEED TO KEEP BUILDING OUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE SO MANY
SWATHS. OF CALIFORNIA DO HAVE
BAD ACCESS. WHILE ALSO- YOU
KNOW- PLACE AND ASCETICS IN
SAFETY. AND EQUITY AND SO
FORTH- SO THIS BILL I THINK YOU
NEED SOME MORE WORK- BUT I
THINK IT'S HEADED IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION- AND I CAN KNOWLEDGE
OF MY OWN CITY IS OPPOSED TO IT
I RESPECT THAT BUT I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD TODAY- I DO THINK THAT
SOME OF THE ENERGY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WAS I GUESS WE'RE
TAKING. OFFICIALLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE- ARE POSITIVE THAT
WHEN THIS ONE CENTER HUESO OUT
OF A MUCH BROADER VERSION OF
THIS BILL. THREE YEARS AGO. I
KNOW I AM CENTER MCGUIRE AND
OTHERS HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
LOCAL ABILITY TO MANDATE THE
RIGHT DESIGN AND AESTHETICS OR
NOT BEING- DOWNED YOU KNOW IT
IF THE IF THE CITY SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT WE KNOW YOU WANT US
ALSO BUT WE DON'T WANT ON THIS
POLL WE WANT ON THIS POLE
ACROSS THE STREET. HAVING THAT
KIND OF FLEXIBILITY AND I THINK
THIS BILL DOES PROVIDE- AND
AMENDMENTS I THINK. HELP TO
CLARIFY THAT AND STRENGTHEN. BY
THAT I DO- YOU KNOW WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE CITIES HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. GOING FORWARD- I
AM- SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
THE- CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
REYES I HOPE CENTER YOU'LL
GOING TO SIT DOWN WITH. THE
FOLK FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO TALK
THROUGH. THE DETAILS
PARTICULARLY AROUND ON EQUITY
AND I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW
DO WE- MAKE SURE THAT. THIS IS
NOT JUST BEING BUILT ON
WEALTHIER AREAS THAT WE'RE
TRULY BENEFITING LOWER INCOME
AREAS RURAL CALIFORNIA- CAN
ALSO. A SAFETY AND I KNOW THAT
SAN FRANCISCO'S REYES OF MEDIA
SHOW TRAFFIC SIGNALS AND THOSE
POLLS SOMETIMES NOT BEING
APPROPRIATE. FOR CELL SITES AND
I KNOW THERE IS A PROCESS OF
THE BILL OF A- CITY BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A SAFETY ISSUE.
BECAUSE TRAFFIC SIGNALS OF
COURSE FOR FIRST AND FOREMOST
ABOUT TRAFFIC AND PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY. MAKING. SURE THAT THAT
PROCESS WORKS. TOP CITIES
THAT'S I WOULD I. YOU TO. YOU
KNOW- UGH UGH CHAT WITH HER
ABOUT THAT AN- ABOUT TODAY ALL
TO MOVE THIS FOR AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR ALL THE- AT
THE BILL TO SEE WHERE WE ARE AT
ALL THE SIDE HELD IT ON THE
FLOOR- SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WIENER AT CONCERN OVER TO
CENTER DOT TO BE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THOSE I REQUEST- IS
WELLS COMMENTS PLEASE CENTER
DIED. GOD HELP YOU TO TALK TO
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY-
PARTICULARLY ABOUT DIGITAL
EQUITY BENEFITS. IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE AT THE
BEGINNING IT WAS ALL ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL. IT JUST NOW
LATELY AFTER TAKING MOST OF
THESE AMENDMENTS. NOW THAT. THE
TOPIC AT HAND SEEMS TO BE
DIGITAL EQUITY WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I- TALK TO
SENATOR DORADO ABOUT- THIS
MORNING HAPPY TO TALK TO THEM.
I THINK THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE GOING FORWARD
I'M HAPPY TO. CHANGE THE FOCUS-
TO DIGITAL EQUITY BUT ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME WORKING WITH
LOCAL PUBLIC WORKS. AGENCIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
TAKEN CARE OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER DATA LIKE TO GO TO THE
VICE CHAIR THAN TO CENTER DRAWS
OF MISTER VICE CHAIR. THE
GRIFFIN OBSERVATION THE PAID A
BIT OF A PICTURE OF WHAT THE
SENATORS. PROGRESSING WITH.
THAT DOESN'T MESH TO. APPLY TO
SMALL COULD. THIS VERY TINY
SCHOOL IN WESTERN TO HAMMOCK.
BUT DOES. FEW YEARS AGO DISTURB
CAME FUND THE SCHOOL WHEN IT
WAS IN FACT. HE PREVIOUSLY HAD
SHOT. A WOMAN IN A CAR THEN
CAME TO ASSAULT THE SCHOOL
INTENT ON HARMING THE CHILDREN.
IT'S JUST SAY IT WAS TAKEN CARE
OF AND ONLY ONE CHILD GOT
WOUNDED BUT- ONE OTHER PERSON
WAS KILLED. THE POINT OF BEING.
WE ARE NOT IN THAT VERY RURAL
AREA HAD ACCESS. TWO CELLPHONES.
AND IT CERTAINLY DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR COMPANIES TO PUT
ANYTHING OUT THERE. WITH THE
COOPERATION OF A LOCAL PHONE
COMPANY AND AT AND T. WE WERE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
CONNECTIVITY. AND THAT FURTHER
THAN HAD LATER APPLICATION ON A
HUGE FIRE CAME THROUGH THAT
SAME AREA SO WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT LIFE HEALTH AND SAFETY
HERE TOO. ALBEIT AND RURAL
AREAS BUT THE SHOULD BUT BASS
IS ACCESSIBILITY HELP THOSE
AREAS NOT ONLY SAVE LIFE AND
PROPERTY BUT ALSO TO PROSPER
ECONOMICALLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH INTEREST YOUR
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THAT
FORWARD I CENTER DIED ANY ITEMS
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO FROM THE VICE CHAIR BEFORE
WE GO TO SENATOR RAZA- NO I
THINK HE MADE HIS POINT VERY
CLEAR. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU THANKYOU SO MUCH
CENTER DIED CENTER DRAWS A GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU- VERY
MUCH- AS THE AUTHORS SAID- IS
IT THE ISSUE OF ACCESS IS
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE RAISED- I
RECOGNIZE THE GOALS OF THE
AUTHOR AS FAR AS THE INVESTMENT
THAT'S NEEDED IN THIS INDUSTRY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT- ACCESS
IS. OF THE THREE THAT I THINK
THE MR RUDY. VETERANS WITH
SERVICE- MENTIONED BUT- REMOTE
LEARNING HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH ACCESS TELEHEALTH ACCESS
TO THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM- A LOT
OF SO MANY THINGS HAVE NOW COME
UP THAT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO DEVELOP
A WHOLE LOT MORE BUT EVERY TIME
THE TECHNOLOGY COMES UP THERE'S
ALWAYS A DOWNSIDE BECAUSE OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT OR LEFT BEHIND AND SO
WE CANNOT MOVE FORWARD AS FAST
AS WE WANT ON TELEHEALTH
BECAUSE SO MANY COMMUNITIES
DON'T HAVE THAT ACCESS THE SAME
THING GOES THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
ARE RUNNING AHEAD. HERE AND
THEY'RE STILL PEOPLE BEING LEFT
BEHIND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
AND I HAVE A PLACE TO
SACRAMENTO IN BOTH I HAVE WE
GET ACCESS. IT'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT NOT ONLY OUR
RURAL AREAS SO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING- THAT STRONG SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THAT
REASON HOWEVER. I WOULD ALSO
WANT TO ASK YOU TO HONE IN ON
THE ISSUE OF EQUITABLE ACCESS.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO- SAY
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST ACROSS
THE BOARD THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEEDED. ALMOST AND- WHEN
WE SAY HARDEST HIT- DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT WAS CERTAINLY THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND IT DOES. IT THE
PART THAT. CONCERNS ME IS THAT
IF WE TAKE AWAY AS MUCH AS WE
ARE- IN TERMS OF- ABILITY TO
RAISE THE ISSUES FROM THE LOCAL
AREAS. THAT MEAN WE LOSE THE
ABILITY THE LEVERAGE WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL IT TO BE ABLE
TO. GET THESE COMMUNITIES THE
INVESTMENT THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO COME ALONG AS MUCH AS
EVERYBODY ELSE'S SO I REALLY
LOOK FOR A CLEARER- INCLUSION
OF THAT IN THE BILL AND SO- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT. THE SAFETY
ISSUES ARE IN THE HANDS OF THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS RIGHT. YES
OKAY SO. THAT'S WHAT I ASK OF
YOU AND THE- AND THE PROVIDERS
THAT WERE IN THIS CONVERSATION
WITH THANK YOU THANK YOU-
PLEASE CENTER DRAWS- APPRECIATE
THAT- YOU'VE GOT MY COMMITMENT
THAT THAT. WILL BE WORKING ON
IT I WOULD LIKE HISTORY IS TO.
COMMENT ON THAT THOSE TO SEE-
WHAT THAT THEY MAY HAVE IN
STORE AS WE SIT HERE AT THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY.
MYSTERIES ARE GONNA HAVE YOU DO
A QUICKLY PLEASE. SENATOR
GRASSO SENATOR WIENER KIND OFA
TALE OF TWO CITIES- WE'VE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH MAYOR
GARCETTI. TO BRING. FIVE G.
ACROSS THE CITY WE'RE SEEING
BLINKING RED DEMAND. A CROSS
THE CITY MORE DEMAND IN LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAN IN
WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES FIVE G.
WITH THE LAST MILE NOT HAVING
TO DIG UP THE STREET ALL THE
WAY TO THE PREMISE OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT
DEMAND. IN SAN FRANCISCO MY
HOME TOWN- IT'S THE IT'S THE
OPPOSITE WE HAVE A PLAN TO
COVER FIVE G. ACROSS THE CITY
INCLUDING IN HISTORICALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED AREAS BAYVIEW
HUNTERS POINT TENDERLOIN. AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
GENTLEMAN FROM BY MY HOME
TOWN'S CITY HALL THE ONLY THING
HOLDING US BACK IS CITY HALL.
AND IF WE COULD GET AN
AGREEMENT THAT COMPLIES WITH
FCC REGULATIONS WE WILL BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY FIVE G. ACROSS THE
CITY THANK YOU IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR AS YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
ALL RIGHT I DO WE JUST SIT IN
THEIR EQUAL TIME RULE HERE
TODAY I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO-
AND AGAIN JUST BECAUSE WE
PROMISE EQUAL TIME MISTER
ROBERTS- FROM THE SITTING
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO- YOU HAVE
SIXTY SECONDS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BE TO RESPOND- IN OUR EQUAL
TIME RULE. MISTER ROBERTS. YES
WE'RE WE'RE AWARE OF-
PRINCETON'S CONCERNS- AND ARE
WORKING WITH THEM ON THE
DRESSING. SO- YEAH AND THE
INDIGO WELL BEYOND- PROVIDING
TWO- EXCAVATION OTHER
TRANSACTIONS SEVERAL- BUT WE
ARE WORKING ON THOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS BRIAN
ROBERTSON CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE HEARD EARLIER
FROM THE RANGE OF HOUSING
PRICES THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MISTER GRAHAM SECONDS SINCE
MISTER ROBERTS AND AGAIN WE'RE
DOING EQUAL TIME TO THIRTY
SECOND SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS ARE JUST TWO
QUICK THINGS WHEN THEY INSTALL
FIBER OPTIC CABLES THEY DO NOT
DIG UP THE STREETS. THAT'S NOT
THE WAY IT'S DONE THE YOU DO
NOT DIG UP THE STREETS LOOK AT
THE TECHNOLOGY GOES IN THE
RIGHT AWAY THERE'S A MACHINE
THERE'S NO IMPACT WHATSOEVER TO
THE STREETS. AND THIS DOES NOT
COMPLY WITH THE FCC ORDER OR
ANY OF SEE THROUGH ORDER
EFFECTED BLATANTLY CONFLICTS
WITH THE FCC ORDERS FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS RECENTLY
CONFIRMED BY THE CASE I
MENTIONED CITY PORTLAND VERSUS
UNITED STATES AND CONFLICTS
WITH THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT
OF NINETEEN NINETY SIX. WHICH
PRESERVES LOCAL ZONING
AUTHORITY. THE SYSTEM IS
PRESENTLY WORKING JUST ALLOW IT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN HIS
REFUSAL WILL HAVE THE ACCESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE BOTH YOU MISTER IS
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR WOULD LIKE YOU TO SEE
IF THERE IS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECEIVE THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR WERE LOOKING FOR MOTION
FOR WITH THE MOTION BY MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG. WE'RE GOING
TO ASK MISTER DODD TO PLEASE
CLOSE. BUT JUST QUICKLY- MISTER
CHAIR THERE WAS OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORTS. EMAILS
IN ON THIS- OBVIOUSLY- NOT ALL
WANTING TO- YOU KNOW CALL IN
TODAY. I APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE THAT HAPPENED HERE I
TAKE SERIOUSLY. WORKING WITH US
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS AND YOU'VE
GOT MY COMMITMENT. AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD TO CONTINUE THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DIED
IN AGAIN AS I SAID THE CENTER
DIED ALL ALONG VERY GRATEFUL
FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT HE'S BEEN
VERY SINCERE WITH ALL MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. INCLUDING
MYSELF IN VERY EARLY ON AS WELL
WHICH I THINK WE ALL
APPRECIATE. AND I SEE SHARED
WITH MEMBERS- I WILL BE.
OPPOSED TO DAY. BASED OFF OF
SUGGEST ON GOING CONCERNS AND-
CENTER DODD HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE
IN REGARDS TO. HIS OUTREACH.
WILL INVADE PROVIDE INFORMATION
IN TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
SINNER DIED PLEASE MR NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AS
WELL AS- THE- THE MOTION AND
MEMBERS. ARE FREE TO VOTE AS
THE ONE OF A- THE MOTION IS
PASS AS A MAN. BUT FIRST A MAN
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MCGUIRE YEAH MCGUIRE NO SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI A SENATOR
DRAWS SO. ZERO ZERO FIVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
SORRY SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI
FORTY ONE FORTY ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER
DIED THANK YOU TO OUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT REALLY GRATEFUL-
VERY MUCH THANK YOU TO OUR
WEAKNESS IN OPPOSITION AS WELL
AND TO ALL THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN.
HANGING WITH US ON THE LINE WE
ARE SO APPRECIATIVE ALL RIGHT
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA
QUICKLY GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
THAT'S S. B. E. TWENTY AT
CENTER DOT YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO PROVIDE A
TRUNCATED STATEMENT A PLEASE
ENTER DODD. RECEIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH
DETERRENT IS GIVE US A TO.
THIRTY SECONDS REVIEW OF WHAT
THE BILL DOES. I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS NOTED ON PAGE THREE
OF THE ANALYSIS INTAKE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK.
SB EIGHT TWENTY IS A GEO
COMMITTEE BILL THAT SIMPLY
INCLUDES CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO
LEGISLATION FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN REQUIRING A SPECIFIED
PERCENTAGE OF SALES TAX
REVENUES. PRODUCED ON THE
PROPERTY OF A STATE DESIGNATED
FEARED TO BE SEGREGATED
ALLOCATED AFFAIRS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I JUST WANTED MOMENT
SAY THANK YOU SET OUT FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
CLARIFICATION AS WELL TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY- WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO WE DON'T EVER LEAD WITNESS
WE DO EVER LEAD WITNESS ON THE
LINE TO LET'S GO TO OUR LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THIS IS CODY
BOILS FROM THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION. MR BOILS YOU DO
HAVE THREE MINUTES BUT I WANT
TO REITERATE YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW ON EIGHT TWENTY SO
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PROVIDE A TRUNCATED STATEMENT.
MR BOILS THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OUT I TOO WOULD LIKE TO- ECHO
THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS AND THANK.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS
SENATE GOP STAFFER TO WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THAT THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HELP THANK YOU
HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
BOSS WHO WATCHES STATE FAIRS
ASSOCIATION. THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS
LOGGED TWO DAYS A WEEK BACK
TODAY TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN ROOM. FORTY TWO OF THREE I'M
NOT A SUPPORT HEARING KNOWN AS
STAND UP WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SENATORS
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
KNOWN AS IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. NOT A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ASK
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY. TWO PLEASE
QUEUE. UP NOW MADAME MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE TO SPEAK
IN STEP. OF S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
MODERATOR- WE ARE NOT GOING TO
GO. INTO OPPOSITION ON SB
EIGHTY TWENTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE A ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
HEARING SEEING KNOWN RIGHTS ARE
NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY LONELY
OVER THERE AT KNOWN AS IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MATTER MODERATOR
BACK TO YOU IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TO OF ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT TWENTY NOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. E. TWENTY
NOT A MODERATOR. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN HERE WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING FOR TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THEN MADE
BUT BAKER. BUT OUR- I AM SO
SORRY SIR YOU HAVE A BAD
CONNECTION WE'RE GETTING ABOUT
EVERY OTHER WORD I'M SO SORRY
ABOUT THAT SIR IF YOU WANT TO
TRY CALLING BACK QUICKLY AND
NOT NOT A MODERATE. OKAY I'M
GOOD NOW. MY NAME DO YOU HEAR
ME BUT YOU WERE NO GOOD
GOVERNMENT HAD SIR. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MARSHA FREE
PROFESSION ARCHITECT. I LIVE IN
HEALDSBURG CALIFORNIA. WIRESS
FACILITIES MUST STAY ON THERE
WHEN YOU TO BOTHER I'M SO SORRY
ABOUT A MODERATOR THIS IS WRONG
BILLS- I REALLY APOLOGIZE AND I
DON'T WANT TO INTERRUPT YOU WE
DO TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY
PREVIOUSLY AND- ON SP FIVE FIVE
SIX IS A WE DID LOG YOUR
TESTIMONY. BUT WE'VE NOW MOVED
ON TO SB EIGHT TWENTY SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BANCOR
THANK YOU ARE TRIED FOR FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOR
FIFTY SECURING COMMITTEE. THIS
IS PAUL WHEELER FROM CLAREMONT
CALIFORNIA I AM AN ARCHITECT
AND SHE WAS MY WIFE WE NEED
LOCAL CONTROL FOR PLANNING WE
GET THAT WE NEED MORE BEDS WE
HAVE TO WORK IT OUT OURSELVES
BUT WE BUILD A INCREDIBLY
DESIRABLE TOWN ALL RIGHT AND WE
TAKE THE MATTER HOW LIBERAL OR-
SIR I REALLY APOLOGIZE. MISTER
WHEELER WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU
HOLD BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE CON
IN ANOTHER BILL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THAT FIGURES- IN FAIR
REVENUES SO- I APOLOGIZE SIR
BUT- MISTER WHEELER- HOLD
TIGHT. THE MODERATOR WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU BETTER
MODERATOR I'M GONNA HAVE YOU DO
A REMINDER ON WHAT BILL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW SO. IF
YOU COULD JUST DO A REMINDER
WERE TAKING OPPOSITION AND I'VE
SB EIGHT TWENTY AND IF YOU CAN
PLEASE LET FOLKS KNOW THIS IS
THE FINAL CALL. FOR OPPOSITION
ON SP TWENTY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME NOT A MODERATOR THANK SO
MUCH WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN
JUST A BIT WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER. MOTION TO APPROVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. NINETY NINE CENTER
W. LIKE TO CLOSE. BACK WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. HI MISTER NOW IF
YOU CAN PLEASE STATE THE MOTION
AND CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE FIVE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIS SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO HI A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG FIVE
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI. IN A
BIPARTISAN PORTLY GENTLEMAN. MR
DARDEN THANK YOU A VERY
GRATEFUL THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOONER. THANK YOU. LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO. LAW BILL THAT IS IN OUR-
SPECIAL FILE ORDER THIS IS OUR
OR HEARING TAKING SENATE BILL
NINE SENATE BILL AT FIVE FIVE
SIX AND NOW SENATE BILL TEN IF
YOU WERE WANTING TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK ON SENATE BILL TEN WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE Q.
WHAT NOW. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO IS-THE NUMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL TEN
PLEASE DIAL. 877-226-8152 AND
HIT THAT CODE THAT IS ON YOUR
SCREEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. THAT LAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE WHAT WE'VE
ACTIVATED DO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS RIGHT
AFTER WE HEAR IS SENATE BILL
TEN A BRIEF BIO BREAK FOR
COMMITTEE AT SENATOR WIENER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. ON SENATE BILL
TEN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- I WANT
TO. START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL FOR THE SECOND
YAR IN A ROW- AND HAPPY TO
TAKE THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT-
THAT APPEARS- EXCEPT THE
TECHNICAL MOMENT THAT APPEARS
IN THE ANALYSIS- SENATE BILL
TEN COLLEAGUES IS A-
REINTRODUCTION OF LAST YEAR'S
SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO THAT
WAS PASSED BY THE SENATE- THIS
BILL. IS HAS BEEN SELECTED AS
PART OF SENATE. ARE SENATE
LEADER SENATOR ATKINS- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SENATE LEADERSHIP
HOUSING PACKAGE. AND I'M
HONORED THAT SENATOR ATKINS HAS
SIGNED ON TO SB TEN AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. BY THIS
LEGISLATION AND- INCENTIVIZES
AND PROVIDES TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONCENTRATE NEW.
HOUSING AND URBAN INFILL AND
JOB IN TRANSIT RICH
COMMUNITIES- BY GIVING THEM A
POWERFUL NEW TOOL- TO ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH THAT REZONING-
SPECIFICALLY- SB TEN WILL
ALLOW. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IF
THEY CHOOSE AND THEY DON'T HAVE
TO THE VOLUNTARY TOOL- TO- ZONE
FOR UP TO TEN YEAR TO-
BUILDINGS. IN THESE NON SPRAWL
AREAS INFILL AREAS JOB FOR.
RICH AND TRANSIT RICH. AREAS
NEED TO BE VERY VERY CLEAR.
THAT SB TEN IS A PURE. LOCAL
CONTROL BUILT. HI NO CITY WERE.
TO USE TO. AND SB TIME- CITY
CAN IGNORE SB TIME DO NOTHING
AND THE BILL WILL HAVE NO
IMPACT IN THAT CITY. THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY MEASURE THAT CREATES
A NEW POWERFUL NEW VOLUNTARY
TOOL. FOR CITIES- TO REZONE FOR
MORE HOUSING TO MEET THEIR
HOUSING NEEDS. I THINK THAT
THERE IS A COMMON MISCONCEPTION
THAT ALL CITIES ARE OPPOSED TO
NEW HOUSING A NEW DENSITY THERE
ARE CITIES THAT ARE- BUT THERE
ARE ALSO CITIES THAT WANT TO
ZONE FOR MORE HOUSING- AND
RIGHT NOW WE MAKE IT VERY HARD
IN MY FEE FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
S. B. TOWN WILL GIVE THEM AN
EXPEDITED MORE- EFFICIENT WAY
OF DOING NOT VOLUNTARY REZONING-
THE SERVICE- BILL HAS A REAL
POTENTIAL TO HELP CITIES. BUT
DO WHAT WE ASK THEM TO DO WE
ASK CITIES TO ZONE FOR MORE
HOUSING WE DO IT TO RENEW-
CETERA- LET'S GIVE THEM A TOOL.
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT MORE
EFFECTIVELY- I WANT TO BE CLEAR
SB TEN DOES NOT CHANGE HOW
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS ARE
APPROVED IT SIMPLY REZONING
BILL- AND ONCE THE REZONING
HAPPENS EACH PROJECT WILL GO
THROUGH WHATEVER. THE LOCAL OR
STATE APPROVAL PROCESS IS- FOR
THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT- SO
COLLEAGUES ARE WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- IS RICARDO FLORES IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LISK SAID
SAN DIEGO. AND ZACHARY HAMILTON
WHO IS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
AND GILROY CALIFORNIA
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS CENTER WINNER
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT TO US SO LAYS IN
GERMAN THIS BILL WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
EQUAL TIME FOR BOTH SIDES SO
WHAT WE'VE ACTIVATED DO. IS
WE'RE GONNA TAKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE SO THE CLOCK
WILL START THE TECH WHEN WE
HAVE THE FOR THE FIRST LEAD
SUPPORT. AND FIRST LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS A TOTAL OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THAT INCLUDES
OUR LEAD WITNESSES SO LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN LET'S. MOVE INTO
OUR TO LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
IT'S IT RICARDO FLORES FIRST
FROM LIST SAN DIEGO IN INTO
COUNCILMEMBER HAMILTON MISTER
FLORES YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE OR
THREE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. PLEASE
PROCEED WELCOME. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THEM.
BECAUSE LOUDER I NEED. DIRECTOR
THE LIST SAN DIEGO THE NATIONAL
NON. DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL.
RIGHT MOVEMENT TRUE IN THE- NOT
JUST WHAT WE NEED TO PLAY A
CRANE WHERE WE LIVE WHO KIDS
GROW UP WITH. BUT IN ORDER TO
HOLD THIS COMIC YOU MUST CRAZY.
NOT CAREER LIKE JOHN LEWIS
TWENTY AT PATTERSON. THE
PHYSICAL GROUP OF. ON THE
OTHERS. THE GREAT TO DO WHAT
YOU KNOW WAS. I AM THAT YOU AND
THE CURRENT APART AND LIKE SAN
DIEGO AND ALLOW GROUPS WITH IN
OUR PART- LEAGUE THE YOU KIND
OF. IN OTHERS THE BILL. PROVIDE
HOME AND HIGH WELL LOCAL NAY
FOR. HOODS BUT I YOU TO BE
IT'LL BE. BY LAW THE BILL
DESPITE OF HOW THE AND LOW HIGH
WELL. THINK ABOUT THAT. YEAH
EACH OF YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TODAY WITH A SIMPLE BUTTON TO
END THE REMOTE IN OUR CITY
ENHANCE RESTORE PROPERTY RIGHT
AND SET IN MY A WORLD THAT YOU
NEVER SEE BUT ONE IN MY ALREADY
KNOW MY COME TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE VERY
GOOD FORMATIVE APPRECIATE YOUR-
TO THAT TO RECALL FLORES FROM
LIST SENIOR WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO IS A- CAMO. MISTER
COUNCILMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TAKE THE TIME COMING US
LIVE FROM THE- YOUR- YOU HAVE
MINUTES IN SUPPORT OF SB. TEN
HELLO AND BACON COMMITTEE J.
MEMBERS. IN A PUBLIC AND THAT
BUILDING RESIDENT GORY. HOW DO
NOT. AND A GILROY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER. WE ARE CALLING CRISIS
IN THE DREAM OWNING A IS NOT A
REALISTIC UP. FOR EVERY.
MESSAGES TO PROMOTE THE- OF
MORE AFFORD HOUSING ALL. INCOME
LEVELS WHILE LOOKING TOWARDS
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS AND- I HAD
STRUGGLES WITH HOW THE NET OUR
LITTLE. GROW AS A FIREFIGHTER
IN THE AREA I WAS IN A TO
AFFORD A HOME WHERE I WORK. I
AM STILL WORKING IN THE BAY
AREA IN THE COMMUTER SOMETIMES
AN HOUR AND A HALF OR LONGER.
OVER THE PAST YEARS ARE
EXPERIENCE. BEING HAD LET ME TO
BE A HOUSING I MAKE IT. ENJOY
ANOTHER ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
OREGON. ARE THE REGION. AND
TALKING TO THOUSAND CRISIS. IS
NOT MINUTE CYCLE GOING TO TAKE
SOME GREAT. ON HOW COULD. AND
AN INCREASE BROAD THE BIG ONE.
WE CAN'T GROW ONE IMAGE OF OUR-
IT DON'T. OKAY HOME. AT THE
LOCAL. AND GO RIGHT IT IS OUR
BEEN MENTION A MEETING WE NEED
TO LOOK AT ME. MEDINA HOUSING.
YOU THE TRI PLEX IMPORTANT THIS.
CALIFORNIA DESCENDED INTO A
SEPTIC. HOUSING CRISIS. IN TO
MAXIMIZE. I OF STATE. CHIRAG
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT. RIGHT RIGHT
LEVELS OF CRIME HOMELESS. AND A-
CLASS OF LOS INCOME. UNABLE
AFFORD OR ACCESS HOUSING WITH
INSTEAD. HOURS OF THEIR- SB TWO
OF THIS. BILL THE AUTHOR. UNDER
SECRET I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AT
THE TEN WHICH IS THE WHICH IS
NOT CHANGED LOCAL HEIGHT LIMIT
THAT BACK. OBJECTIVE DESIGNED.
HISTORICALLY ARE DONE.
RESTRICTION SB TEN. THE PATH TO
ATTY MATA DE. TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SO. RESERVES THE- LOCAL
CONTROL FOR LOW DRESSER. AND
MAKE THAT. LET AND LESS RISKY
PER. UNDERTAKEN COMMUNITY. TO
INCREASE DENSITY OUR- AT THE
END OF THE- STEP FORWARD IN
PICKING WHAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO.
PROBLEM THROUGHOUT- OUR ENTIRE
STAY. THANK YOU AND INCLUDES I
REACHED. ASK I. ABOUT. CONSUMER
YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE FONG TODAY
PLEASE SHARE TESTIMONY. WITH
THIS FLORIDA THAT'S HIM COUNTY
MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF GO
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT LAZY. WORD
GOING TO SEE THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE. SPEAK IN SOME
OF THIS BILL IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. HEARING SENIOR WE'RE NOT
TO GO TO OUR OVER. ROOM THAT'S
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE IS NO
ONE CRICKET IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. FOUR NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR- PHONE LINES. WE'RE GOING
TO ASK IN. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK. SOME OF SB TWO. TO
PLEASE PROVIDE FIRST AND LAST
NAME. YOUR FIFTH PHILLY. AS
WELL AS YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA ASK
MY- MAY MODERATE. TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP IN. IN SO. OF SO BILL
TEN. NOW MATAMATA. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TEN. PLEASE PRESS. AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU LIKE THE
CALLING TODAY SO SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT. FIVE TWO THE FOR
NUMBER LOOKING FOR SUPPORT FOR
AND TEN THAT PHONE NUMBER IN IS
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW A MODERATOR
THAT'S GO TO WORK. THANK YOU
RECORD HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN Q.
REPORTER TO IN. GO THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE WITH THEN ON BEHALF
OF THE MINOR COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS AND BUT- SOME FOR
YOUR FOR CALL WERE TO GO TO
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
TWENTY. PLEASE GO OUT. HELLO
THIS IS OUR OF SAN BRUNO SENATE
JUST ARE SPEAKING ON THE OF-
URBAN AND BY IN FAVOR THE
CLIMATE AND IN THE HOUSE CRISIS
I STILL SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
PRESHEAF THAT COLOR. THANK YOU
VERY TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M A BIG PART OF IT YOU CAN'T
BUT IT'S BETWEEN REPS ANY
THOUGHT INDIA PRODUCE S. TEN.
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM LOOK HEARING
FOR ME JUST A BIT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS FEEL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THIS
MEASURE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
DAVE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI ALISON SCHALLERT UP CO
FOUNDER OF STORIES FROM THE
LINE UP QUITE A HOLLYWOOD
FLORIDA THIRTY FOUR GROUPS ARE
NOT PART GROUP AND IN. AND WE
ARE ALL ALONG WITH HUNDREDS OF
MY- DR PART OF I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PHONE CALL FOR THE
PEACE THAT THAT'S GOOD OR NOT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR TWO
CALL AT. I'M FORTY TWO
COMMITTEE PLEASE FOR. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OUR CALLER WRITER.
RIGHT WHAT EIGHTY SIX TO GO
AHEAD. CALL COMMITTEE. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LIKE
TO SEE WE'VE GOT. I MEDICARE
THE PUBLIC FROM ANY DAY IF THE
LIFE HEALTH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING THE PORT IN BUT THE LAW
COALITION INCLUDES THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL CALIBER IN THE-
BURKE HE HE PARTNER THAT THE
COLOR. DANIEL PROP THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL ACCOUNT AND BILL BILL
HOUSING ACT COLOR. AT THE END
HOME ALL HOME AND HAS A THIRTY
OF NORTH CALIFORNIA AND
FACEBOOK ALL OF THE FOR REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
THINKING SO MUCH GOT OR CALLER.
THANK YOU AND FORCE. TWO GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS CAN BE DONE BEHALF
OF THE K. BUILDING IN RESEARCH
LOS. STONE SUPPORT BILL THANK
YOU THE YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR FOUR PLEASED
AHEAD. MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
FLOOR ABLE AND STATE REP THE
OTHER PLANNING AT THIS THAT'S-
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THE CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS TERREL CHEN IN
OPPOSITE THIS IS A- GOOD TO
BILL. FILE OUR RIGHTS IN THE
COUNTRY TO WHAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PHONE CALL TODAY TO
YOU SO LAYS IN GERMAN CAN WE
MAY HAVE SOME FOR WHO ARE IN
OFFICE TO GET SUPPORT OF FOLK
ARE AND TO NOT IT'S A GOOD. WE
WELCOME YOUR PHONE IT'S ASK
NEXT COLORFUL. THANK YOU RIGHT
THIRTY PLEASED AHEAD. HELLO
MANY MISTY CALLING FOR UNION
CITY INTENT. TEN OUT OF THE
WOULD BE SAFER IN SUPPORT OF SB
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
HEARING COMMITTEE PLEASE FOR C.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MINIMUM ORDER.
THANK YOU THREE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HENRY OKAY I'M CALLING TO
REPRESENT MEMBERSHIP CENTER
COMMUNITY THE TWELVE SANTA CRUZ
SENIORS DROUGHT. JOHNSON COURT
OF SB TEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS WILL SOON SELL CHARLIE
AGENCY CALLING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I AM NOT LOOKING AT
THE STATE LIMIT APARTMENTS FROM
FOR THIS BILL. YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU BYE NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
COFFEE BEANS AND FROM ON OF
EVERYONE AND IN THE ACTION IN
STRONG COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU I FOUR
NINE ONE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
TURNED MEMBERS BACK YOU CAN'T
YOU WITH UNITED WAY'S
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MATTHEW. NEXT LINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU I FOR SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DAVID WALTON ON THE NUMBER
OF NON BEAUTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THAT'S BECAUSE THANKS SO
MUCH DAVID LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MINIMUM ORDER. AS YOU
ALL RIGHT FOR NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS REBECCA AUBURN I'M A
RESIDENT UNION ALLEY AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF INTER
COUNTY YOU'D BE STRONG
SUPPORTER SB CAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHOE CALL TODAY.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AYE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
I'M BAFFLING- FROM ALAMEDA
COLLEEN OR PRESENT I DON'T NEED
A FOR EVERYONE IN THE ACTION.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH WITH ABOUT THREE MINUTES
LEFT FOR THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
LINE WANTING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WITH ABOUT THREE
MINUTES LEFT LET'S CONTINUE
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. INDEPENDENT A
STUDENT CURRENTLY IN COUNTRIES
CALIFORNIA COOLING IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AT TEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOR SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I TELL ME MARCHAND
O'CONNOR FROM LOS ANGELES ON
BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS THANKS
FOR CALLING IN NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I ONE FORTY
TWO PLEASE CALL. KEVIN ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE NINETY FIVE YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE. SIX LINE PLEASE.
FOUR SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ARJUN COSTUME I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE- EXPRESSED MY STRONG.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THAT PHONE CALL NEXT
CALL. THANK YOU AREN'T SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIXTY SEVEN YEAR INCLUDING
SATURDAY THE BEGINNING. PLEASE
PROCEED. BUT TRIED FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MATTHEW LEWIS I'M A
HOMEOWNER AND A GROUP OF
HOMEOWNERS FROM SOUTH BERKELEY
REPRESENTS OUT WE NOW ENDURE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MAKE MORE
HOMES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS NEAR
OUR HOMES THANK YOU THANKS
MATTHEW NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT. FOR EIGHTY
SIX. I'M SORRY RIGHT RIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DEVIN STROKING FROM
SCRATCH CALIFORNIA SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITHOUT ONE MINUTE LEFT MENTAL
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWENTY FIVE FIVE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BYE FOR SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. INTRO TO
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. M. COUGHLIN
FROM LAPTOP- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOGLE WITH AN
INDIAN STRONG SUPPORT HAPPIER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAMANTLY ITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA TAKE TWO MORE
CALLERS THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THE OPPOSITION ONE
ADDITIONAL MINUTE JUST AS WE'RE
GIVING ONE MINUTE IN ADDITION
TO SUPPORT. TO MORE CALLERS.
PLEASE MADAM MODERATOR IN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN I'LL BE
HAVE A GREAT HOUSING AT THE
COURT THANK YOU THINK ANY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THIS WILL BE OUR
FINAL EIGHT THANK YOU RIGHT
FIVE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS PUBLIC MORE-
CALLING- ABOUT THIS THROUGH
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
LAYS IN GERMAN COMMITTEE WE ARE
NOW AT SIXTEEN MINUTES SIXTEEN
MINUTES. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
THAT WE DO HAVE A FEW WHO WERE
IN OPPOSTION AS WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND ADDITIONAL
MINUTES AGAIN EQUAL TIME HERE
IN GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. JUST WANT TO COMMEND
OUR MODERATOR TO DAVID A
MODERATOR YOU DOING A FABULOUS
JOB. IN MOVING FAST AS WELL. SO
AT LAYS IN GERMAN WE ARE NOW
GOING TO PUT SIXTEEN MINUTES ON
TO THE CLOCK WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. WE ONLY HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON FILE BUT
I BELIEVE THAT WE MAY HAVE TO-
HERE WITH- MISCELLANY IN THE
ROOM. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
FIRST AND FOREMOST. THE ANTHONY
HELTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION MR HELP NEAR.
THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY HELPS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PLANT. TITLE ASSOCIATION. WHAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION DUE TO
CONCERNS THAT THE- BILL WOULD
ALLOW FOR CHANGES TO- REAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS NOT REFLECT THE
DENTAL RECORDS. WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE- AUTHORS
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
THE SPONSOR AND OTHER STAFF TO
WORK WITH US ON THE ISSUE. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OUT A
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. I THINK
ANY HELP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LAND TITLE. MR HELTON THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR FINAL-
IN SECOND- LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S GOING TO BE
TO WEAR AND THE HAND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. BUILDING TRADES I
MISS THE HAND THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROBLEM. AFTERNOON I WILL BE
BRIEF ERIN LANE ON BEHALF OF
THE HALF A MILLION MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL- IN OPPOSITION AND LESS
THIS BILL AS AMENDED TO TAKE
IT- INTO CONCERN- TAKE INTO
EFFECT THE CONCERNS OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR STAYING
VERY GRATEFUL THAT WE PREVIEW
HANGING WITH US HERE TODAY THEY
SAID THEY WERE NOT GOING TO GO
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FIRST AND LAST NAME- NAME
EXCUSE THE FIRST AND LAST NAME.
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
WE'RE GONNA START HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO A THREE HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER WEST WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BUT CHECK IN WITH ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THERE. ABSOLUTELY NOT
SO LAYS IN GERMAN GUESS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS ZERO SO WE'RE
GOING TO THE PHONES SO WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO THE PHONES IF
YOU TO ACTIVATE A CALLING EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU- META
MODERATORS CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IN SUPPORT. EXCUSE ME IN
OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION OF
SENATE BILL TEN. NOW THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO. AND OF S. TEN
THE PLEASE. ONE AND THEN ZERO
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FORTY IN Q.
BORDERLINE FOR NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MICHAEL KONIG HOUSING
CHAIR ELECT OF THE HOLLYWOOD
HILLS WEST NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED IN OUR
COMMUNITY ABOUT SB TEN
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE LACK OF
PROTECTIONS FOR THANK YOU SIR
TO CONNECTING WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL- AND NOT AT ALL TRYING
TO CUT FOLKS OFF I JUST WANNA
REMIND INDIVIDUALS AS WE GO
INTO THIS SECTION OF OPPOSITION
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOLKS TO
PLEASE. STATE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AGAIN
NOT TRYING TO CUT FOLKS OFF
WERE REALLY APPRECIATIVE THAT
YOU'RE HANGING WITH US LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STACY
SILENT AND I'M REPRESENTING
NICHOLS CANYON AND WHERE
MEMBERS UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE
OPPOSE SB TEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU RIGHT FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ERIN BURNED WITH THE
MODESTY TO ASSOCIATION WE ARE
AT THE END THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FIVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE TERM MEMBERS RANGE MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED AS DESCRIBED IN OUR
LETTER TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. BRING GOOD
TO HEAR VOICE THANK YOU NEXT
CAR PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
FIVE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
EILEEN NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAILING
STAFF AND ON BEHALF OF UNITED
I'M SORRY ON BEHALF OF
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE WE ARE MEMBER
OF UNITED NEIGHBORS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR SEVENTY
PLEASE GLAD. MY NAME IS AMY
WITH THEM THANK YOU WITH THE L.
OF BY A REPRESENTING ALL
RESIDENTS OF WHAT THE LIVES AND
MARK MANDELA AND AFFILIATED
WITH UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU AMY PRITCHETT
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER YOU'RE
IN COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE RUN A
MODERATOR. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOW ARE YOUR IN COMMITTEE. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GERMAN MEMBERS AGAIN
YOUR AUNT'S WEEK HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION ANDREW
THANKS SO MUCH YEAH I THINK AT
ANDREW'S BEEN WITH US FOR EVERY
BILL SO FAR SO HE'S- DIDN'T
START TODAY SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND YOU'RE GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR VOICE AGAIN. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY READABLE I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN. REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AYE
LUNCH HADN'T PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AARON COMMITTEE CARD. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
MINIMIZE WRITER. RIGHT FOR
EIGHTY PLEASE CALL AT. YES MY
NAME IS MARK DOT REPRESENTING
SINGLE FAMILY HOME OWNERS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS. BOB THIS BILL
WILL BE STORY SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE PARTY SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY SIR
WE'RE GONNA LOG THT AS
OPPOSITION WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOU CALLING IN TODAY. WE'RE
GONNA REMIND FOLKS IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE YOUR FIRST LAST
NAME THE AFFILIATION IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL CURRENTLY WERE
SEEKING OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL TEN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE AT A MODERATOR. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE A PARABLE CAL
BENJAMIN OAKS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE OPPOSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI DOUGLAS CASE SIR
RETHINK CANADA FOR CITY COUNCIL.
NUMBER OF LIBERAL COUNTY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
CAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINE FORTY
TWO URINE COMMITTEE. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. BY TWO TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT COLOR
YOUR COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT NOW
TOMORROW OR NEXT THE GUARD HAD
PLEASE DURING COMMITTEE.
BARKERVILLE RESIDENTS CROSS
CITY SANTA MONICA WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB TEN THANK YOU MARK
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
LISTEN GENERAL COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A LITTLE OVER SIX MINUTES
SIX MINUTES LEFT FOR OPPOSITION
BUT TO KEEP THE LINES COMING
THAT A MODERATOR THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. AS YOU LIKE
FIVE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANDRA DAHLE DISTRICT FIFTEEN
NUMBER OF FAMILIES IN SATURDAY
WITH STRONG OPPOSITION. HE
SANDRA NEXT CALL OF. THANK YOU
RIGHT THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS JOHN WELBORN
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE WINDSOR
SQUARE IT SAYS THE ATION OF
ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED HOMES
STRONGLY OPPOSES THIS PROPOSAL
BEST BE TEN THANK YOU JOHN GOOD
TO HEAR YOUR VOICE AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIS GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALLER YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE.
NEXT LINE PLEASE READ IN ORDER.
AS YOU RIGHT FOR SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SANDY HUBBARD I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE VALLEY VILLAGE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS REALLY ENDED
WITH OVABLE CALIFORNIA WE'RE
OPPOSED TO SP TENANTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HE TAKEN
THE TIME. TO GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. AS YOU RIGHT ON OUT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAREERING
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OUR NEXT LINE AND A
MODERATOR. AS YOU LIKE FIVE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
WHEATLEY WITH LEVEL CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL KELLY. AND I WOULD
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL SB TEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIVE FIFTEEN YEAR AND COMMITTEE.
BUT A MODERATOR THAT'S ROLE
DURING EXCELLENT. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIVE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE OH SIX HEARING
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN THE
PAULA ONE FINAL RESIDENT OF
REDONDO BEACH IS A MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS OPPOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING WITH US
TODAY NO IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ELIZABETH HENRY
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF
SAVE SAVE LAFAYETTE UNITED
NEIGHBORS ANALYTICAL CALIFORNIA
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB TEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY WERE REALLY GRATEFUL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIVE OH WAIT HE'S GLAD. MY NAME
IS KERRY SHARPE- REPRESENTING-
STRATFORD SQUARE ASSOCIATION
AND INSIDE BURKE STRONGLY
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR OPPOSITION
WE APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
TODAY THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
YEAH ARCHITECT BUT ANY CREASES
DENSITY IN ALREADY DENSE AND
MOSTLY BY PARTLY BECAUSE
WITHOUT PROVISIONS FOR
ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM
I OPPOSED TO TEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT FOR THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT SO WITH
MISSION STREET NEIGHBORS WERE
PROBABLE CALIFORNIA AND- UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAREERING COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT LINE. LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M DEMóCRATAS I REPRESENT
BERKELEY TOGETHER AN
ORGANIZATION A BERKELEY TENANTS
AND HOMEOWNERS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB CAN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DEBORAH APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT FOR
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHECK READ WITH THE TO LOOK
ALIKE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
AND MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN
JUST STOP. THANK YOU SO MUCH
JEFF APPRECIATE NOT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWENTY FIVE YEAR AND COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT MADAM MODERATOR LET'S
CHECK IN WITH OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SIXTY
THREE YEAR AND COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT NOT A MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA PUT THAT EXTRA MINUTE ON
THE CLOCK SO- IT IS JUST ABOUT
TWO O'CLOCK THAT WILL BE ENDING
AT TWO OH TWO SO MATTER
MODERATOR WERE PUT AN EXTRA
MINUTE ON THE CLOCK PLEASE
PROCEED NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI NANCY OKADA. BOB
FELLER WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MONEY CAN'T HEAR
FROM FAMILIES AND HOMES AND SAN
JOSE AFFILIATED WITH UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN LIVERPOOL
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
UNLIKEABLE LADY HALF MARATHON
TO BE A BURBANK SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BURBANK MEMBER. APPLE
SPRINGER AND THE BURBANK CITY
COUNCIL. COUNCIL UNANIMOUSLY
OPPOSES SB TEN THE FILTH OF THE
ROTATE AND EQUITY AND FAIRNESS
COMMODITIZATION MARKET RATE
HOUSING IT OFFERS
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS ONTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY WE'RE
GONNA ALONG THAT IN HIS
OPPOSITION DON'T MEAN TO CUT
YOU OFF WE JUST NEED FIRST LAST
NAME AFFILIATION AS WELL AS
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURELY LUNDELL
HE ALONG WITH GROUPS KELLY THE
MOBILE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE
VERY GRATEFUL- ONE MINUTE LEFT
ONE MINUTE LEFT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU ORANGE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
GEGEN LOS ANGELES FRANKLIN
COURT A COMMUNITY UNITED
NEIGHBORS WILBUR CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENT
WHICH BUILDINGS MUST TAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE FEES NOT
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A MAJOR
ACCOUNTS CITIES FOR BROKEN
OVERRIDING THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT ALL ON ONE BILL HOW
IMPRESSED WITH POWER GRABS THAT
AND NOT A SINGLE WORD ABOUT IT.
VERY GRATEFUL FIRST LAST NAME
AFFILIATION AS WELL AS YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AGAIN NOT
TRYING TO CUT FOLKS OFF WE JUST
NEED TO GET YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOU. ALL HANG IN WITH US LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU RIGHT FOR NINETY THREE. GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KRISTEN
RASMUSSEN- I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE BURDEN VALLEY
NEIGHBORHOODS GROUP
REPRESENTING ABOUT THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AND BUT
PROBABLY IN THE CITY OF ROCK
YET I'M ALSO THINKING ON BEHALF
OF THE LAFAYETTE HUNTERS
COUNCIL REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
HOMEOWNERS GROUPS AND H. AWAY.
YET WE STAND IN UNITY WITH
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO BACKGROUND THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE NOW HAVE TIME
FOR TO LAST CALLERS TO FINAL
CALLER'S BEEN A. MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP NOW. THANK YOU
ARE IN FACT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR TURN NUMBER LITTLEJOHN OF
THE AT THE MONICA OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANKS LAST CALLER
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS CARLENE DR DALLAS
ANY THE UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY VERY
GRATEFUL I A FIRST AND
FOREMOST. TO EVERYONE WHO'S
CALLED IN TODAY FOR THOSE HAVE
BEEN WAITING ON THE LINES WE
JUST CAN'T SAY THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK TODAY WE
APOLOGIZE IT OUT WE COULDN'T
GET TO EVERYONE WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING. YOUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING AT THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE ALL RIGHT
LAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO COMMENTS IN THAT START
WITH OUR MAJORITY LEADER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS-
CENTERS FOR. I'M NOT GETTING
LIKE. THIRTIES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN ON- CENTER WINNER IF
THE CITY OF BAKERSFIELD. NEXT
WEEK WHETHER THROUGH ORDINANCE
OR THEY SHOULD'VE DECIDED TO
ADOPT A- POLICY SIMILAR TO
WHAT'S CONTAINED IN SB TEN.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD TO ADOPT AN
ORDINANCE TO ZONE A PARTIAL FOR
UP TO TEN UNITS IN THE TRANSIT
RICH AREAS JOB CHERRY URBAN
INFILL SITE BECAUSE THEY DO SO.
THE GROUP WHICH TODAY COULD I
DO SO YEAH. HI YES YES
ABSOLUTELY IT WOULD BE A MUCH
LENGTHIER AND MORE EXPENSIVE
PROCESS FOR THEM TO DO IT BUT-
YOU COULD DO IT. IF THEY COULD
DO IT- BUT NOT IN THE SAME WAY.
NOT THEY WOULD NOT HAVE THE
EXPEDITED. PROCESS THAT SB TEN
WILL PROVIDE THE NEW VOLUNTARY
PROCESS. OKAY YOU KNOW I A FEW
WELL KNOWN WE HAD LONG
DISCUSSIONS ON THE SENATOR. YOU
ARE ONE BRIGHT FELLA. BUT I WAS
NOT SOMEBODY WHO WAS SUPPORTIVE
OF- SB FIFTY LAST YEAR AND THE
REASON I DIDN'T DO IT WAS
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT IT
DESTROYED AS I SAID IN MY FOR
STATEMENT SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND I BELIEVE
THAT. THERE'S  VALUE TO SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS I THINK
THEY'RE IMPORTANT PEOPLE MAKE
DECISIONS TO LIVE IN SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS. AND I
THINK THAT ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
SOMEWHAT OF A CHALLENGE PRETTY
URGENT CHALLENGE WITH RESPECT
TO HOUSING SUPPLY. THE QUESTION
IS DO WE NEED TO DESTROY
BECAUSE BASICALLY BY GOING TO
TEN UNITS OF MY BLOCK AND STATE
BAN EYES. AND I COULD BUILD TEN
UNITS ON MY BLOCK WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY IN MY JUDGMENT.
AND I KNOW MY NEIGHBORS
JUDGMENTS DESTROY THE CHARACTER
OF MY NEIGHBORHOOD- AND SO- ALL
OF A SUDDEN THOSE WOULD NO
LONGER BE ASSUMING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MADE THOSE
QUESTIONS. AND SO FROM A
PHILOSOPHICAL STANDPOINT YOU
KNOW THE FACT THAT THE ARGUMENT
WITH RESPECT TO S. B. TEN
VERSES SB FIFTY IN MY VIEW. IS
THE VOLUNTARY NATURE OF IT IT'S
LIKE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HAVING. A BILL THAT HAS SHARP
TEETH OR DENTURES IT MIGHT IT
MIGHT NOT. BE EASIER TO MAKE
THE ARGUMENT BUT THE REALITY
FROM A PHILOSOPHICAL
STANDPOINT. I CAN'T VOTE FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE WHAT I'M
TELLING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS. YOU COULD DESTROY A SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS SEEMS TO
ME OF THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE MILES WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
NEED TO PRESERVE A GREAT DEAL
OF IT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL SPACE.
THAT WE HAVE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY NOW
WITH THE PANDEMIC THE BILLS WE
HAVE HERE FOR ADAPTIVE RE USE
CERTAIN IN MY CITY I'M TRYING
DESPERATELY WANT TO SUPPORT
THOSE THINGS ALONG. VENTURA
BOULEVARD IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WE CAN TURN THOSE INTO-
LIVABLE UNITS I LIVED IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AND- IN
THE ARTS DISTRICT INTO OVER
HOUSE WHERE WE DID ADAPTIVE RE
USE THAT WORK PRETTY
BRILLIANTLY EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN DOWNTWN LOS ANGELES.
UP UNTIL THE PANDEMIC WE'RE
PRETTY BRILLIANTLY- THE
CABALLERO MEASURE WHICH SAYS
WITH THESE BUILDINGS THAT WE
HAVE LOST BECAUSE OF. THE
PANDEMIC OF THE DE CHANGE THE
ECONOMY WHICH HER. FORMER-
OFFICE BUILDING OR OFF PARK OR
SHOPPING CENTERS TO CONVERT
THOSE TOGETHER WAS CENTER
PORTANTINO'S MEASURE TO FIGURE
FUNDING MECHANISM. THE REALITY
IS. MANY JUST DON'T SEE THAT
WERE IN A POSITION IN A SOCIETY
WHERE WE HAVE TO SAY. WE HAVE
TO GET RID OF SINGLE FAMILY AND
IT GIVE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES I
FIGHT FOR THAT VALUE I THINK
THAT VALUES IMPORTANT PART OF
WHAT. IS IT IS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE READ
IN THE OP ED PIECE THAT I WROTE
ABOUT BUILDING HOMES. AND
BUILDING HOMEOWNERSHIP. IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOLKS SO. EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A BILL WITH
DENTURES AS OPPOSED TO SHARP
TEETH IS ONE WORD I AS I TRY TO
CHARACTERIZE IT BECAUSE- IT'S A
VOLUNTARY. IT'S VOLUNTARY OF A
PHILOSOPHY THAT I JUST DON'T
SUPPORT. SO I READ THIS THING A
COUPLE OF TIMES. LISTEN A LOT
TO YOUR POINTS OF VIEW AND I
TRIED TO BRING MYSELF TO IT. I
REMEMBER SO LAST POINT TALKING
TO CONGRESSMAN CARGOES IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN WE HAD THE
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY. AND
THEN HE INITIALLY NOTICED THAT
MUCH FASTER THAN WHAT HAPPENED
IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH SPEAKER
PELOSI. THEN MINORITY LEADER
PELOSI I THINK IT WAS- BECAUSE
HE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES OR GOOD
FOR. ON FIRST RUNNERS. AND I
JUST I THINK WE'RE DURING A
POSSIBLE CANCER SUPPORT BONUS
SHIP. AND TO ALLOW PEOPLE HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY SO. WITH THIS
HAS T. THROUGH THIS VOLUNTARY
NOT. IT'S INDICATIVE OF A
PHILOSOPHY. THAT I CAN'T
EMBRACE AND THAT BASICALLY SAYS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO. AS A
GOVERNMENT. CREATE AN
INCENTIVIZE AND EXPEDITE AWAY
TO DESTROY A SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH I THINK ARE
CRITICAL SO. EIGHT I KNOW
YOU'RE A THOUGHTFUL PERSON AND
I DON'T MEAN TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL IN ANY WAY. I'M
JUST TELLING YOU SOMETIMES EVEN
MY OWN FAMILY WE CAN'T AGREE
AND I JUST IT'S JUST NO WAY I
CAN SUPPORT THIS. BECAUSE IT IS
SO ANTITHETICAL TO WHAT I THINK
IS SO IMPORTANT TO AN ELEMENT
OF OUR SOCIETY SO AS TO ENSURE
THOSE THOUGHTS WITH YOU- MISTER
WINNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
THE MAJORITY LEADER CENTER
WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND OR TO GO TO SANTA ROSA
SURE THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS- MR MAJORITY LEADER-
AND THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THE SENSE OF THE SAME BILL.
LAST YEAR WHICH IS SENATE
PASSED ON. OVERWHELMINGLY. I
YOU KNOW I I'VE- YOU KNOW. I
JUST HAVE TO. TAKE ISSUE AND-
WITH YOU YOU KNOW WHAT I AND I.
I WILL JUST EXPRESS IN WITH SB
FIFTY. WE WERE TOLD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. TELL YOUR FORCING
CITIES TO DO SOMETHING YOUR
FORCING IT YOU'RE TAKING THAT
ABILITY. AWAY FOR CITIES TO
MAKE THEIR OWN THEIR OWN
DECISION WE SHOULD. INSTEAD BE
YOU KNOW IT PEOPLE SAID DON'T
TO THE STICK. TO THE CARROT.
GIVE TOOLS GIVE POWER TO CITIES
EMPOWER CITIES YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU YOU KNOW YOU BRING
KNOWLEDGE. THAT WE HAVE A DEEP
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE NEED
MORE HOUSING YOU AND I CAN
AGREE ON THAT. AND WE WERE TOLD
WITH SB FIFTY INSTEAD OF LIKE
YOU KNOW TO USING THE STICK TO
TELL CITIES WHAT TO DO. GIVE
THEM TOOLS GIVEN THE CARROT
GIVEN THE POWER EMPOWER CITIES
TO SOLVE THIS DEEP TERRIBLE
CRISIS. AND WE WERE TOLD FIFTY
FIFTY- THIS IS ONE SIZE FITS
ALL I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
ARGUMENT BECAUSE IT REALLY
WASN'T BUT- THAT WAS THE ARGUES
ONE SIZE FITS ALL. AND CITY
SHOULD HAVE THE POWER TO TAILOR
THE RESPONSE IN THEIR OWN WAY.
WHILE I. LISTEN THAT I HEARD
THAT. BUT THOSE SENTIMENTS AND
THAT'S WHY I INTRODUCED. LAST
YEAR'S VERSION OF US. THE TIME
SB NINE OH TWO. BECAUSE THAT'S-
WHAT IT DOES. IT IS SORT OF A
CARROT AND THE EMPOWERING OF
CITIES THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO IT
ALL. BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING FOR
THE CITIES THAT ARE INTERESTED
IN DOING. A REZONING AND MIGHT
JUST BE ON THEIR MAIN CORRIDOR
OR MIGHT BE IN ONE PART OF THE
CITY OR MIGHT THEY MIGHT JUST.
NOT WANT TO DO IT ANYWHERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THEIR LIVES
EASIER IN DOING THAT INSTEAD OF
JUST TELLING CITIES. PLEASE
ZONE FOR MORE HOUSING. LET'S
GIVE THEM A TOOL TO DO IT SO.
HERE THIS THIS THIS LEGISLATION
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY GET RID OF
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING THERE ARE
OTHER BILLS. THAT DO THAT THIS
IS NOT ONE OF THEM. CITIES CAN
DECIDE. WHEN I HAVE NO SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING. THEY CAN DECIDE
IF THEY WANT TO IN 90% OF THEIR
CITY OR IN 50% OF THOSE CITY
CITIES CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT
AND THAT'S WHAT S. B. TEN- IS
ABOUT I WOULDN'T CALL IT
DENTURES- NO NO DISRESPECT TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DENTURES IT IS
IT IS A TRULY A CARROT- AND
EMPOWER MENT OF CITIES. TO DO
WHAT MANY CITIES WHAT TO DO AND
TO SAY IF YOU WANT TO ALSO IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND YOU'RE DOING
IT IN A NON SPRAWL WAY PRICE TO
DOING IT AND FILL IN YOUR JOB
YOUR TRANSIT NOT SPRAWL- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO A FIVE TO TEN
YEAR PROCESS- TO DO IT SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE- AND I THINK IT'S A SOLID
BILL AND I THINK IT DESERVES
YOUR SUPPORT. YOU CAN ITEMS
CHALLENGES RICHARD IS A LITTLE
BIT HERE BACK AND FORTH YEAH
SUPPORT ISSUE IT IS BUT SENATOR
WINNER TO DISCUSS THIS. AND I
AGREE WITH YOU TO TOOL. BUT
SOMETIMES IT AND THAT'S- STAY.
WILL PUT. AND THIS IS WHY. IT
AS IT RELATES ISSUES I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT. THAT THAT CONCERNS ME
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW IT'S A TOOL
THAT I WOULD USE YOU'RE RIGHT
WE SHOULD GIVE TOOLS TO CREATE
A HOUSING AND CENTER PORTANTINO
HAS A MEASURE. WANTS TO
REIMBURSE CITIES BECAUSE WE
HAVE BRADLEY BURNS AND WE HAVE
THIS FISCAL POSITION OF THE
ID'S AND HE'S TRYING TO USE A
TOOL TO BE ABLE TO INCENT
SHOPPING CENTERS. AND OFFICE
PARKS TO TURN INTO HOUSING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT'S A TOOL
THAT I SUPPORT. I DON'T I MEAN
IT'S LIKE WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH POLICING WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE GUN
IS A TOOL YOU MIGHT WANT TO USE
A TASER OR DIFFERENT KIND OF A
BILLY CLUB. TO ME THE ARGUMENT
YOU MAKE IS COMPLETELY FAIR WE
NEED TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
CHALLENGES. ONLY MAKE TWO
OBSERVATIONS IN THAT REGARD HEY
THIS IS NOT A TOOL I WOULD USE
BECAUSE THE POWER OF THE STATE
IS EXTRAORDINARY. AND EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A TOOL IT MAKES A
STATEMENT THROUGH THE BACK DOOR
ABOUT IT'S OKAY TO BUILD TEN
UNITS ON A TEN THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT LOT. IN THE MIDDLE OF
SOMEBODY'S NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE POLITICS AND THE
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO DEVELOP THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND WILL PAY FOR POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS. AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
ARGUMENTS FIRST AS THE PEOPLE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS THE
DISPARITY OF POWER IS SO GREAT
SO THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN
SOMEBODY'S GOT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS DEVELOPER IN MY
CITY PUTS A MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALLOWED
BECAUSE WE AS A STATE HAVE SENT
THAT. WE THEY WILL USE THE
ARGUMENT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAYS THIS IS A GOOD
AN APPROPRIATE TOOL SO THERE
ARE A TOTAL NUMBER OF TOOLS WE
CAN USE TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF BOTH CREATING SUPPLY WHICH
IS WHAT I'M WORKING ON WITH MY
SELF LIQUIDATING. BOND ISSUE
THAT I'M WORKING ON FOR AWHILE.
AND CREE A HALF OF MY NEW YEAR.
AS TO. IT IMPAC THE CORE OF
WHAT NEIGHBORHOODS MIGHT LOOK
LIKE. THERE COULD BE OTHER
TOOLS IT COULD WORK. I JUST I
DON'T LIKE THIS TOOL BECAUSE I
THINK IT HAS ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES. AND I THINK IT'S
AS THE POWER OF THE STATE. I
THINK IT'S IT SENDS A MESSAGE
THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH MY
CORE VALUES SO. JUST IF I COULD
ADD THAT TO AND HAPPY TO LISTEN
BUDDY I WANTED TO ENGAGE A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THE
SURCHARGE CONVERSATION. BY
RICHARD SHERMAN WAY STE THAT'S
TO BE CLEAR. WE TALK ABOUT THE
POWER OF THE STATE. THIS IS THE
STATE GETTING OUT OF THE WAY OF
CITIES. IT'S A STATEMENT SAYING
WE ARE GOING TO GET OUT OF YOUR
WAY. AND LET YOU DO THIS IF YOU
WANT TO AND THIS WILL NOT
HAPPEN UNLESS THE CITY COUNCIL.
OR COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
DECIDES TO DO IT. WE'RE NOT
FORCING THE CITY COUNCIL IS A
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO DO
ANYTHING. THE ONLY IF THEY
DECIDE TO DO IT AND- TEST IT
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WITH
THE DEVELOPER GOING TO THE
BALLOT TO BY THE REZONING. THEY
CAN DO HAT RIGHT NOW THAT'S A
WHOLE DIFFERENT THING. DIE IN
THE BILL TO GO TO THE BALLOT
WITH THE REZONING A DEVELOPER
CAN DO THAT. TODAY AND THIS
WON'T CHANGE THAT. SO I YOU
KNOW I RESPECTFULLY MR MAJORITY
LEADER- I JUST DON'T THINK THATTHE CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
BILL- IS. RELATED TO WHAT THIS
BILL ACTUALLY DOES IS A
VOLUNTARY TOOLS. THAT CITIES
CAN USE. OR THEY CAN IGNORE
ENTIRELY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER RETURNING ADDITIONAL IT
YOU MAY. I THINK SO MUCH. OF
IT'S GOING TO CENTER DRAWS OF
CONNECTING. THANK YOU- I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE FROM THE START
THAT I KNOWS SENATOR WE KNOW
THE AUTHOR HAS. WORKS ON THIS
DAY AND NIGHT ALL THE TIME
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT TO
DO FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. I KNOW
THAT THINKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS ALWAYS ON YOUR MIND
AS WELL- I DON'T MIND USING THE
POWER OF THE STATE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR
WE'RE HERE AS- LEGISLATORS. FOR
THE STATE. AND DO WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO USE THAT IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY THE DOESN'T HURT
PEOPLE. BUT DOES HELPS PEOPLE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE OTHER
ISSUES THAT YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT WITH REGARDS TO
THIS AND I'M HOPING. DURING THE
TIME I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOU
RESOLVING OF THE ISSUES THAT
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
BUT I. I AM MOST CONCERNED WHEN
THE HOUSING ISSUES COME UP IS.
HOW IT IMPACTS- POOR WORKING
POOR. WHO HAVE A VISION FOR
THEIR FUTURE BUT FOR NOW AND
FOR A WHILE THE RENTERS AND
THEY JUST REALLY WANT TO BE
SECURE IN SOME PLACE. AND NOT
BE EVICTED- WHETHER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY THE CONDITIONS ARE
SET UP FOR THAT- AND THAT'S
WHERE WE HAVE OUR CRISIS. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE WHO WERE BUYING
THEIR HOMES FOR THE MOST PART
EXCEPT FOR THE- ECONOMIC CRISIS
OF THE PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW THEY
GOT A PLACE TO LIVE I'M TALKING
ABOUT WHERE PEOPLE ARE ON THE
EDGE OF BEING EVICTED ON THE
EDGE. OF ANY EXCUSE TO GET THEM
OUT SO THAT. YOU KNOW THOSE WHO
CAN MAKE MONEY OFF OF WORKING
POOR CAN CAN DO THAT SO I'M
THAT'S WHERE I'M COMING FROM
THAT'S WHERE MY DISTRICT I'M
CONCERNED AND I DON'T HAVE JUST
WORKING POOR IN MY DISTRICT I
HAVE A LOT OF MIDDLE CLASS AND
UPPER INCOME PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT BUT THAT'S WITH A
CRISIS AND WE HAVE TO REALLY
FACE THAT CRISIS HEAD ON SO. I
APPRECIATE ALL ALL THAT YOU DO-
ICE AS I SAID I WILL- SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I HOPE THAT
THE OTHER ISSUES ARE RESOLVED
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
DRESSES CENTER WIENER ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE
FOR CERTAIN DRUGS NO I SORT OF
DRUGS AND I REALLY ENJOYED AND
APPRECIATED OUR CONVERSATION
SUCH ABOUT THIS BILL BUT OVER
THE YEARS BECAUSE I THINK YOU
AND I ARE. ON VERY ALIGNED IN A
LOT OF WAYS IN RECOGNIZING THE
DEEP CRISIS. THAT PARTICULARLY
OUR LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS- IN
TERMS OF BEING MARGINALLY HAL'S
OR IN VERY OVERCROWDED-
CONDITIONS AND THE REAL RISKS
OF DISPLACEMENT AND THAT'S A
VALUE THAT I HOLD. IN MY HEART
THAT WE SHOULD NOT YEAH WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT I. PUT HOT
HOUSING SHOULD BE ADDITIVE.
ADDING TO WHAT WE HAVE AND NOT
REPLACING THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE- AND YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY
I KNOW YOU AND I'VE BEEN VERY
ALIGNED PUSHING FOR MORE
FUNDING- BUT ALSO AND YOU KNOW
LEGISLATION SPECIFIC TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS SO. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU AND I. REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. BEFORE I
COME IN I WANT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO BE A NEW ADVANCE IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. SOMEONE
WILL MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MATTER
SENATOR LOOK I'LL BE QUICK.
CENTER WINNERS I KNOW THAT.
WE'RE GETTING LATE IN CHORE
HEARING. NUMBER ONE- AS WE SAID
IN THIS PREVIOUS BILL WITH SB
NINE. THERE ARE NO BILLS NO
BILLS IS IN FRONT OF THIS
LEGISLATION ARE EASY WHEN IT
COMES HOUSING- RIGHTFULLY SO.
HI EVERYONE CARES DEEPLY TERRY
PERSONAL ABOUT THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH THEY CALL HOME. IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN WHICH THEY LIVE
IN AND IT'S VERY PERSONAL FOR
ALL OF US AS WELL. THE FACT IS
THERE BEEN SEVERAL TIMES. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS IN THE
PAST. OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH IS WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING. SO NOW WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ARE MORE STRATEGIC FOCUS
BILLS ARE COMING FORWARD THEY
CAN HELP MOVE THE NEEDLE IN BIG
CITIES AND SMALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHETHER IT'S THE ISSUE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS
REALLY AT A DEEP CRISIS. FOR
MARKET RATE HOUSING. FEW THINGS
ON THIS BILL. NUMBER ONE BUT
THIS BILL IS NOW. VOLUNTARY.
IT'S VOLUNTARY EVERYONE. TO IF
THE CITY DECIDES TO OPT INTO
THIS BILL IT'S ULTIMATELY THE
CITY COUNCIL OR THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DECISION. IN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD THEN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE- WHEN IT COMES TO
VOTERS. AND IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL THAT'S THE
ULTIMATE LOCAL CONTROL. NUMBER
TWO ITS FOCUS ON INFILL- WE
SHOULD BE DEVELOPING NOT ON
GREENFIELD ON INFILL
REVITALIZATION PROJECTS NUMBER
THREE I'VE HEARD FOLKS CALLING
ST WHAT ARE YOU DOING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE WELL WHAT THIS SAYS
ABOUT AFFORDABLE IS THAT. IF
THERE'S AN AFFORDABLE PROJECT
OF UP TO TEN UNITS IT GETS THE
STREAMLINED PROCESS. PERFORMER
UNITS FOR WORKING FAMILIES FOR
THOSE WHO ARE STRUGGLING BE
ACHIEVED THE AMERICAN DREAM-
AND I THINK THAT'S ALSO.
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE
HEARD IS. SAID TIMES BILLS ARE
TO FOCUS ON MARKET RATE IN ON
AFFORDABLE IT GIVES THIS A
MARKET RATE AND AFFORDABLE
EQUAL TREATMENT WHICH I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND THEN
FINALLY WHAT I'LL SAY. IS THIS.
IT IS ULTIMATELY UP TO CITY TO
BE ABLE TO OPT INTO THIS- AND
THEIR CONSEQUENCES GOOD AND BAD
FOR CITY TO DEAL WITH I'M GOING
TO BE SUPPORTED TODAY AS CENTER
WINNER IF YOU HAVE TAKEN IN
LAST YEARS IN LAST YEAR'S
ITERATION. PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS WOULD WORK WITH
HOUSING LEAD GROUP THAT HAD
SOME VERY CRITICAL FEEDBACK AND
I MEAN THAT INTERTRIGO COMPLETE
BACK ON ME SHE THINKS I'M
MISTAKEN IN THAT BUT I THINK
YOU REALLY TOK IN THAT
FEEDBACK I AM VERY VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR THAT AS WELL
PATTERSON WIENER ON AND HAVE
YOU CLOSE- BUT I'LL BE SUPPORT
TODAY PLEASE CENTER WIENER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
REALLY WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ADDITIONAL INSURANCES COMMITTEE
YOU'VE BEEN REALLY INSTRUMENTAL
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS AFTER SB
FIFTY- FAILED ON THE SENATE
FLOOR ON OUR LEADER SENATOR
ATKINS IMMEDIATELY SHE GOT UP
IMMEDIATELY AFTERWARDS AND SAID
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING ON
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND WE'RE
GONNA DO A PACKAGE. AND
CONVENES A VERY REALLY DIVERSE
GROUP OF- OF MEMBERS WHO YOU
KNOW WERE AND THE STRONGEST-
WELL- SUPPORTERS OR OPPONENTS
WHO WERE MORE YOU KNOW ME
SENATORS A LITTLE BIT IN THE
MIDDLE WHO AW BOTH SIDES- AND
I THINK THAT WAS A REALLY
POWERFUL PROCESS AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A HOUSING
PACKAGE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR ATKINS S. B. TEN. IS
PART OF SENATOR TONI ATKINS
LEADERSHIP PACKAGE COMING OUT
OF THE DIVERSE SENATE HOUSING
WORKING GROUP AND I'M REALLY
APPRECIATIVE TO HAVE HAD THIS
BILL INCLUDED- AND- YOU KNOW
AND IT'S A IT'S A STRONG
PACKAGE AND OF COURSE WE KNOW
LAST YEAR FOR REASONS UNRELATED
TO HOUSING- SOME OF THE HOUSE
ISSUES THAT POP UP FROM TIME TO
TIME WE HAD A TUMULTUOUS. AND
THE SESSION THAT WAS
EXACERBATED BY KOBE NINETEEN IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD BEING
EXHAUSTED AND YOU KNOW JUST
DEALING WITH THIS DISASTER
PANDEMIC BUT WE GOT RIGHT. BACK
ON THE HORSE THIS YEAR- ONE
AGAIN- KNOW MOVING. US NOT A
NOT YOU KNOW AND NO SILVER
BULLET NO NOS PACK. IS GOING TO
THE CRIME. BUT WE HAVE THE OP.
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOOD HOUSING BILLS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. TO AT LEAST TWO
WITHIN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WERE WE
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SEVENTEEN.
SOLID HOUSING BILLS THAT ARE
HAVING BENEFITS TODAY SOME OF
THE TAKES A FEW YEARS. TO GET
WRAPPED UP WITH HOUSING BUT
THOSE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BILLS
ARE HAVING BENEFITS TODAY WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THIS YEAR
IN THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY TO
DO THAT AGAIN. AND THEN
HOPEFULLY WITHIN A FEW YEARS
START SEEING THOSE BENEFITS AND
SO I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COOPERATION IN THE DIALOGUE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSUMING YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ALL RIGHT
SO LAYS IN GENERAL WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR MOTION
AMOUNT FLOOR VICE. SENATOR REID
SO MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE THE MOTION. AND CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HIGH. WATER HIS SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIS SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO HIS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG NOTES
SENATOR WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI
FORTY ONE FRIDAYS ENGINE THAT'S
A FOUR ONE VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE GONNA CLOSE ROLE IN
AGAIN WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
CENTER HERTZBERG SAID LOOK. WE
DON'T SEE THE SEPARATE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING EVERY
DAY- IN VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT ROBUST DISCUSSIONS BUT
WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER AND
CENTER WE ARE WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO REBOOT
OUR PHONE SYSTEM AT THIS TIME.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A TEN
MINUTE BREAK A TEN MINUTE
BREAK. WE'RE GONNA REBOOT THE
PHONE SYSTEM- WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU HERE- BETWEEN TWO TWENTY
FIVE CITIES BETWEEN TWO THIRTY
FIVE TO FORTY. SO GIVE US TEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO BE A REBOOT
WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU BETWEEN
TWO THIRTY FIVE AM TWO FORTY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. THAT
WE HAVE QUITE A BIT IN FRONT OF
US. HI AND A- ACTUALLY ON ONE
ONCE. SOMEBODY'S IN GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA GIVE IT TO YOU
LET'S SEE THIS IS TAKE ONE MORE
BILL CENTER HERTZBERG MY DAD
CENTERS FOR BECAUSE I KNOW
CENTER HERTZBERG. HAS TO BE IN
ANOTHER MEETING SO LET'S GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE FOR INTAKE
I'M NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE FIVE
TO DENVER GOING TO REBOOT THE
PHONE SYSTEM- AND YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL- MR MAJORITY LEADER
FORGERIES I MAKE IT VERY QUICK
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER UP FRIEDMAN I. SPONSORED
A PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT DEALT
WITH- THE DID ISSUE OF
CONSERVATION N. AND DROUGHT AND
WATER CONSERVATION AND DROUGHT.
BUT THAT BILL REQUIRED AS IT
RELATED TO SMALL DISTRICTS
BETWEEN TWO AND 300-015-3000
CUSTOMERS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO COME UP WITH
THE COUNTY DROUGHT ADVISORY
GROUP TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
BAKED RESILIENCY FOR THE
SMALLER WATER DISTRICTS TOWARD
SOME OF THESE COMMITTEES IN
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE HAVE TO
DRIVE A OUR WOULD TAKE A SHOWER
THEY'RE DRINKING BOTTLED WATER
IT'S HORRIBLE AND THERE'S NO
PLANNING FOR THAT AND NOW WE
HAVE THE GOVERNOR THIS WEEK
DECLARED DROUGHT ON TO COUNTIES
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WE SAW.
THE 5% LIMITATION IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE DROUGHT WAS SO THIS IS
JUST FURTHER PLANNING THAT
BASICALLY RURAL AREAS THAT
AFFECT PEOPLE IN SUCH A DEEPLY
HUMAN WAY. SO THIS REPORT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE DONE IT WASN'T
JUST DONE UNTIL RECENTLY THIS
BILL SETS FORTH A THE MANDATES
FOR THE SMALL WATER DISTRICT
JUNE FIVE AND TWENTY NINE TWO
THOUSAND NINE OR NINETY NINE TO
DO EMERGENCY PLANNING FOR
DROUGHT FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE FAST
RIVAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH A
CENTERS FOR VERY GRATEFUL WE'RE
GOING TO BE GOING TIED TO OUR
LEAD WITNESSES WE HAVE JONATHAN
NELSON FROM THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER INGENIO BLASTED FROM THE
KING THAT CALIFORNIA'S WILL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. JONATHAN
WE'RE GONNA START WITH YOU YOUR.
THREE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. GREAT
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS JOHN
NELSON WITH THE COMMUTER WATER.
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE AT THE
NETWORK FINE ACTOR THE TAKE A
AFFORDABLE DRINKING ISSUE HERE
IN THE PORT- WITH- HAT
PLANNING. LEAGUE EMILY ABOUT
THAT. GET RETURN SCIENTISTS. WE
ARE IN A DRAW NOW. AS WE SPEAK-
THE IS NOT AN ACT ISSUE. AT
EIGHT. THAT WE THOUGHT THAT.
GOVERNOR STRUGGLING. YESTERDAY
WE NEED. PROACTIVE PLANNING WE
WILL CAUGHT. GRAHAM AND LAST
DROUGHT. WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
BLANK FOR THAT BILL HOW TO
FIGHT BAKER EIGHT. I RECOMMEND.
ON TO DRAW PLANNING CANNOT
CONSERVE BILL IT IS NOT WE
ORDERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER NELSON AS MISSING
OUT FROM THE CAN WATER. NOW
GOING TO GO TO DANIELLE IT'S AN
ACCOUNT MUNICIPAL. SEARCHES OR
SECOND FINAL WITNESS THE FLOORS.
TO YOU'RE FREE MINUTES IN A
GIVE YOU A THREE SECOND. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND OF THE-
NAME IS THE ABOUT THE- WITH
CALIFORNIA MINUTES WE-
ASSISTANCE. WE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WILL AGENCY AND PUBLICLY ON.
UTILITIES THROUGHOUT THIS.
OCTOPOD OF SB FIVE BY TWO AND
WE'RE ACTED AND IN THE- OF THE
MAKING. A WAY BY LATEST. ABOUT
BUT IT KERR BURKE REFERENCE AND
WE APPRECIATE IT WILL BE.
DURING THAT. ADVERTISEMENT
WOULD NOTED THAT WHILE I
CONCERN BUT THE MIKE MANY OF.
WAYS MEMBERS. HARPER ABOUT
WATER SHORTAGE CONTINGENCY.
MORE DROUGHT PLANNING IS NEEDED
FOR SMALL WATER SUPPLIERS AND
COMMUNITIES RELY ON DOMESTIC
WELLS. THAT LEGISLATION THAT
LED TO THE CREATION OF THE
COUNTY DROUGHT ADVISORY GROUP
OF WHICH HE ANYWAY AND
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER WHERE
MEMBERS. SB FIVE FIVE TWO
OUTGROWTH OF THAT WORK THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL INCLUDE
INCLUDE CRITICAL PLANNING TOOL
WHILE ALSO MAKING EFFORTS TO
STREAMLINE REQUIREMENTS FOR
COUNTIES AND OTHERS THAT WE
RECOGNIZED HER PAINTING
STRAINED RESOURCES. INCLUDING A
LINE OF COKE AT NINETEEN
IMPACT. WE KNEW MARC PLANNING
HAD TO BE A PRIORITY FOR THE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN OUR STATE EXPERIENCE
IN DROUGHT AND FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO SUFFER. AND HERE WE
ARE AGAIN IN A DROUGHT
HIGHLIGHTING THE URGENT NEED
FOR SB FIVE FIVE TWO. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
BLESSED WITH YOU SEE YOU TAKING
THE TIME TODAY WE ARE NOW GOING
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. CURRENCY KNOWN STAND
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE YOUR ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NINETEEN KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OR NOT GOING
TO GO TO A TELECONFERENCE LINE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE MEMBER A
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
SB. FIVE FIVE TWO NOW MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COME IN SEPT. OF S.
FIVE. TWO PLEASE. ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BRITAIN
FOLKS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN Q.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIVE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARAMBULA THE CALIFORNIA LITTLE
CONSERVATION VOTERS INTO COURT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT AND FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR TEN
MEMBER WILLIAM TRITON WITH
TRITON FIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE
BROADER FOUNDATION AND JOHNSON
CORRECT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIVE SIX THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS ADRIANA FINANCIAL JOE
WITH NEXT GEN POLICY IN STRONG
SUPPORTER SB FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIVE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL
BUT ONE WITH LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE PROJECTS WITH THE
CAPABILITY IN SUPPORT THANKS
MICHAEL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MINIMUM MODERATOR. HERE
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT AND
A MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GOING TO
COME IN BACK THERE ARE- HEARING
ROOM TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
THAT THEY CAN SPEAK ON- SB FIVE
FIVE TWO IN OPPOSITION HEARING
SEEING NO ONE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSITION SB
FIVE FIVE TO HEAR AND SEE NO
ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING
TO OUR PHONE LINE THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN GUESTS WERE GONNA
TALK TO WE'RE GONNA TALK TO
MADAME MODERATOR. TO BE ABLE TO
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE FIVE
TWO. NOW MADAME MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE LAYS IN GERMAN I SEND
HERTZBERG WE HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS YOU'RE
GONNA BE TAKEN OF THE MEN'S
TODAY I WILL ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT CENTER HERTZBERG
WE THANK YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WILL MOST VETERANS DON'T HAVE.
TO CHANGE YOUR MIDDLE NAME
MOTION CANYON YEAH. ARE WE
GONNA MOST ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER RAZA HEARING SEEING
QUESTION COMMENTS CENTER WOULD
YOU LIKE THIS IS A WANT TO
CREDIT TO DENNIS O'CONNOR IS
THE LEAD COUNSEL IN THE LEAD
CONSULTANT IN THE WATER IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AS CHAIR FOR
HIS GENIUS OF PUTTING THE
FRAMEWORK OF THIS TOGETHER AND
DR MICHAEL DARD WAS THAT MY
CHIEF OF STAFF I ALWAYS GIVE
CREDIT WHERE CREDIT'S DUE THERE
THE PART A BIG PIECE OF THIS
FRAMEWORK AS RIVAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL THE SUPPORTERS MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE PROVIDE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED CAN BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE N
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
I REQUIRE A SENATOR NIELSEN
NIELSEN HIS SENATOR ALSO DORADO
HIS SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
SORRY. SENATOR WIENER'S. BORDER
ZERO FOUR ZERO VOTER GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN LAZY JIM AND
HAVE SENT WIENER AT ON HERE IN
JUST A BIT ALL RIGHT FLAYED
GENTLEMEN. THIS IS WHERE GONNA
TAKE A BRIEF COSTS ARE GOING TO
EVERY SO. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
READ. UNTIL TWO FIFTY TWO
FIFTY. AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GONNA BRING IN CENTER
PORTANTINO CENTER PORTANTINO
WILL BE PRESENTING. SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT AT APPROXIMATELY.
TWO FIFTY WE'LL BE BACK WITH
YOU HERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS
ALLOW US TO REBOOT OUR PHONE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LOSING CHEN BRIEF RECESS UNTIL
TWO FIFTY.
WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY. ON THE LINE WE'RE
GONNA GET STARTED HERE IN ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS ARE GOING TO GET
STARTED ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS.
ARE THEY CENTER WE WELCOME YOU
BACK TO THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE- IS OUR
AFTERNOON SLASH EVENING
EDITION- PRETTY SHOULD
EVERYBODY WORKING THROUGH THIS
MARATHON HEARING DATE LAYS IN
GERMAN I WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD FOR THE
REST. OF THE AFTERNOON. NUMBER
ONE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT CENTER PORTANTINO HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT. WE'VE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE UP TO SENATOR
HUESO BILLS. ON YOUR AGENDA
THAT'S LISTED ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB SEVEN TWELVE. UNITED NUMBER
TEN IS THREE SEVEN THREE FOUR.
SO THE WAY THIS IS GONNA MOVE
IT IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
SOONER PORTANTINO. SB THREE TWO
EIGHT. THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO A SENATOR HUESO SB SEVEN
TWELVE. THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE SECOND CENTER HUESO BILL
FIFTY SEVEN THREE FOUR. FOUR
THEN GOING TO TAKE. PRIDE
SENATOR RUBIO AND SENATOR
BRADFORD. SO WHAT WE GET RIGHT
INTO IT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A MOMENT. INDIGO EDGE
CENTER PORTANTINO ON THIS BILL
LOOK BOTTOM LINE IS CENTER
PORTANTINO. MADE A COMMITMENT
HE MADE A COMMITMENT LAST YEAR
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON RURAL
COMMUNITIES- AREA AND ON LATE
SCHOOL START HE FOLLOWED
THROUGH ONE HUNDRED AND 10% OF
THE TIME. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
FOR FOLLOWING THROUGH AND I'M
SURE YOU'RE GONNA BE AYE TAKEN
THAT CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS IN
TWO DAYS- AT PRESENTATION. SAN
FORTINO THE BILL SHORTEN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND IT HAS BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
DEFINING THIS ROLE SCHOOL
EXEMPTION I APPRECIATE YOU IN
YOUR STAFF'S. DUE DILIGENCE AS
WELL SO- I WANT TO SEND A BIG
SHOUT OUT BACK TO YOU AND YOUR
TEAM- SO I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT. WHICH IS A
CLEAN UP TO THE PREVIOUS SCHOOL
START TIME MEASURE OBVIOUSLY
FIRST I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND
COMMENT TO ON PAGE THREE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RELATED TO
THE MATTER STATEWIDE CONCERNS
IT UP AS IT APPLIES TO SCHOOL
START TIME. IN ADDITION TO THE
MATTER STATEWIDE CONCERN SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT DEFINES A
RURAL SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE EXEMPTION.
CONTAINED IN THE ORIGINAL BILL
UNDER THIS BILL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE RURAL
EXEMPTION. IF ONE OF THREE FILE
OF QUALIFICATIONS ARE MET.
FIRST IF THEY ARE LOCATED IN A
COUNTY. WITH A TOTAL POPULATION
OF SEVENTY OUR IN PEOPLE ARE
FEWER. SAID OF THE SCHOOL THERE.
IS OR AT LEAST. FIFTY PER OF
THE SCHOOL WITHIN THE DISTRICT-
OR DOES IT. AS A RURAL- AS
RURAL UNDER THE FEDERAL
UNIVERSAL SERVICE E. RATE
PROGRAM. AND THIRD IF THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE GRANTS
UNDER THE FEDERAL SMALL RURAL
SCHOOL ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM. OR
ANOTHER FEDERAL GRANT PROGRAM
LIKE THE RURAL AND LOW INCOME
SCHOOL PROGRAM IN WHICH
ELIGIBILITY IS DETERMINED BASED
ON A RURAL DESIGNATION- THE
PREVIOUS BILL EXEMPTED OUT
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH IS SOMETHING PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY. ASKED ABOUT SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT ALSO AUTHORIZES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUBJECT TO A
START TIME REQUIREMENT. TO
OFFER SERVE CLASS WORK OR SURF
CLUB BEFORE THE START OF THE
SCHOOL DAY. CENTERS SB THREE
TWENTY TO SAMPLE IT CLEANS UP
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE AND IT'LL
SURE THE ORIGINAL INTENT. AND
ENABLE LEGISLATION WHILE MAKING
THE CLARIFICATIONS IN LAW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH INTO
PORTANTINO LAYS IN GENERAL WE
DO NOT HAVE A LEAD WITNESS ON
RECORD SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
STRAIGHT TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. C. KNOWN WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY HEARING SEEN KNOWN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LAYS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WERE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR- TELECONFERENCE
LINE. NOT A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU YOU WISH A- AND- OF
S. B. THREE TWO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE ENTER AS WE COME
BACK IN THE COMMITTEE WE WANT
TO REMIND YOU YOU CAN CALL TOLL
FREE ANY TIME INTO THE
COMMITTEE TO BE A COMMON ON
BILLS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO HIT THAT
CODE THAT'S ON YOUR SCREEN AND
WE LOOK FORTY HEARING FROM YOU
MADAME MODERATOR LOOKING FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF. SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT NOW. THANK YOU I
DO UP MY MIND AND Q. IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT SO GOOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SAN PORTANTINO'S GONNA
DO A LITTLE SONG AND DANCE AND
PORTANTINO WHAT EITHER THAT
HE'S TAPPING AWAY RIGHT NOW. WE
HAVE CLIENTS FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE NUMBERS CHRIS
RESPOND BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AFTERWARDS SO THEY
CAN HAVE A- DIDN'T- WE JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
BRINGING. SOME IS ALTHOUGH WE
OPPOSE TO THE PRE ADDRESS OF
THE BILL. WE DO READ TALENTED
AND SO WE WANTED AND ARE LET
THAT WE WANTED TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE EXEMPTIONS APPLY TO
RURAL SCHOOLS RURAL AND SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL AS
AGAIN SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
MULTIPLE GRADE LEVELS BEYOND
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL-
AS WELL DELAYING. FROM JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND SO- AND ALSO
AFTER THE REMOVAL OF LANGUAGE
THAT GRAHAM'S LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RESTRICTING LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
FROM COMPLY WITH DISTRICT
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALWAYS OF THE HERE MYSTERIES
THE IN COMMITTING GIVE BEST TO
YOUR LOVELY BRIDE IN KIDS
SERGEI TO HEAR YOUR VOICE THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT. CALLER PLEASE MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU HAVE
ENOUGH COMMENT I THINK YOU AT
THIS. ALL RIGHT IS IN GERMAN
WHEN GOING TO TURN IT BACK HERE
TO THE COMMITTEE TO BE A SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OFFICE. AND
OF THREE TO EIGHT CAN SEND FOR
NOW. AND SEE NO ONE STEP
FORWARD ONE GOING TO BE GOING
TO ROOM TO FORTY FROM TWO FORTY
YEARS NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
GUESS WHAT WE'RE GOING BACK TO
MADAME MODERATOR. MADAM
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION.
OF SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. S. THREE TWO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE NOW AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH MENTAL MODERATOR GRATEFUL
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION SENATOR EYES ARE. YES I
AM. I INDICATED TO THE AUTHOR
THAT ARE WOULD BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL AT THIS TIME. I ALSO.
SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR MY
CONCERNS. ABOUT WHAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE GOING THROUGH
SINCE THE PANDEMIC- THE- AND
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD THEY BE
FACING IN. IMPLEMENTING THIS
BY- TWENTY TWENTY TWO. NOBODY
EVER ANTICIPATED THE PANDEMIC-
AND WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO.
I KNOW AN L. A. U. S. T.
EVERYTHING FROM PROVIDING MEALS
FOR THE- STUDENTS AS WELL AS
FOR THE ADULTS SAW MILLION
MEALS GIVEN OUT. ALL OF THAT
WAS TO RESPOND TO THE CRITICAL
NEEDS THE EMERGENCY NEEDS HELLO
LIFE AND DEATH NEEDS OF. OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SO- I HOPE YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK LISTEN TO WHAT
THE SCHOOL. DISTRICTS THE
SCHOOL ENTITIES HAVE TO SAY-
AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF THIS CAN
BE DONE AND- IN CONSIDERATION
OF THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
WHAT IS ALREADY- LAW. IN AND
MAKE SURE. WE CAN. INCORPORATE
THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR DRESS-
CENTER PORTANTINO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND PLEASE YEAH I
WOULD SAY THAT- THEN THAT THE
CENTER I HAD A VERY NICE
CONVERSATION TODAY ON THE FLOOR
AND- CERTAINLY L. A. U. S. T.
SHOULD BE. PLEASE WITH HER
ADVOCACY ON THEIR BEHALF AND
JUNO REPRESENTING OUR DISTRICT
WELL. BUT I WOULD. RESPECTFULLY
SAY TO THE L. A. U. S. T. IN
EVERY DISTRICT AROUND THE STATE.
DURING THE PANDEMIC CREATED
CHALLENGES BUT IT ALSO PROVIDED
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PUT IN
PLACE. THE LATE START FOR NEXT
YEAR- WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH IS
TO THE SAFETY OF OUR KIDS- THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
CAN DO FOR OUR CHILDREN NEXT
YEAR. IS TO START SCHOOL LATER
BECAUSE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
WILL BE BETTER AND THAT'S JUST
NOT OPINION THERE'S THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
TO SHOW THAT THE FREQUENCY IN
INCIDENCES OF SUICIDAL THOUGHTS
DEPRESSION ANXIETY- ACTUAL
SUICIDES GO DOWN WHEN CHILDREN
GET TO SLEEP LATER IN THE
MORNING. AND SO IF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WANT TO HAVE THAT
POSITIVE AFFECT IMPLEMENTING
LATE START SOONER ON THEIR OWN
BEFORE THAT THE ACTUAL TIME
FRAME IN THE ORIGINAL BILL GOES
TO PUT WOULD GO TO THAT COURSE
SO I'M HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH
ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND TALK
ABOUT THEIR SPECIFIC ISSUES-
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY LET'S USE
THIS PANDEMIC TIME WHEN KIDS
ARE HOME. TO RETHINK HOW WE'RE
GONNA GET HIM BACK TO SCHOOL
ONCE WERE OPEN THIS IS THE
PERFECT TIME TO DO THAT AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY.
PARENTS TEACHERS. D. A. MEMBERS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HOW HOW MANY
NEWS STORIES THERE ARE ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH TOLL. THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON OUR KIDS
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE CAN DO
TO HELP THEM. IS START SCHOOL
LATER AND SO I HOPE THE L. A.
U. S. T. REACHES OUT TO ME- AND
I HOPE THEY DO IMPLEMENT AND
START TO IMPLEMENT LIKE START
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. BUT
IT'S A QUESTION THAT AND A
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN SO I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT. THIS ADDRESS ANY
ADDITIONAL ITEMS. I THINK THE
THEM- THE WAY THAT. WE AS A
STATE AND I KNOW OUR GOVERNOR
WORKED REALLY HARD ON THE ISSUE
OF OUR SCHOOLS RE OPENING THAT
WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXTRAORDINARY FEAT TO JUST PLAN
THAT OUT SO. I'M HOPING. WITH
YOUR INVOLVEMENT- AND WITH
THEIR CONCERNS AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE SAID WE CAN DO THIS
WE CAN DO THIS INA WAY THAT
DOESN'T DISTRACT. ONE FROM THE
OTHER THANK YOU. THE SENATE
WRESTLED MISTER VICE CHAIR.
PORTANTINO I'VE BEEN RESISTANT
TO YOUR HAND BRACING OF THE
LATER HIGH SCHOOL. I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE EVER GOING TO GET
ME THERE- I GREW UP. GETTING ON
BUDGET SIX OR SEVEN O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING AND I DIDN'T SEE
ANY THAT HAVE COME INTO MY
LIFE. BUT OF COURSE IN THE
STUDIES THERE PROBABLY ARE
PLENTY OF STUDIES. IT IS A SAD
THING. TO CONTEMPLATE GETTING
OUR KIDS BACK AND STRAIGHTEN
BALLOT. FROM THIS PERIOD OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND THE GREATEST
DAMAGE DONE TO THEM HAS BEEN
THE REMOTE SCHOOLING. AND THE
RELUCTANCE OF SOME UNIONS. TO
GET OUR TEACHERS AND OUR KIDS
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM. THAT IS
NOT GOOD FOR THEM AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD PAY SOME
ATTENTION. TO THAT. IN ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT I WOULD LIKE TO PUT
ON THE TABLE LOOKS PRETTY
CONTEMPORARY. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAS NOW DECIDED THAT GANGS ARE
NOT A PROBLEM. AND HE'S MAKING.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OPEN THE
GANGS HE'S INVITING THEM. INTO
THE COUNTY. THAT IS A RECIPE
FOR DISASTER. THE PEOPLE THAT
COUNTY AND THE REST OF THE
STATE WILL PAY A DEAR PRICE FOR
GAS COMES NARAL VIEW. OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. I KNOW HAS NO
RELEVANCE TO YOUR BILL. YOUR
AVAILABLE FOR YOUR BILL TODAY
CONSERVE YOUR SINCERITY OF
PURPOSE AND FOR SELLING. BUT I
REALLY. WHICH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
ALL RIGHT WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CONCERNS
OR MOTION ON THE FLOOR. SOME OF
THE WHERE WE GET A MOTION BY-
CENTER DRIVE CIVIC SO MUCH AND
SENATOR. MISTER SENATOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD THANK
YOU- AND THANK YOU FOR POINTING
OUT THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
RELEVANT TO THE TO THE- GANG%
ISSUE THAT YOU MENTIONED IN.
THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT I AM
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE-
AND YEARS AGO IN THE SIXTIES
AND SEVENTIES ACTUALLY MOST
HIGH SCHOOLS DID START LATER.
AND THEN SOMEBODY HAD THIS BIG
IDEA THAT. YOU KNOW WORLD GOT
COMPLICATED LET'S MOVE
EVERYTHING EARLIER. AND THAT
JUST TURNED OUT TO BE CONTRARY
TO SLEEP SCIENCE AND SO. IN
ADDITION TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS OF STARTING LATER.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT- CENTER. TEST
SCORES GO UP. GRADUATION RATES
GO UP AND ATTENDANCE GO UP. IN
ADDITION ALL THE MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS SO ACTUAL AVERAGE
DAILY. DOLLAR AMOUNTS WILL GO
UP AND IF IN THE L. A. U. S. T.
THAT GOES UP PERCENT. I THINK
IT'S ONE PERSON IT'S LIKE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF EXTRA
EIGHTY EIGHT. DOLLARS L. A. U.
S. THE WOULD GO UP. BECAUSE
ATTENDANCE WOULD INCREASE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I WAS VERY PLEASED TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIR ON THIS CLEAN UP
BILL AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION AS
AS WE MOVE INTO THE OTHER
HOUSE. BEGIN CENTER PORTANTINO
ALL THIS QUICKLY SAY YOU'VE
BEEN PERSON OF YOUR WORD YOU
WORK WITH US IN COLLABORATIVELY
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'VE- I JUST.
TO THAT IN JUST WANT TO SEE HOW
MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH CENTER PORTANTINO VERY
VERY GRATEFUL. FOR MR NO CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE MOTION AND
THEN CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HIGH. REQUIRE
FIVE SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
HIS SENATOR DRAW. TORONTO HI
SENATOR. HERTZBERG SENATOR
WIENER. THREE TWO ZERO RIGHT
THAT IS CURRENTLY THREE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP SEVERAL OPEN CENTER
PORTANTINO I WILL LET YOU KNOW
WHEN IT'S OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME CENTER HUESO TO
COMMITTEE THERE ARE TWO BILLS
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US FOR
SENATOR HUESO. SB SEVEN TWELVE.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AS
BEFORE- WITH- IF YOU THE SB
SEVEN TWELVE IN S. B. SEVEN
THREE FOUR. SO CENTER HUESO
WHAT WE START WITH SB SEVEN
TWELVE AND- JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU- MISTER
SENATOR FOR WORKING WITH US.
AND ON THIS BILL THAT WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
CENTER HUESO AND GERMAN IS
READY- ON THE BILL AND AS YOU
KNOW SENATE HUESO. HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH THE
CHAIRMAN BUT WE DON'T HAVE. ANY
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF US TODAY
THERE IS A CONCEPT THAT WITHIN
FIVE DAYS OF RECEIVING NOTICE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACID TRY FOR
ECONOMIC BENEFIT INFORMATION IN
OF TRIBES- DON'T RESPOND WITHIN
FIVE DAYS- THEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FREE TO BE ABLE TO
PROCEED ON PARAPHRASING HERE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THAT. AS LONG. ALONG WITH
CHAIRMAN IS WELL. FOR SURE SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I TO
CONFIRM THAT WOULD. JUST SO IS-
A HUNDRED ACT ONE OF THE YOU
FOR- WORK WITH US THIS VERY.
MESSAGE AGAIN THIS DOES BILL-
TO RECTIFY YEARS OF
LONGSTANDING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES. BUT NOT MUCH NOT
ONLY ARE STATE GOVERNMENT OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- IT WITH
REGARDS TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AND THIS IS A TEMP
TO RIGHT KIND OF A WRONG IN
HISTORY THAT- YOU KNOW CLUB. IT
AMERICA A RESERVATIONS TO
RELIEVE WAYS TO IMPRISON THE
NEGATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND-
HAVE THEM LOSE THEIR SELF
SUFFICIENCY IN THE WERE OFTEN
PUT. IN IN RESERVATIONS THAT
HAD NO ABILITY TO PRODUCE THEIR
OWN FOOD OR A BUSINESS OR OR
PROVIDE EVEN HOUSING OR
EDUCATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETIMES. LAND THAT WAS PUT ON
ON EXTREMELY HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENTS. OFTEN TIMES AND
ON HILLSIDES AND MOUNTAINSIDES
SOMETIMES WHEN THE LAND WAS A
FLAT IT WAS- IN A CHECKERED
PATTERN SO THAT THERE COULD BE
NO CONTIGUOUS DEVELOPMENT. SO
THIS THAT THIS BILL. IT IS A
REALLY SMALL STEP TO RECTIFY
BUT THAT. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT A
CHARGE CONTRIBUTION TO THE
COMMUNITY WHAT. OF REALLY SEEK
TO MAKE SURE THEY THEY- INSTEAD
OF JUST HAVING A LONG STANDING
POLICY TO POSE ANY TYPE OF.
ENDEAVOR BY A TRIBE TO PUT A
LAND IN TRUST FOR THE PURPOSES
OF PROVIDING THEMSELVES HOUSING
TO HELP YOU WITH YOUR BUSINESS
PLAN- THAT'S WHAT COUNTIES HAVE
DONE THEY HAVE OPPOSED NO
MATTER WHAT. AND OFTEN TIMES
THESE. THESE EFFORTS TO PUT
THIS LAND IN TRUST HAS REALLY
POSITIVE ECONOMIC. BENEFITS TO
THE COMMUNITY FOR. NEVER MIND
THE FACT THAT THESE ARE REALLY
GOOD. FOR A FOR THE TRIBES
THEMSELVES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR ABILITY TO SURVIVE
AND TO PROSPER. SO THESE ARE
GOOD THINGS THAT COUNTY SEVEN
STARKLY OPPOSED SIMPLY ON A ON
A QUESTION OF REVENUE TO THE
COUNTIES IN. A NOREEN THE FACT
THAT MORE REVENUE COULD COME IN
FROM THE REV UP FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THESE COUNTIES.
AS A RESULT OF THIS WE'RE
LOOKING. FOR THE COUNTY TO BE.
A FAIR. AND TO WORK WITH OUR
NATIVE COMMUNITIES SENT TO
RESPOND AS ANY CONCERNS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE BEFORE THEY START
TO OPPOSE. ANY EFFORTS FOR THE
NATIVE AMERICANS BUT MANAGE
TRUST SO- WE DON'T KNOW OF ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND SO
WE WORKED VERY HARD WITH YOU
AND WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S RESPONSIVE TO
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS. TO GIVE A
NATIVE AMERICANS ARE RIGHT TO
FORM- RESERVATIONS OUR LANDS TO
PUT THAT MUCH PUBLIC TRUST OUR
CHIEF THEIR GOALS. THIS IS NOT.
THIS WOULD THIS WOULD HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH. ALLOWING
THEM TO PURSUE CONTINUE TO
PURSUE GAMING THESE. LANDS THAT
THEY WOULD- PUT TOGETHER ARE
NOT AT ALL RELATED TO GAMING
THIS IS SIMPLY. A LAND THAT
WOULD HELP THEM PROVIDE HOUSING
AND PROVIDE A SCHOOL LEAN AND-
JUST BASIC SERVICES. TO THE
PEOPLE OF THEIR- TRIBE SO WE
ASK THAT YOU JOIN US IN THIS
EFFORT. CORRECT SOME TORKEL
WRONGS. AND SUPPORTER NAY
INCOME MADE A- COMMUNITY WHICH
I SOME OF THE- IMPOVERISHED-
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY THAT. SUFFER FROM THE
LOWEST- EDUCATION ATTAINMENT
RATES THE HIGHEST HIGH SCHOOL
DROP OUT RATES. HIGHEST POVERTY
RATES- NATIVE AMERICAN STUFF
SEARCH STILL SUFFERING VERY
MUCH IN NEED OF SUPPORT. MASS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
MEASURE. GOING SENATE HUESO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE IN FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT CONCEPT AS WE
MOVE INTO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE VERY GRATEFUL SO LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR LEAD WITNESSES
WE'VE TO CHAIR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THE LINE TODAY WE HAVE
CHAIRMAN BO MAZZETTI FROM THE
RINCON BAND OF LEUCINE YOU KNOW
INDIANS ALONG WITH CHAIRPERSON
ERICA PINTO FROM THE HOMMEL
INDIAN VILLAGE WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO EACH OF THE CHAIRS WHO ARE
JOINING US HERE TODAY. CHEERS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THREE MINUTES
EACH I DON'T GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT AS YOU GET CLOSE
TO THAT THREE MINUTES WHY DON'T
WE START WITH TERMINE BIS ENDE
MISTER CHAIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOUR THREE MINUTES AND WE
WELCOME. YOU TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. BAKER BURKE. OF BE THE
CHARM AND- CENTER. WHAT. IT'S
SEPARATE BUT YOU REALLY CARE
OUT. BUT THE OF THE STATE
STARTED RECOGNIZES IT. THE BILL
BENDER ARE. THIS CARRYING OUT
OUR BIT FURTHER IT IS GOING
HELP US. BURKE TOGETHER WITH
ANOTHER BIT OF. TO BUY BACK
THANKS BYE BACK. AROUND OKAY
THAT WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR NOT
ALL ACCOUNTABLE ORGANIC PERHAPS
MONEY. THIS BILL WILL HELP. BUT
TO BUY PROGRAM. AND TO THE BIT
THE BILL. TO FOCUS BACK BETTER
AROUND WITH HIS BROTHER. IT.
BIG CORPORATE IMPACT BABY THAT
THE FEDERAL PROPONENT DON'T SO.
WE THIS BILL IN THE MIDDLE
SENATOR. THINGS BE AFTER THAT
WHEN I COULD NOT CARE
EXPLAINING SO MANY THE MOST
FEDERAL THERE ABOUT WANTED TO.
OF THE PEACE OF LAND FOR THEIR
PEOPLE. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU HAVE OF THE RECALL BACK IN
THANK YOU IN. I'M SIR THANK YOU
FOR BEING AN COMMITTEE TODAY
YEAH IT'S GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO A
CHAIR PERSON ERICA PINTO. MADAM
CHAIR YOU ARE IN COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY.
THANK YOU HAPPY TO BE HERE-
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ERICA UNTIL AND I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SERVING AS
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE HOMEBUILDING
INTERNSHIP CALIFORNIA. I WAS
THE DEADLINE ONLY SIX ACRES OF
LAND AKING UP ONE OF THE
SMALLEST TRIBAL RESERVATIONS IN
THE COUNTRY. TWENTY MILES
OUTSIDE OF DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO I
TRIED TO RUN OF EIGHTEEN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
VENTURA COUNTY. LIKE MOST
FITNESS COUNTRY WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND UNFAIR
AND DISCRIMINATORY ACROSS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT USED TO TRY
AND BLOCK TRIBAL ST PETER TRUCK
ACQUISITION. IN WILL COUNTY MY
TRIBE IN. HAS STATE BANK IN
OPPOSITION TO OUR EFFORTS TO
EXPAND OUR RANDY. LONG STANDING
COUNTY POLICY. WELL MY TRIED TO
TRUST COULD MEAN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HELPING
EDUCATION A CULTURAL CENTER HOW
THE HELL COULD. HE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CURRENTLY DO
NOT. IT OFFERS A LOT WHAT WILL.
COMMENTED ANY IMPACT ON
REGULATORY JURISDICTION WILL
PROPERTY TAXES AND SPECIAL
ASSESSMENTS UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RARELY SUPPORT THESE
APPLICATIONS EVEN A BIGGER
IMPACT ROCKERS ARE MINIMAL. AND
THE BENEFITS HE TRIED AND
LOOKED AROUND THE COMMUNITIES
ARE SUBSTANTIAL BADLY MY TRIBE
HAS BEEN SUBJECTED TO THIS TYPE
OF BLIND AND I'M SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION IN. OVER TWENTY
YEARS. SB SEVEN TWELVE HOW TO
DRESS YOU BY ENSURING THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THE BENEFITS OF THE
TRUCK ACQUISITION. GIVEN THAT
IN OUR HISTORY WE STRONGLY.
ENDORSE SB SEVEN IT ENCOURAGE
MORE AND FTER TODAY. FLETCHER
UP OUR SLEEVES AND WORK
TOGETHER. THANK YOU SENATOR
WAIT THOUGH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS. AND THANK CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY AND
FOR YOUR TIME A VERY GRATEFUL-
DO YOU INTO CHAIR MAN CITY AS
WELL. FOR YOUR TIME ON THIS
CRITICAL MATTER. PLACE IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CHECK IN TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. KAREN SCENE NO ONE WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO RETURN TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. KNOWN AS IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCING LINE
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
MATTER MODERATOR. NOT A
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVEN TWELVE. MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU- THIS IS
MISTER MODERATOR. YEAH WE GOT A
NEW MODERATOR THERE WE GO MR
MODERATOR IT'S GOOD TO TALK TO
YOU. GET ATTACKED YOU KNOW
WORRIES AT ALL I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GIVE INSTRUCTIONS TO
THE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO THE- SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN TWELVE AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL GO TO NINE FIVE
EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MAN THAT YOU ARE ON YAKKING
CONN ON BEHALF OF THAT BROWN
ABANDONED MISSION INDIANS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENT AT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
ON SB SEVEN TWELVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND I
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE LOOKING
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN
RIGHT NOW ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
FORTY TWO OR THREE. FOR NOT
GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NOTHING HAPPENED IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISTER MODERATOR
GUESS WHAT WE'RE COMING BACK TO
YOU WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT
EXCUSE ME IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
SEVEN TWELVE EDUCATE PEOPLE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TWELVE
NOW. TO EXPRESS YOUR OPPOSITION
FOR SB SEVEN TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS STAR FOLLOWED. BUT ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO SKEWS ME
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. VERY GRATEFUL MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION OR MOTION. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR REID SO ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HERE AND SEEN ANSWER
WAY SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THE MOTIONS ON
THE FLOOR FOR SB SEVEN TWELVE
BY CENTER DRAWS A MISTER NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE MOTION
AND THENCALL THE VOTE. MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI WIRE HIS SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO SENATOR DORADO.
TORONTO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. TWO ONE THREE
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPENING.
AN AD FOLKS ON AS THEY COME
BACK AND WE LOOKFOR TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WE MOVE INTO
APPROPRIATIONS ON THAT CONCEPT.
GERMAN WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
THE SECOND AND FINAL BILL OF
CENTER HUES THIS IS SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR. ON REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES CENTER WAY SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS A SIMPLE BUILT
NO OPPOSITION ALL IT DOES IS
REALLY ALLOWS. COUNTIES TO
ENTER INTO RENEGOTIATIONS WITH
CITIES ON REDEVELOPMENT DEBTS
SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO REALLY
PROTECT THE FISCAL SOLVENCY OF.
CALIFORNIA CITIES SAID ALLOWS
THEM TO. TO RENEGOTIATE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF DEBT
INCURRED TO THE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES AND OF COURSE AS WE
KNOW THE DISSOLUTION OF.
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES AFFECTED
THEIR ABILITY TO REPAY SOME OF
THAT THAT THE STATE HAS COME
IN. AND MADE A COMMITMENT. TO
REPAY IT BUT SOME OF THOSE-
RESPONSIBILITY STATE BACK TO
THE EARLY NINETIES AND THERE
ARE. THEY ARE- AGREEMENTS WITH
COUNTIES AND BECAUSE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IT
NORMALLY SOMEONE HAD FORTY
YEARS TO REPAY THAT DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
THOSE FORTY YEARS TO- REALLY
ALLOW THEIR EQUIPMENT CREEK TO
GROW TO KEEP THEIR OBLIGATIONS
SO THIS REALLY THIS BILL REALLY
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING FINANCIALLY
DOESN'T OBLIGATE ANYBODY TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN TO ENTER
INTO NEGOTIATIONS. THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME COUNTIES AND CITIES
ARE WILLING TO DO THAT BUT FEEL
THAT THE LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
THEM TO THIS WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
THEM TO SIT AT A TABLE TABLE
AND REFINANCE DEBT THAT MAY BE
ABLE TO COUNTY'S. THAT'S FOR
YOUR EYES OPEN THAT WE DON'T
KNOW OF ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
HUESO NO EVEN WORK ON THIS YES
WE DON'T HAVE ANY- OPPOSITION
REGISTERED HERE AS OF AT THIS
MOMENT BUT WE ARE GOING TO ASK
BEFORE WE GO INTO OUR LEADERS
SUPPORT WHEN HE SEES IT
SERGEANTS COULD PLEASE CALL
EITHER SENATOR RUBIO OR SENATOR
BRADFORD WERE LOOKING FOR
CENTER RUBIO. OR SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR NEXT BILL
PRESENTATIONS WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE ONLY INDIVIDUAL WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ON THE LINE IS
ARNOLD PALMER IS CLASSMEN WHO
IS THE CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON PARK MR
AVERAGE GLASSMAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY. YES AND THE
CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY
PLANNING TO PARK ALSO- SPONSOR
OF THE CITY PIC REPAIR BEEN
SPEAKING TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF TRYING TO PARK.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR RECENT FOR HIS SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND PRESENTING IT
TO YOU. DENNIS IS A SENATOR
INDICATED- YOU KNOW THE BUT A
REDUCTION OR THE ELIMINATION.
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES. THAT
ACTION HAD A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
UPON MANY CITIES. WHO HAVE
THESE EXISTING PASSED THROUGH
AGREEMENTS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ELIMINATED A KEY
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES. TO
REPAY THE OBLIGATIONS INCURRED
BY THOSE. THE IMPACTS ELIMINATE
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAS
RESULTED IN MANY CITIES BEING%
LEFT WITH EXORBITANT
OBLIGATIONS. THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK SUPPORT THIS
BILL IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
COMMUNITIES JUST LIKE YOURS WHO
UNDER SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
NEGOTIATE ADVOCATE ABOUT YOU
CAN LOOK AT YOUR MONEY. FROM
THE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
INTEREST RATES ESTABLISHED OVER
THE PAST AGREEMENTS AND WILL
ALSO ALLOW FOR THE POSSIBLE
REDUCTION OF PRINCIPAL OWED. BY
THE FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES. SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY FOR RELIEF
AND RECOVERY. FOR EXAMPLE
CURRENTLY UNDER THEIR PASTOR
AGREEMENT HUNTINGTON PARK WHOSE
OPPRESSION PROXIMALLY TWO
HUNDRED SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE HIGH INTEREST RATES
THESE NUMBERS WILL CONTINUE TO
SKYROCKET. SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
PROVIDES THAT MECHANISM FOR
LEVEL FEW BUTTERFIELD
NEGOTIATIONS TO REDUCE THOSE
AMOUNTS BY UP TO TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. AND TO ADJUST THE
INTEREST RATE FROM THE RANGE OF
7% OR MORE DOWN TO ZERO
PERCENT. SEVEN THIRTY FOUR IS
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF CITIES TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO PAY THEIR TAXES
DURING THESE DIFFICULT TIMES.
WE BELIEVE THAT SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR IS A BALANCED
APPROACH IS A GOOD START AND A
MUCH NEEDED COURSE OF ACTION TO
ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT
OBLIGATIONS OF FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES. HUNDRED
THESE PASTOR WERE TREATMENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE ARE BOTH FOR SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S ARNOLD
OVER AS GLASSMAN HE'S THE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK FOR VERY
GRATEFUL SIR. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY SO LAYS IN
GERMAN NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
IT OVER TO ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CAN YOU
PLEASE COME FORWARD HEARING IN
SEEN NO ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO ONE IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM WHICH MEANS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK MISTER MODERATOR
TO PLEASE Q. ANYONE UP. WHO IS
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU WOULD LIKE SHOW
YOUR- FOR. B. THIRTY FOUR.
PRESS ONE FOR BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GET TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR S. SEVEN THREE FOR. PLEASE
ONE BY. ZERO AMATEURS NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF. MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL WE
DON'T HAVE AT LEAST SUPPORT
WITNESS ON RECORD SO WE'RE
GONNA START HERE IN PERSON IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE RISE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. HEARING
SEEN NINE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY HEARING
SEEN NONE WERE NOT GOING TO GO
BACK TO OUR MODERATOR- IN ON
OUR TELECONFERENCE ON MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION.
OF SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR NOW.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU AND I
HEARD SOMEBODY HITTING THE
BUTTONS TO SHOW SUPPORT. BUT
THEIR LINE IS ALREADY OPEN
THAT'S THE BEEPING THAT WE'RE
GETTING SO. GROVER WAS DOING
THAT YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD. I AM
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
VICTORIA THAT MY NAME IS
ANGELINA GARCIA AND I'M THE
FINANCE DIRECTOR AND THAT AND I
AM IN AND- IN AGREEMENT WITH
THE BILL. AND THAT THE CITY
HAVE BEEN VERY VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP STRUCTURE THE
EXISTING APPLICATION AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND ENSURE FUTURE-TAX INCREMENTAL REVENUE GROWTH.
TOWARDS INVESTMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CITY. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HANGING
WITH US THANK YOU FOR GETTING
THAT TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MA'AM. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE MAKE YOUR
PHONE MA'AM BECAUSE YOUR LINE
WAS ACTUALLY OPEN AND OUT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION FOR SB. SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. THE MSU
CARE NOBODY IS KEEPING UPWITH
THE MODERATOR THANKS FOR ALL
YOUR WORK SIR WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION INDOOR A MOTION ON
SB. SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. THE
MOTION TO BE. DRAWS- SO SANTA
ROSA IS- ON A FOR A MOTION ON
SB. SEVEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I LOVE IT FIFTY SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR IS MOVED BY CENTER
DRIVE SO- MISTER HUESO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLUB THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
ANOTHER CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK NIVAL THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO LAYS IN GERMAN
THE MOTION IS ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER DRIES OUT. MR NOW IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE MOTION IN
THE CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HIS SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI YOU SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO. SENATOR HERTZBERG. SAN
WIENER. THREE DAYS AGO ALL
RIGHTS RESERVED- WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA ANSWER
WIENER ON CENTER BRADFORD IS
HERE WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE AS SENATOR RUBIO SO
CENTER BRADFORD WE WELCOME YOU
ON I. S. G. SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THE REFERENCE ONE FOUR HERE ON
SB SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN-
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT-
CENTER BRADFORD ON THIS BILL-
WILL ASK IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
TAKING THE- AMENDMENTS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
YOU SIR TO GO TO PRISON SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU MR AND YES I
AGREE TO TAKE THE MEASUREMENTS
THAT I WORK WITH WITH BOTH YOU.
AND YOUR COMMITTEE SIR WE
APPRECIATE FOR THE WAR CARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE- ITS
SEE. SERVER THANK YOU ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS INCLUDING GRATEFUL
TO BE- GOING BACK AND FORTH AS
YOU. AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU. R. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN IS THE JUMP START
OCT AND THAT'S WHAT. WE HOPE
TO. DO FOR SMALL. BUSINESSES
AND UNDERSERVED PARTS OF THE
STATE- THE LET'S SAY THAN THE
GOVERNOR HAVE HAD SEVERAL WHO
CREATED SEVERAL PROGRAMS I
SHOULD SAY IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC- ONE WASN'T AUTHORED.
A BILL THAT AUTHOR LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS THIS. SMALL BUSINESS
TAX CREDIT. GET THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED. AND THIS BILLS UPON
THAT WORK- MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE INVESTING THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SMALL BUSINESSES
LOCATED. AND ALL UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- THESE THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL NOT JUST ALLOW
A BUSINESS TO. SURVIVE BUT
HOPEFULLY ALLOW THEM TO THRIVE
AND GROW. ADDITION JUMPSTART
ACT ACHIEVES THIS BY CREATING A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
FUNDED BY THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN TAX CREDITS SPREAD OVER FOUR
YEAR PERIOD. THIS PROGRAM WILL
BE OVERSEEN BY OUR GOOD FRIEND
STATE TREASURER FIONA MALL.
ELIGIBLE INVESTMENT AREAS HAVE
THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATES THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND
LOW MEDIAN INCOME. THIS BILL
WILL FOCUS IS OUT OF REACH ON
THOSE MINORITY OWNED
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES AS
WELL- THIS IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
TRADITIONAL FINANCING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE. HISTORICALLY
NOT PUT MONEY AND THESE
MINORITY COMMUNITIES OR THESE
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES- AND
LEAVE HEM AT A GREAT
DISADVANTAGE- BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THERE WAS A STUDY AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY THAT STATE
ONE PERCENT. ARE MINORITY
BUSINESS OWNERS. ALONE. IN
THEIR FOUNDING YEAR. THAT
COMPARES TO PER. WHITE OWNED
BUSINESSES- ARE AN EXAMPLE OF
AGAIN THE DISPARITIES DURING
THE PPP WAS OUR- LOOKING AT
LAST YEAR'S- INEQUALITY IN THIS
ACTION EXAMPLE COMPANIES LIKE
SHAKE SHACK THE LAKERS- GOT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS- WHILE
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE GOT VERY
LITTLE IF NOTHING AT ALL AND
THEY STRUGGLED- TO STAY STILL
FLOAT MANY OF THEM WILL NEVER.
OPEN AGAIN THE JUMPSTART ACT
HOPES TO FILL THE GAPS CREATED
BY THE PROGRAMS LIKE PPP AND
INVEST MORE THAN JUST A FEW
THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO SMALL
BUSINESSES THIS INVESTMENT WILL
I BE IN THE FORM OF LOANS AS A
STATE IT. WOULD CAP INTEREST
RATES OR MINORITY EQUITY
INVESTMENTS THE JUMP START OUT
WILL EMPOWER SMALL BUSINESSES
TO GROW AND THRIVE- THAT IS
KEY. WE WANT ARM THAT HAVE A
MORE- EQUITABLE ECONOMY AND
FAIR ECONOMY THEN- BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE HERE TO TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE IS
OUR STATE TREASURER FIONA MA AS
WELL AS SENATOR MORE CHEAP
IMPACT OFFICER OF ADVANTAGE
CAPITAL A REAL BUSINESS
INVESTMENT COMPANY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT SO ON THE
LINE NOW WE ARE HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE CALIFORNIA STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA ON OUR LIVE
LINE- TREASURE MOB THE FLOOR IS
YOURS WE WELCOME YOU WE ARE
STILL WAITING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE CENTER MORE SHE'S NOT
CALLED IN QUITE YET FROM-
ADVANTAGE CAPITAL BUT LET'S GO
TO OUR STATE TREASURER. FIONA
MALL- QUITE THE TAG TEAM ON
THIS BILL BETWEEN CENTER
BRADFORD AND MADAME TREASURER I
HAVE BEEN A REAL DYNAMIC DOING
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR WORKON THIS.
MATTER TREASURE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU BACK IN THE
CHAIR AND LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND THE AT THE- THAT
SEVEN WHICH WILL LET'S START
BOB IS THAT THERE'S A-
COMMUNITIES. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE OPERATIVE. OF WHAT
THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE BIKEPACKING
BEEN WORKING HARD TO
COLLABORATE WITH ALL. OF YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
EFFORT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER TO
INSURE THE PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL. I ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE YOU THAT WE TAKE OUR
COMPLIANCE DUTIES VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
ENSURE. THE TICKET THEY CAN
DEAL WITH NON COMPLIANCE AS WE
DO WITH ALL OF OUR OTHER
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. OUTLOOK IN
MY OFFICE. TO THE RECAPTURE
PROVISIONS THAT WELL AS ANY
OTHER PENALTIES. WE FIND
APPROPRIATE DURING OUR
TRANSPARENT RED CROSS THE ROAD
HAPPY TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON OUR PROGRESS. AS
WELL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER TO HELP
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
CALIFORNIA. YOU OUT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS. VERY
POINT BILL TO HELP. BOB IS
SURVIVED AND THRIVED. SPECIALLY
DURING HIGH. THANK YOU ALWAYS
GOOD EAR YOUR VOICE I'M SORRY
YOU'RE NOT. CAN WITH BUT WE'RE
FOR YOUR WORK VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. WE ARE NOW GO TO IN. MR
RICHARD YOU WANNA SAY SOMETHING.
THIRTY EIGHT HELLO THE- MOCK.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS AND MY
REGARD FOR THE AUTHOR A
DISPOSAL YOU TO REQUEST TO BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL. SHOULD
OF EVERY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND
MISTER VICE CHAIR THE DEAN OF
THE SENATE IN FOR HIS LONG TERM
SUPPORT IS WELL NAY TO GERMAN
ARE GOING TO CHECK IN TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE CURRENCY KNOWN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WE DON'T SEE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY PLACE IN
JENIN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH MR
MODERATOR TO BE A TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN IF SO CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP NOW MR
MODERATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND- AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINETY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY THE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB. SIX NINETY ONE.
MISTER MODERATOR CHECKING IN TO
SEE IF ANYONE SUPPORT IN SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN. MISTER
MODERATOR. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. OKAY GOOD I WAS I THOUGHT
IT WAS A DIFFERENT I APOLOGIZE
FOR SAYING THE WRONG ONE I
THOUGHT OF THAT THE SIX NINETY
ONE BUT WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
PEOPLE QUEUING UP. WE WILL GO
TO- NINE FIVE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD FIVE NINETY
NINE. NINE FIVE NINETY NINE
URINE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND THANK YOU- THERE
BRADFORD FOR THAT MEASURE SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN THAT THAT
MICHAELIDES ON BEHALF OF THE
BALLOT CAPITAL REPORT
APPRECIATE YOU CARRYING THE
MEASURE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESERVE ONLINE SIX GRATEFUL FOR
THAT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
ZERO TWO SIX OH TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE I'M HERE FOR
SIX. SB SIX NINETY ONE. SO
SORRY ABOUT THAT MA'AM WILL BE
COMING RIGHT BACK WITH YOU HOLD
WITH US AND THE MODERATOR WILL
BE WITH YOU SHORTLY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN. MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. I APOLOGIZE I HAD THE
WRONG ONE IN THE WRONG LIST
THERE- WE WILL GO TO WINE. WELL
THIS ONE IS AN OPERATOR I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT SHOULD BE WITH
US MOMENTARILY. HEARING THEM A
LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANKS FOR YES MISTER
MODERATOR THAT'S WHO'S CALLING
DECLARE WITH ENHANCED CAPITAL-
I WAS CALLING IN TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR SB. SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN NINE TWO THANKS ARE
BRADFORD AND- THE CHARTER AND
THE CHAIRMAN FOR ALL ABOUT
WORKING ON THIS BILL. VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. BUT
THE MODERATOR THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU I
WILL GO TO LINE SIX ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
AHMED AMERICAN PRESIDENT OF
STONEHENGE CAP AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT A LEADING.
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL THAT.
IN ORDER TO AT THE- WHAT ABOUT.
BUT THANK YOU. MISTER ADAMS
THANK YOU WE LOST YOU A LITTLE
BIT THERE AT THE END THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
IN TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR
MODERATOR. THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. I THINK AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN. HELLO THIS MORE GOOD
AFTERNOON- SAMORI IS CALLING
AND SHE WAS ALSO A- LEAD
WITNESS- SO I MISS MORE WE ARE
PRECLUDED OR WERE CONCLUDING
HERE ARE SUPPORT COMMON
SICKNESS MORE PLEASE CONTINUE
WEEK WE APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
IN YOU ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU CAN ACQUIRE
BRADFORD- COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA JUMPSTART
ACT I'M SITTING ALONG TO
PROTECT OFFICER DID MANAGE
CAPITAL SENATOR BRADFORD. GAVE
YOU THAT INFORMATION WHAT THAT
MEANS I UNDERSTAND WHAT WORKS
ON THE GROUND WHAT HAS IMPACT
CALIFORNIA JUMPSTART HAS THREE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS BUT I KNOW
FROM EXPERIENCE OUR BEST IN
CLASS AND NETWORK I WANT TO
QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT THEM. ONE
CALIFORNIA JUMPSTART IS A LONG
TERM INVESTMENT AND THAT IS
WHAT IS NEEDED FOLLOWING
SHORTAGE USED SHORT QUICK
CONDITIONS ATTACHED WITH A PIN
NEEDED DURING CORPORATE AND-
OUT TO GET US TO RECALL THAT
AND IT COMES AT THE RIGHT TIME
IT COMES ON THE HEELS OF
TARGETED- THAT TARGETED
SUPPORT. AND WILL TAKE US INTO
RECOVERING SERVICE FUTURE
SECOND CALIFORNIA JUMPSTART IS
DIRECTED TO THE PLACES OF
SCIENCE NEEDS YOU'VE HEARD BACK
STATUS CRITICAL BACK KIND OF
LOSING FOCUS HAS NOT. HAPPENED
SEARCH CALIFORNIANS JUMPSTART
IS A BEST IN CLASS PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT IS
COMBINING PRIVATE CAPITAL SOME
TAX INCENTIVES BUT SHALL NOT
TAX INCENTIVES WITH PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT CONTRACT. IN PLACE
HAD BEEN. SPIKED WILL BE AND
WILL NEED EXTRA HELP TO GROW UP
LAUGHTER ACTION IS LONG. THREE
HUNDRED AND SIX DEGREES. AND
BUSINESS SUPPORT IS THE BIG
MOMENT. THE SYSTEM GROWTH FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES PER PRINT
WORLD MINORITY ARE. AND
MINORITY LET WHEN OWNED AND
WOMEN LED CALIFORNIA JUMPS
BERMAN PET LIMITED. AND OPEN
DOORS PROPERTY FOR. AND WORKERS
OF TODAY AND ALIKE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR BETTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR IN TODAY VERY GRATEFUL
AND SO HAPPY THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED TESTIMONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN-
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO MAYBE
OPPOSED- SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. IF THERE'S ANYONE IS
IN OPPOSITION OF SEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. NO ONE IS STANDING WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM
TWENTY FOURTEEN DON'T IS THERE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. DAYS IN JAIL
AND COMMITTEE WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH MR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. TO
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN NOW. THANK
YOU MISTER SHE AT YOU WOULD
LIKE SHOW EXPRESS TOP. TO ASK
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I
WAS LOOKING TO MODERATOR THE IS.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP IT UP JUST
WHEN I THOUGHT HAD OF COURSE
WHEN WE HAVE ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE MISTER CHAIR. IT
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY.
BRIGITTE EVERYBODY'S PATIENCE
FOR HANGING WITH US TODAY WANT
TO REMIND YOU OF OUR TELEPHONE
NUMBER. 287-722-6815 TWO WITH A
FEW BILL SO IN FRONT OF US WILL
BE HEARING FROM SENATOR RUBIO
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS ON HER
AND PORTENT BILL MISTER
MODERATOR THAT'S COME BACK TO
YOU SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE WE WILLING FIVE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU GUYS HAVE
BEEN MESSING EVERYTHING UP SO
MUCH- I'VE BEEN WAITING ALL DAY
TO TALK ABOUT. AT EIGHT FIVE
FIVE SIX I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE ON RIGHT NOW YOU'VE
CONNECTED ME DISCONNECTED ME
ANYWAY. I'M OPPOSING FIVE SIX
AND I'M NOT SURE WHICH ONE
YOU'RE ON ALL RIGHT WE ARE A
CURRENTLY ON NOW SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN WE DID SPEND FIFTEEN
MINUTES ON FIVE FIVE SIX
EARLIER AND GAVE SEVERAL NOW
SPEND TIME COLLEGE EYES ABOUT
THAT. BUT WORST CURRENTLY ON
SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN SO MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO CHECK
IN WITH YOU SIR IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE. IN OPPOSITION AT. SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN IF NOT WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
BACK NOT AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE MODERATOR ALRIGHT
WE'RE BRINGING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION. A
LOOK AT THAT ADDRESS SIR WIENER
IS A HERE IN THESE OVER THE
BILL ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT-
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM ANY
OF THE MEMBERS. NINETY NINE I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO OUR
WORK TOGETHER I. I THINK LOOK.
AT CENTER BRADFORD I IF I HAD
TO ROBUST CONVERSATIONS ALONG
WITH. THE TREASURER'S OFFICE I
THINK THE ONE ITEM. THAT I KNOW
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT IS THE ISSUE OF INVESTMENT
FUNDS- AND- BEING ABLE TO GRANT
TAX CREDITS. EQUAL TO THE
AMOUNT OF THE INSURANCE
COMPANY- SO LONG STORY SHORT I
KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME. ONGOING WORK ON ON THIS
ISSUE- AND AGAIN CENTER
BRADFORD I APPRECIATE. THE
PARTNERSHIP HERE AS WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS BILL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS FOR YOUR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK IN AND GET
AN ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS ALSO
WANT TO WELCOME. THE CO
AUTHORSHIP OF OURS. ARE DEAN OF
THE SENATE SENATOR NELSON THANK
YOU FOR WANTING TO JOIN. PART
OF THIS. AS WE'VE ALL SEEN OVER
THE LAST YEAR- THE- TO. DOES
STE. CHALLENGES THAT SMALL
BUSINESS MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE FACED. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC- BUT THE FIGURES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
DISPARITIES OF AND LANDING OR
NOT NEWS THEY WERE JUST EXPOSED
MORE SO. DURING THE PANDEMIC
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY HELPS.
BRIDGE THAT GAP CLOSE THOSE
DIVIDES. BY PROVIDING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. TO GO TO THOSE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
THOSE WOMEN OWNED MINORITY
OWNED DISADVANTAGE SHELBY GT.
HOME BUSINESSES THAT NEED THIS
MONEY THE MOST WITH JUST. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION AND- TAX
CREDITS AND I DON'T WANT TO ACT
LIKE THAT'S A SMALL AMOUNT BUT-
WERE. LEVERAGING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE WORTH OF- LOANS TO
THESE BUSINESSES AND- WE HOPE.
THAT THIS MONEY WILL HELP THESE
BUSINESSES AS I STATED NOT
ONLY. SURVIVE BUT THRIVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARTICLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER BRADFORD WITH EMOTION
THE FLOOR MOTIONS AND BROUGHT
FORTH BY CENTERWIENER MISTER
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE. CALL THE
MOTION AND THEN THE ROLE.
MOTION IS DUE. AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE WIRE ON A
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN A
SENATOR DORADO. TORONTO HIS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI BORDER ZERO
PART IT'S A FOUR ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE
ON THAT AS SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
AT AND MEDIAN WILL NOT BE
COMING BACK TODAY THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH I ISS
YOU SERMON COMMITTEE THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
TO OUR TREASURES WHILE. ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE
GOING TO BE WELCOMING THAT THE
WOMAN THE MYTH. THE LEGEND I'M
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HER
NAME IS SENATOR RUBIO WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR CENTER
RUBIO'S. ONGOING PARTNERSHIP-
AND THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL IN REGARDS TO. TAX CREDITS
THE EARNED INCOME TAX RATE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE YOUNG
CHILDREN VERY VERY GRATEFUL UP
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS- IN
FOCUSING ON I. TEN TYLER'S.
MEDICINE AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS
IN REALLY MEAN THIS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. THANK YOU WHILE HIGH.
REALLY JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
THAT WONDERFUL INTRODUCTION. I
REALLY ENJOYED IT BUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT. SB SIX NINETY
ONE. I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND STUFF
FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH MY
STAFF TO MAKE THIS WORK TODAY.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THIS BILL
WHICH IS A MUCH NEEDED ECONOMIC
RIGHTLY FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND
IT IS A LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY
BILL. THAT KELLY ITC IS ONE OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS FOR
REDUCING POVERTY ACROSS THE
NATION. AND UNFORTUNATELY NOT
EVERYONE RECEIVES A MEANINGFUL
TAX CREDIT. WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT OUR LOW WAGE EARNERS HAVE
BEEN MORE LIKELY TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS THIS PAST YEAR AND NEED.
EVERY POSSIBLE RESOURCE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM PAY FOR
FOOD. RENT AND BASIC
NECESSITIES. AND ALSO TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION IN PARTICULAR
ARE CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THE
UNMET NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
ITIN. FILERS ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER MORE THAN HALF OF LOW
INCOME WORKERS WHO BENEFIT.
FROM THE COUNTY ITC ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT AND ABOUT HALF OF THOSE
WORKERS GET LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. MANY OF THE
WORKERS WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS ARE HARD WORKING
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS DURING CARPET NINETEEN
AND EARNED VERY LITTLE. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE. AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND CREDIT AT THE ONLY FOR TEN
FOR EXCUSE. FROM THE FEATHER
TAX CREDIT. IMAGINE THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT INCOME
ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLDS IS
CURRENTLY SET AT ONE DOLLAR
ALLOWING FOR NEARLY ALL LOW
INCOME WORKERS WITH CHILDREN TO
BENEFIT HOWEVER THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND THAT ELIGIBILITY BY
LOWERING THAT THRESHOLD TO ZERO
TO ENSURE THAT THE Y. C. T. C.
IS INCLUSIVE. TO IN HOME
CAREGIVERS WITHOUT PAID PAID
WORK THE CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
IS A CRITICAL ASPECT A TACKLING
CALIFORNIA'S POVERTY CRISIS AND
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
TO WORKING FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO AFFORD BASIC NECESSITIES AND
IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY WITNESSES ON THE PHONE I
HAVE STILL RIDLEY. ARE SEEING
YOUNG WITH THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA AND
SUZANNE HARRIS COMMUNITY IMPACT
DIRECTOR WITH THE UNITED WAY OF
ONE COUNTRY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM
SENATOR WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE HAVE TO LEAD WITNESSES
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO MISSING YOUNG. WHO IS
WITH THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND A MISSING YOUNG YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT YOU ARE
NOW IN COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THAT'S A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
AND THE RELIEF WELL TO BUT ON
HOW. THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND HAVE BEEN CAN TO THE
PLAYING OUR CHURCH COULDN'T
LOOK ME IN PARTICULAR FOR
CHILDREN AND CHILDREN ACROSS.
OF ONE OF THE TOP OF THE ATP
COALITION COURTING WE HAVE THE-
OF THE KARAOKE BOARD OF
PROBLEMS INTERCUT FIFTEEN. WE
CAN ADVOCATE CURRENT OF THE
COUNT YET AND I AND POVERTY TAX
CREDIT BUT THE BANKS ACT ALONG
I PART BELIEVE THAT ONE SHOULD
LIVING IN. ESPECIALLY AND I
PRAY THE PUCK GROUP IN. NINETY
ONE BACK BUT RUBIO OF THE THAT
THANK YOU UNDOCUMENTED MEMBERS
WORKERS WHO. IN TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER I. THEY
DO NOT HAVE WITH THE KIDDING
NUMBER BY ADDING AN ADDITION
HUNDRED I CAN BUY BY THE AND
COMPACT. BUT CERTAIN IT
ELIGIBILITY BUT ACTED UPON ONE
DOLLAR. ABOUT ANY. TO ENSURE
THE UNPAID CAREGIVERS WHAT
CHILDREN FIVE UNDER THE YOU BUT
WE DON'T CHARGE ABOUT I CAN'T
YOU BECAUSE COMMITTED TO ADD
EQUITY TO COMPLETELY TO BE WILL
HAVE BEEN THE TARGET. I WANT TO
MOVE THAT MOMENTUM BACK AT THE
MOMENT WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE MIX
UP. UNDOCUMENTED HOW LOOK BUT
THEM. OF OUR- WORK. HAVING TO
THE CROPS THAT OUR COUNTRY WITH.
FIFTY THAT BECOME THE QUOTE ARE
BACK. BY THE GOOD PEOPLE CLEAN
TO CUT NINETEEN. AND FOR MUCH
MORE I WOULD CHILDREN BE
ORGANIZED. THE CHILDREN PERFECT
FUND PUBLIC AND KNOWLEDGE WITH
BUTTON PERCENT I CAN HELP OUT
OF THE PEN. AT DEPENDS ON WHAT
ENSURE THAT UNPAID CAREGIVERS
WITH CHILDREN HAVE ACTED ON TOP
TRACK. THIRTY SECONDS ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN BUT- DEFENSE
AND HOW. I BOUGHT AND
REQUESTING THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY GREAT FOR YOUR HARD WORK
PARTNERSHIP BY SENATOR RUBIO IN
AT WE APPRECIATE BEING IN
COMMITTEE. PLEASE ENTER AND
COMMIT WERE NOT TO GO TOWARDS
FOR WE- HER NAME IS SUSIE
HARRIS. SHE'S WITH THE UNITED
WAY OF THE WINE COUNTRY MS
HARRIS R. AS ALWAYS WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. TEARS. TO
FLOOR IS YOURS HEARING
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SUZANNE HARRIS AMANDA COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
DIRECTOR AT UNITED WAY OF THE
LANCASTRIANS. OVERSEEING OUR
VOLUNTEER INCOME TAX ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM I'M HERE TO OFFER A
PASSIONATE SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
NINE ONE. THE EXPANSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND THE YOUNG TECH CHILD
TAX CREDIT IS CRUCIAL TO THE BY
THE CLIENTS WE SERVE. 40% OF
WHOM IDENTIFIED PATINO AND MANY
OF WHOM ARE I CAN ORDER AN
UNPAID CAREGIVERS BUT THE COST
OF LIVING RISING SO
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE YEARS
CONCERNED NUMEROUS LOCAL FIRE.
I WOULD BE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITH BEING AN ALL TIME LOW MORE
AND MORE FAMILIES REMAIN AT
RISK OF BEING HOMELESS AT ANY
MOMENT. AN EXTRA ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS BACK TO A STRUGGLING
FAMILY AT TAX TIME CAN KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON CAN PUT FOOD IN THE
REFRIGERATOR CAN FIX A CAR THAT
VITAL TO GET TO WORK AND EARN A
LIVING. THERE ARE ALREADY SO
MANY BARRIERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES NEED TO NAVIGATE IN
ORDER TO ACCESS ANY FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AT ALL. THE RECEIVING
MORE MONEY BACK AT TAX TIME CAN
BE THE URGENTLY NEEDED WAIT A
MINUTE THAT MAKES A DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE ON A
DAILY BASIS ONE OF OUR TAX
CLIENTS FIFTIES AND THE WORK
THAT. OUR FARM EVERY DAY IN THE
FIELD AND INCUMBENT NINETEEN
HEAD AND EVERYTHING CAME TO A
DEAD STOP. EARNED JUST OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY YES TWO SMALL
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE
AND HIS WIFE IS PREGNANT WITH
THEIR THIRD CHILD HE AND HIS
WIFE HAVE I CAN AND HIS
CHILDREN HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS. IS TOTAL CALIFORNIA
REFUND WAS TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SIX DOLLARS WHICH WAS
COMPLETELY COMPRISED OF THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT AND THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. IF IT HAD NOT BEEN TO
THE EXISTENCE OF THESE TAX
CREDITS HE WOULD HAVE TO TRY TO
COVER HIS FAMILY BASIC NEEDS
WHICH IS MUCH SMALLER FEDERAL
REFUND. CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST
DO BETTER FOR OUR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS WHO REMAIN LOCKED OUT
OF MOST PUBLIC SUPPORT AND GET
A VITAL TO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE. MANY OF THESE HARD
WORKING UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY AFRAID
TO FILE TAXES OUT OF. THE IRAQ
MIGHT SHARE THE INFORMATION I
AND OTHER AGENCIES. WEARING A
PARTICULARLY FOUNDER DIRECTOR
PA. OR HAS IT TO HAVE IT.
REFUND CHECK GO TO THE- AND-
THE MILLER REASON. AND WHEN
FILING THEIR WHOLE RELY ON TO
OR- LIKE OURS. AND REALIZE TO
HELP GUIDE THEM THROUGH THESE
CREDIT. THIRTY SECONDS SINCE
TAX. EXIT EXIT PENSION. WOULD
ACT AS STRONG AND SAN THAT WE
USE TO FURTHER ENCOURAGE I CAN
WHOLE. HOLDERS AND UNPAID
CAREGIVERS TO COME FORWARD AND
FILE THEIR TAXES. IRVINE
RECOGNITION AND THIS INCREASE
IN THE KELLY AGENCY AND I CAN
HOLDER. ALONG WITH THE CHANGE
AND INCOME ELIGIBILITY FOR
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. WOULD
GO SO FAR IN HIGHLAND THAT
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YES
VOTE TODAY ON SB SIX MICRON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS HARRIS
WERE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY- IN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE FACING CHEN
COMMITTEE WERE NOT GOING TO
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN. THAT ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ANYONE. SEE
NO ONE RISE FOR NOT GONNA MOVE
INTO YOU GOT IT. BROUGH TWENTY
FORTY NOTHING HAS HAPPENED IN
THAT ROOM. SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH MR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX NINETY
ONE NOW. THANK YOU VERY. AND
GET THIS YOUR FOR S. SIX NINETY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOR BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR
FIRST PURCHASE WILL BE RIGHT
FIVE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL TODAY WE
APPRECIATED NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO ONLINE SIX
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINE
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
JIM. NEXT LINE PLEASE. NINE SIX
TEN YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU-
THIS IS MATTHEW CANTEEN BUT
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL- AND IN
ADDITION- I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF A COLLEAGUE AT SHANTI PRASAD
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS THEIR
ALSO A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER. NINE SIX ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- CHAIRING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS WHAT
WE FAVOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GREITENS SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING ON WE WERE LINE SIX
OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AS YOU CARRY
A LEAD WITH AT THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
EXCELLENT BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH TERRY APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT LINE
PLEASE. AND LINE SIX ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SABRINA THIS AND GO ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINETY ONE
THANK YOU FOR THE PRE SHOULD
THE PHONE CALL THANK YOU LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER. AND MR
SHERIFF THE ACCU IS EXHAUSTED.
THE PATIENT THAT MR MODERATOR
GUESS WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE BACK
WITH YOU IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION BUT FIRST LET'S
CHECK IN HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE RISE HERE AND
SEEN KNOWN OR NOT GOING TO GO
TO ROOM- PRETTY GOOD FOR
OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO
ONE IS IN THAT ROOM THAT'S A
SHOCKER. WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
COMING BACK- TO GO TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION. OF SB SIX
NINETY ONE NOW. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU THE MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS EMOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATION BY
COMMITTEE. PLEASE ENTER DRAWS
OUT YES I THINK IT'S IS GREAT I
AM PROUD THAT THE LATINO
CAUCUS'S SILVA. AS HOLDING THIS
UP AS A PRIORITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. CURRENCY NINE
ETCETERA WE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THIS GREAT DEAL YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL THE
COLORS I CALLED THE FORD- YOU
KNOW I BELIEVE THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL AS
DOES THE LATINO CAUCUS AND MANY
OF EXPRESSED- YOU KNOW LIKE IN
THIS BILL THIS REALLY IS
INTENDED TO TAKE CARE OF MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND SO MUCH. STRESS
AND TRAGEDY I THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER RUBIO INTERVIEW
THANK YOU FOR HANGING WITH US
TODAY I KNOW IT'S LATE AND YOU
HAD TO HANG BACK BECAUSE OF
THIS- AND I APOLOGIZE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IT'S ABOUT. THE
CANAL IF YOU WANNA CALL MOTION
IS WELL AS THE ROLE IN THE
MOTION IS BY CENTER WIENER. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
HI REQUIRE FIVE SENATOR
NIELSEN. AYE NIELSEN AYE
SENATOR DRAWS- TORONTO ON A
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI BORDER ZERO
IT'S CURRENTLY OF FOUR ZERO
VOTE AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE BECAUSE
AS SOON HERTZBERG WILL NOT BE
BACK HERE TODAY DUE TO HIS
MEETING- SO WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE THAT TO FOUR ZERO VOTE AND
AT THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT REYES IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
WE'RE JUMPING BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SIXTY FOUR OF THREE
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY CENTER GONZALEZ
SHE HAD ANOTHER MEETING SO WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL THAT ARE
AMAZING COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER
ARRIVES IT WAS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON HER BEHALF HERE
THAT SORT OF DRUGS- THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ONSB FOUR OH THREE
ALRIGHT THERE'S GREAT OKAY.
WELL THIS WAS ORIGINALLY I'M
READING THIS- STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF A SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND SHE SAID GOOD MORNING. BUT
IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR. MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS.
AND WANTED TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS AMAZING STAFF FOR
CRAFTING THESE AMENDMENTS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FOUR OH THREE. WHICH WILL
PROVIDE STATE WATER AUTHORITIES
WITH AN IMPORTANT TOOL. IN
HELPING CALIFORNIA GET CLOSER
TO FINALLY REALIZING THE HUMAN
HUMAN RIGHT TO SAFE. RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB EIGHT
EIGHT WHICH PROVIDED THE STATE
WATER BOARD WITH THE AUTHORITY
TO ORDER MANDATORY
CONSOLIDATIONS. FOR WATER
SYSTEMS. THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
WELL THIS OF FORTY IS IMPORTANT
IN THE STATE'S SAFE DRINKING
DRINKING WATER EFFORTS IT CAN
ONLY BE USED IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE DAMAGE IS ALREADY
DONE. AND THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
PROVIDING UNSAFE WATER WAITING
UNTIL A STRUGGLING WATER SYSTEM
FAILS BEFORE TAKING ACTION
MAKES NO SENSE. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A PROACTIVE SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM BY EXPANDING
THE S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY. TO
APPLY TO WATER SYSTEMS WITH.
THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS OR LESS THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ARE AT RISK OF FAILING
CONSOLIDATION IS AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL IN IMPROVING ACCESS TO
SAFE WATER BECAUSE LARGER
CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS ARE
GENERALLY MORE RELIABLE SAFE
AND EFFICIENT. THAT IS
EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT 90%
OF ALL DRINKING WATER
VIOLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA OCCUR
IN SMALL WATER SYSTEMS MEMBERS
THE WATER BOARD'S RECENTLY
RELEASED THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RISK ASSESSMENT. AND THEY
IDENTIFIED SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN AT RISK WATER SYSTEMS
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
POTENTIALLY AT RISK WATER
SYSTEMS. AND DETERMINE THAT ONE
THIRD OF THE ASSESSED DOMESTIC
WELLS OR PROXIMATE LEAST
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND WELLS
WERE CLASSIFIED AS HIGH RISK.
THESE FINE BINDINGS DEMONSTRATE
WHY WE MUST ACT NOW. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE THE DIRECTING
ATTORNEY FOR LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ALSO ABLE CRUZ A RESIDENT
OF TOTAL BILL THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON AS BEFORE THREE THAT
CENTER DRAWS- PITCHING FOR
CENTER GONZALEZ ON HER SB FOUR
OH THREE. SO CURRENTLY ON THE
LINE WE HAVE ONE OF OUR TWO
LEADS WITNESSES MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE IS WITH US HE SAID
FROM THE LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
MISTER CLAIBORNE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT- IN WILL
WAIT TO SEE IF WE'RE GOING TO
GET ABLE CREWS ON HERE IN JUST
A FEW MOMENTS BUT MR CLAIBORNE
WELCOME THE COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THREE MINUTES PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S MICHAEL QUICK ONE AND
I'M A DIRECTING ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WHICH IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION BASED IN
THE FAMILY WALKING IN AND YOU
COULD TELL ABOUT IT. THE V.
DURING THE CORE THREE THANK
THAN EVER THAN. FOR OFFERING A
AND DORADO RECALL OFFERING AND
PRESENTING THE BILL TODAY. IT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN DIFFICULT THAT
SMALL WATER. IN HOUSE SERVED
DOMESTIC BOX TO PRINT. BY AN
ADDICT QUAN OF SAFE DRINKING
WATER. THANK YOU FOR CAN THE
CHALLENGES THAT SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS STATE ANY CHALLENGES
ONLY GETTING WORSE. WITH THE
CLOUDS SMALLEST SYSTEMS
AVAILABLE TO INCREASING
GROUNDWATER POLLUTION EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS. AND MORE FREQUENT
AND SEVERE DROUGHTS THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
JUST COMPLETED OUR DRINKING
WATER NEEDS ASSESSMENT. AND
IDENTIFIED SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOMESTIC ROUTES
THAT ARE AT RISK OF FAILURE IN
THE STATE. APPROXIMATELY FORTY
SEVEN NEW WATER SYSTEMS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE EVERY YEAR. IN ORDER
TO MAKE PROGRESS ON DRINKING
WATER ACCESS WE MUST CORRECT
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR PATRICK
WATER SYSTEMS. AND WHAT MAKES
SENSE OKAY POLITICIAN WATER
SYSTEM AND THE MESS THE CROWDS
WITH NEARBY LARGER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEMS. SB
FOUR THREE BUILT ON SB EIGHTY
EIGHT TO AID IN THE STRUGGLE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS TO SAFE AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THAT THE BOARD IS NOT HAVE
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL TO GET A HOLD
A SINGLE ROOM TO TALK ABOUT
CONSOLIDATION. SYSTEM IS NOT
YET FAILED EVEN IF IT ENTIRELY
PREDICTABLE BUT IT WILL FAIL.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO WAIT
FOR WATER. ALCOTT AND FAMILY TO
LOSE ACCESS FOR WATER AND THE
STATE TO INEFFICIENTLY EXPEND%
PUBLIC FUNDS TO DELIVER BOTTLED
WATER. INSTEAD THE STATE'S WHO
ARE PROACTIVELY ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITY. PRIDE DENTED BY AND
IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS FOR SYSTEMS
THAT ARE AT RISK AND ON THAT
CUTS THE FAILURE. THE BILL
IMPORTANTLY REQUIRED MEDICAL
CONSULTATION AND CONSIDERATION
OF INPUT FROM THOSE SERVED BY
THE IRISH WATER SYSTEM THIRTY
SECONDS AND I JUST WAS BY
NOTING. THAT ACCESS TO TAKING
ON WATER AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUE. WITH THE BURDEN
THE CONTAMINATED TAP WATER
SYSTEM FAILURE AND DROUGHT
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. I WOULD
ALLOW BUT NOT THE BOARD. THEM
BY MY JUSTICE. AND COMMITTEE.
AND I JUST SAID YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE. WERE
WITH OUR ON A MAN. WE ARE
DENIED ABOUT AND I'D SAY. MY
UNDERSTANDING ABLE BETTER THE
WORK AT ABOUT FORTY FIVE. BUT
BUT AT THE BUREAU ON THE AND
PROVIDE. A STATEMENT- WITH THE
CHAIR COMMISSION. GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER. WHY DON'T
WE GO BLOG ABOUT AYE AYE. THIS
EAST. YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES IN
IT WILL BE YOU THIRTY. FROM
GOOD ATERNOON SENATORS CAN YOU
GIVE ME YES YOUR COMMITTEE WERE
HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US TO
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT BACK UP THE MIDDLE
LEADERSHIP CONFIRM HERE TO READ
IT BECAUSE THIS TESTIMONY THAT
HE PREPARED BUT HE HAD TO LEAVE
FOR WORK. HE HE WROTE IT AS A
RECRUIT- I AM FROM TO EITHER.
REMOVE WATER HAS HIGH LEVELS OF
HEXAVALENT CHROMIUM. THE
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN WANTING TO
CONNECT WITH THE CITY OF EXETER
FOR A VERY LONG TIME TO THE
WATER SYSTEM. OPERATIONS TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. WHEN YOU COME-
NOT WANT TO CONSOLIDATE TRULY
THE- HOWEVER WE HAVE TO GET
WATER DELIVERED BY THE COUNTY
TO DRINK AND COOK WITH. IN
ADDITION WE HAVE TO BUY A
LETTER OUT OF POCKET. YOU CAN
WATER SUPPLY IT BY THE COUNTY
IS NOT ENOUGH IN MY HOUSE WE
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE. AND WE HAVE
TO BUY ADDITIONAL BOTTLED
WATER. MONTHLY IT CAN BE
EXPENSIVE TURNOUT ON BOTTLED
WATER ALONE AND ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL FOR THE COMMUNITY IN
THE STATE TO KEEP. PROVIDING
WATER MONTHLY. THIS IS WHY I.
SUPPORT. SB FOUR OH THREE THANK
YOU. RECEIVE TESTIMONY YOU SO
MUCH AND PLEASE CENTER- REGRETS
TO MR CRUZ SORRY THAT HE CAN
JOIN IS TO PLEASE ADD THANK
THEM FOR US BAKI DID A
FANTASTIC JOB THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA NOT GONNA CHECK IN
WITH ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THREE HERE IN COMMITTEE. KAREN
SCENE NO ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWENTY
FORTY AGAIN. SENATOR ALSO THAT
IS A LONELY ROOM THERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. FIVE ZERO SO
WE'RE HAD SOMEONE SPEAK IN A
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. YEAH ALL
RIGHT KEEP HOPE ALIVE KEEP HOPE
ALIVE DOESN'T SAY IT ALL RIGHT
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES YOU CAN CHECK IN
WITH MISTER WATER- WELL IT'S
JUST I THINK WE HAVE MATTER
MODERATORS BACK- SOMATIC
MODERATOR WE ARE GOING TO CHECK
IN WITH YOU TO SEE IF WE COULD
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT AT SP FOUR OH THREE.
NOW THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR
EIGHT IN Q. WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIVE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU CAN MEMBERS PLAN
TRAVEL TRACKING TRY TESTIFYING
IN COURT ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
FOUNDATION. THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
AND NEXT GEN PAULA THINK I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND CLEAN
WATER ACTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR AND
MISTRANSLATED THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR STRATTON VERY GRATEFUL. FOR
THAT THAT'S GOING ON. THANK YOU
RIGHT SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CARD WAS WITH HIM
WHEN ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION-
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR OH THREE THANK YOU JIM IS
BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU HANGING WITH
THIS TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU OVER THE LINE
SIX OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS WOULD IT
BE BETTER WITH THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL. THE
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME HIGHLANDER
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THE WORK TODAY- WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO SP FOUR THREE
WE HAVE- THIS IS THE LEAD%
OPPOSITION WITNESS HER NAME IS
CINDY TACK SHE THROUGH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES MS TALK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES ON SB FOUR OH THREE
I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT YOU'RE NOW COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CITY
TALK WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
REPRESENT SENT PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY ARE ALL ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. ON SB
FOUR OH THREE. AQUA GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
COMMUNITY SENATOR GONZALEZ AND
THE SPONSORS HAVE UNDERTAKEN TO
IMPROVE THE BILL OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE MEETING SET THE DOCTOR
STAFF IN THE SPONSORS INCLUDING
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE I HAVE HAD
WITH AQUA ON THIS BILL. THE
FIRST PART OF THE BILL UP TO
THE PROPOSED CONSOLIDATION
MATURITY FOR THE AT RISK PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS WERE CLOSE TO
RESOLUTION ON THAT PROPONENTS
ALL. FOR EXAMPLE THE HEAT IN
THE ANALYSIS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED FOR THE
OCTOBER ADDING THAT THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED CONNECTIONS CAP.
AND SUGGESTED NONSENSE THAT'S A
POSITIVE CHANGE HAVING THE
CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF SUGGEST TO
NONSENSE THAT'S ANOTHER
POSITIVE CHANGE. THERE'S A
SUGGESTION FOR DESIGNATION
DISPUTE MECHANISM AND WE WANT
TO REVIEW THAT LANGUAGE BUT WE
AGREE WITH THE OSCAR IN THE
SPONSORS THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
A GOOD PROCESS- YOU KNOW IN
THAT CATEGORY. ARMY TO. AT THIS.
IT THE OTHER PER OF THE BILL.
AND THAT'S THE- FOR CAN.
AUTHORITY OR THE AT RISK
DOMESTIC WELLS. WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE ANALYSIS SUGGESTED
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
INSPECTION OR TESTING OF THE
DOMESTIC WELLS ON TO DETERMINE
IF THEY'RE AT RISK. THIS RAISES
THE QUESTION OF COURSE WHAT
WITH THE INSPECTION OR
MONITORING NEED TO SHOW FOR THE
WORLD TO BE AT RISK AND I'M SO
FOR THE BILL WOULD BE SILENT ON
THAT. ARE YOU THINKING I'M JUST
STEPPING BACK IS THAT THIS PART
OF SB FOUR THREE THAT PROPOSES
A CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY FOR
THE OUT REDUCE DOMESTIC WELLS
WE THINK THAT'S PREMATURE.
WATER BOARD DOES NOT GENERALLY
REGULATE PRIVATE DOMESTIC WELLS
THAT'S DONE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THE WORKED AT THE STATE WATER
BOARD ON AT RISK WELLS IS NEW
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT GOING ON
TO THE CREDIT OF THE STATE
BOARD STAFF THIRTY SECOND WAS
MUCH LESS DATA IT. MUCH LESS
DATA IN THIS AREA THEN THERE IS
FOR THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN
THE STATE WATER BOARDS JUST
STARTING TO IMPLEMENT STYLE.
PRETTY NEW AT THE READY FOR
CONSOLIDATION FOR THE FEELING
WELL. CONSISTENT WITH OUR WATER
WE SUGGEST NARROWING THE BILL
COULD BE AT RISK PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS INTO LEADING THE
PROPOSED AUTHORITY FOR THE AT
RISK DOMESTIC WELLS THAT CAN-CONTRIBUTE IT'S MY TESTIMONY
AND TAKE THE CHANCE TO PROVIDE
THAT TODAY MR THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN HANGING WITH US
THIS AFTERNOON WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU COMING IN- AT
THIS LATE HOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM. ALL RIGHT VERY
WELCOME- THAT'S CHECKING TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE HERRON
SEEN NONETHELESS FEELS GOOD NOT
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WE'RE GOING TO
NOW GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
MANTA MODERATOR MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB FOUR THREE
CAN WE DO THAT NOW. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN THE- OF
S. FOR OH THREE. WE'VE ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MA'AM MODERATOR PRECIADO THE
WORK LET'S TURN BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS- CENTER
WIENER. ARE WE GONNA MOTION SIR
WIENER IS MOVING THE BILL RIGHT
THERE AT PLEASE. MISTER VICE
CHAIR. THURMAN AND COLLEAGUES
AND MEMBERS WHO ARE. PAYING
ATTENTION HERE TODAY. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
PATTERSON ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
LONG NEGLECTED NO CHADLI SOME
OF THESE. THOSE WHO TESTIFIED
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ABSENT. ABSENT
NO WERE TO BE SEEN AND TALKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
PARTICULARLY IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE ONE WE DEVISED A NEW
WATER PLANNED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M DELIGHTED THAT
THEY ARE ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
HUMANS HAVE A WATER RIGHT. BUT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE FOR
DECADES. HUMAN WATER RIGHT USED
TO BE THE PRE EMINENT RIGHT AND
OVER DECADES THAT WAS
DIMINISHED. TO A SMALL LOCAL
THIRD OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR WATER HUMAN. PAGE WERE
FIRST. NOBODY PAID ANY
ATTENTION TO THAT WE FINALLY
DID ACCOMPLISH IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE SOMETHING TOWARDS THAT
END. NOR WERE THEY HAVE VERY
VERBOSE ABOUT ANY NEED TO
INCREASE OUR WATER SUPPLIES IN
CALIFORNIA. FINALLY IF
PROPOSITION ONE WERE ABLE TO
GET SOME FUNDS IN THERE TOO.
AND CREATION SURPLUS STORAGE AT
LEAST ONE LARGE SURPLUS STORAGE
FACILITY. MOST OF THAT WILL BE
PROBABLY ENVIRONMENTAL WATER.
BUT IT DOES EASE THE PRESSURE.
ENTRIES UP OTHER WATER SOURCES.
IN ADDITIONTHEY WERE ABSENT
WHEN WE WERE DEALING WITH THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BEING
CREATED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE. UNDER THE AUTHORITY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT THE
STATE HAS A PROVISION IN THERE
WHERE IF THE STATE DOESN'T LIKE
WHAT THE COUNTY DOES THEY CAN
USURP. THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES
THIS WILL AFFECT. AT THE TIME
IT WAS REPORTED THAT DOMESTIC
WELLS WILL NOT BE BOTHERED. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT YOU BETTER
BELIEVE DOMESTIC WELLS ARE
GONNA COME UNDER SOME KIND OF
AUTHORITY. AND I DON'T
NECESSARILY TRUST THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO BE
REGULATING DOMESTIC WELLS. THE
TRACK RECORD IN MANY AREAS IS
NOT GOOD. IT'S A GOOD IDEA. BUT
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE FLOATED.
A LOT FURTHER AND I THEREFORE
CANNOT SUPPORT IT TODAY AGAIN
WATER IS VERY VERY COMPLICATED.
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO TRY TO
ENGAGE IN THIS SHOULD REALLY
COME TO UNDERSTAND A LOT MORE
ABOUT IT I DON'T THINK SOME OF
THOSE WHO ARE ENGAGED HERE. I
DO UNDERSTAND THEY UNDERSTAND A
NEED CLEARLY AND THERE IS A
NEED WE'VE GOT PLACES SHOULD
HAVE A REALLY SUFFERING LIKE
PORTERFIELD. ALL THE OTHER HAND
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED SO I
SUGGEST WE MOVE SLOW. IT'S A
GREAT YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION- I'D ADVICE HERE WIENER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN MISTER
BRASHER WITH THE GRATEFUL FOR
THOSE AT ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE BY COMMITTEE.
CURRENCY NINE. MEMBER CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- NEAR
ME YEAH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON BEHALF OF CENTER
GONZALEZ THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER DRAWS SO ON BEHALF OF
CENTER GONZALEZ SAID WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY AS
CENTER WIENER HI MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE MOTION AND
THEN CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. REQUIRE HIGHER
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THAT BILL IS
OUT ON A THREE ONE VOTE WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR I STILL GIVE US
THIRTY SECONDS I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR COM WALKER. WITH YOU.
OKAY. RIGHT NOW. ONE OF THE
FISHERMEN YOU ARE BRINGING TO
OUR ATTENTION TODAY SB SIX
SEVEN NINE BY SENATOR COME A
LONGER. AND THE THIS IS RELATED
TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
FINANCING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING WITH
YOU IN COMMITTEE I'LL BE QUICK
THAT CENTER KAMAGRA SENSORY
GRANT SHE HAD. A CONFLICT IN
MEDIAN BACK HOME IN HAD TO
CATCH A FLIGHT SO I DO
APOLOGIZE AND SHE SENDS HER
REGRETS PLEASE RISEN SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE THIS MAY SOUND
FAMILIAR AND IF IT DOES IT'S
BECAUSE THE BAY AREA I DID A
VERY SIMILAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ON. HOUSING THAT
DATA CENTER WIENER AND I WERE
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN IN FACT
CENTER WIENER WANTED FOR A
COUPLE PAINS INTO IS I AT
TOWARDS THE END OF IT- BUT I'M
VERY GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK THIS
TIME CENTER COM LONGER IS
FOCUSING ON THE POTENTIAL OF A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGIONAL
HOUSING. FINANCE ACTING THE
AUTHORITY THAT WOULD CREATE THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS AGENCY-
TODAY'S BILL- IT LOOKS
DIFFERENT THAN IT REGIONALLY
DIDN'T HERE'S WHY IT'S A
STRIPPED DOWN VERSION OF THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
ALLOW THE GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO BY THE WAY IS AN
ABSOLUTE CHAMPION FOR HOUSING
AND- TO BE ABLE TO COMBAT THIS.
HOW THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
LOS ANGELES IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
GOING TO ALLOW HER MORE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO FLESH OUT THE
DETAILS OF THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE WHICH WILL DEFINE WHO
SERVES ON THE BOARD. CENTER
COME LONGER HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT- IN SHE PLEDGES TO BE
FULLY TRANSPARENT AS SHE
ENTERED- COALITION WORKS OUT
THE DETAILS OF LEGISLATION IT
EACH MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THE CHAIR OF HOUSING WHICH IS
CENTER WIENER- IS WELL AS THE
CHAIR OF THE PREPARATIONS
CENTER PORTANTINO AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD I DON'T NEED TO
TELL ALL OF YOU THIS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CENTER DRIVE SO
THAT L. A. COUNTY STRUGGLED FOR
DECADES TO BE TO CREATE AND
PUSH. A COHERENT COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROTECTION. PRESERVATION
PRODUCTION. SOME SAID WITHIN A
COUNTY HAVE. DONE A LOT. OTHERS
HAVE HAVEN'T DONE IT NEARLY AS
MUCH. IN THE COUNTY HAS REALLY
BEEN TRYING TO FILL THE GAPS AS
A RESULT UNFORTUNATELY- L. A.
COUNTY RANKS LAST IN THE NATION
IN HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
OVERCROWDING IN UNSHELTERED- IN
THIS IS RESULTED IN RAMPANT
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IT IS ALL
OF YOU KNOW THIS WEEK A FEDERAL
JUDGE ORDERED THE CITY AND
COUNTY TO OFFER HOUSING TO THE
ENTIRE. SKID ROW POPULATION BY
OCTOBER. BUT SHE KNOWS THAT
CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH IS IT IS
HAPPENING DAVID PRESERVING
CREATE HOMES FOR WORKING CLASS
AND- LOWER INCOME FOLKS IN THE
COUNTY. IN A SHE ALSO BELIEVES
THAT THE HOUSING CRISIS IS FAR
TOO GREAT TO BE DRESSED
INDIVIDUALLY. BY THE COUNTY'S
EIGHTY EIGHT INCORPORATED
CITIES IT TRULY IS THIS
REGIONAL CHALLENGE THAT. AS
SENATOR COM LONGER IS 1100%
COMMITTED TO TACKLING WHICH IS
WHY THIS BILL IS IN FRONT OF US
TODAY IN TRULY GRATEFUL FOR
LEADERSHIP. IN AGAIN- LOOKING
TO CENTER WIENER. THIS IS NO
EASY FEAT TO BE ABLE TO GET
EVERYBODY ON THE SAME PAGE AND
TO BE ABLE TO WADE INTO THIS
ISSUE. AND CENTER COM AUGER IS
ABLE TO DO THAT IN WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL AS WELL. WE HAVE ONE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS MISTER
VICE CHAIR SAME IS TAMI NEUMANN
IS A SINNER IS SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF IMPACT AT THE UNITED WAY OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES. WHO'S BEEN
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH THE
GOOD SENATOR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE IN KNOWING.
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE BACK IN
FRONT OF US IN HOUSING AND
APPROPRIATIONS IN MAY SO- THIS
IS. AGAIN A STRIPPED DOWN
VERSION OF THE BILL. AND WE
HAVE MISSED NEWMAN AND- BEFORE
THE- FAVORABLE CORRECT. YES
NOBODY. MISTER NEWMAN. ARE YOU
ON THE LINE MISTER NEWMAN
AFTERNOON MISTER. I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME PLEASE PROCEED. DEPUTY
MISTER VICE CHAIR. I MEAN
COMING NEWMAN AND I HOPE TO
LEAD OUR HOUSING ALMOST AT THE
UNITED WAY OF GREATER LA WE'RE
SO PROUD TO BE SPONSORING AT
THE SIX SEVEN NINE BECAUSE
LITTLE BREAK INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL BRING
COORDINATION THE PATIENT. OKAY
OUR HOUSING AFRICAN L. A.
COUNTY INSPIRED BY THE
LEADERSHIP THAT'S ANOTHER SET
OF BAY AREA AND FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH IS PART OF HER
DRESS AND ALLOW IT TO IT
KNOWLEDGE- WE ARE HONORED BY
THE DOESN'T SUPPORTERS ON THE
BILL RANGING FROM HOUSING AND
RACIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION. ON
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PARTNERS IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
I WILL ALSO HONORED WITH THE L.
A. SACRAMENTO DELEGATION HAD
ELECTED THIS BILL AS ONE OF THE
TOP PRIORITIES I'VE MET SOME OF
THE LEADERS WITHIN THE
DELEGATION INCLUDING SENATOR
DROPPED THOUGH I HAVE STEPPED
FORWARD TO COOPER THIS BILL.
THIS IS THE SOLUTION OF BEING
DRIVEN BY COMMUNITY HERE IN L.
A. COUNTY BUT IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS- AND I'VE MENTIONED
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS
UNDERWAY LOCALLY TO BUILD THE
AGREEMENT NECESSARY ON THE
CRITICAL PIECES OF THE BILL.
THE MOST AFFECTED GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE MOST APPROPRIATE WAY
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING ACROSS THE
COUNTY AND WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. BOB IS OPEN QUESTIONS ON
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WENT. AWAY
THAN WORKING FOR OVER A DECADE
TO AND HOW MUCH DOES NOT HANDLE
ACCOUNTING AND EVEN IF WE HAVE
COLLECTIVELY DOUBLE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE LEAVING ALMOST EVERY
YEAR ALMOST HAVE NEVER LACKED
INCREASE. AND THE REASON IS
CERTAINLY NOT A MYSTERY WE'RE
NOT DOING ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
RANCHERS TO PRESERVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE AND
TO CREATE NEW HOUSING OVER THE
LAST DECADE LOCK TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS IN THE L. A.
METRO AREA THAT WENT FOR LESS
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH. AND THOSE WERE REPLACED
BY UNITS THAT RENT. FOR AT
LEAST 50% MORE. IF THERE WAS
EVER A CREDIT. WITH CERTAINLY
GET. SB SIX NINE BRING WHAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED A- APPROACH TO
IN. CHALLENGE AND IT IS
UNTENABLE CONTINUE PATCH.
FRAGMENTED OF THAT WE HAVE. I
WOULD STAND LESS THAN HANDED
EIGHTY EIGHT. EVEN THOUGH THEY
CAN. AT THEIR OWN LOCAL.
INTEGER SUPPORT RENTERS ARE THE
CREAM OF THE- HOUSING LAST. TEN
SO WE HAVE. JUST TO THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT BLOCK THE ABOUT
THE SPEND. IN KNOWING IF WE DID-
IT'S FILLED WITH BE ENOUGH. I
WILL HEAR CERTAINLY NOT MORE
GOVERNMENT ARE GOING IS TO A
FRAME. THAT BRINGS ARE MANY BUT
TOGETHER TO FOCUS THIS
CHALLENGE WITH THE LEAST. AND
THE BUT IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND WILL FORWARD TO.
BURKE WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME.
THURMOND DO WE HAVE A- TO.
SUPPORT WAS BUT WITNESS WE DO
NOT HAVE A SECOND WE- SO A ONE.
BUT DO S. HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM TO SPEAK SUPPORT. AND THAT
PERSON LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOT UP
TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE ENTER.
YOUR SIR AND- EVENING BUDGET
NIELSEN. GERMAN WIRE MY QUEST
REFER THIS BUILDING A COULD.
TRADES COUNCIL AND- OF THE B.
SIX OF NINE YOU. THANK THAT YOU
FOR BEING HERE. VERY GOOD. AND
THE WE HAVE ANY ONLINE
TESTIMONY MODERATOR TWENTY
FOUR. WELL IN TWENTY FORTY I DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NOT WE HAD ONE
INDIVIDUAL HERE ANYBODY ELSE
BOOKS NOT. THAT SAID THEN TO
THE MODERATOR COULD YOU
ANNOUNCED THAT ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY REMOTELY
THANK YOU SO GIVEN THE PHONE
NUMBER AND- HAVE THEM CALL AND.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR EIGHT WILL KILL WILL GO TO
WRITING SIX TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT PROVIDES FOR THE
BILL CALLING FOR ME THEY HAVE
BEEN LIKE HAD PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING AT THE PORT ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AS WELL AS
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SIX SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR EXACTLY
ONE MONTH FROM THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER IN LOS ANGELES
AND A MEMBER OF OUR FUTURE CALL
OUR FUTURE WHEN A COALITION
CALLING IN PRODUCT SUPPORT SB
SIX SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
NINETY PLEASE GLAD. AGAIN I DO
THINK I'M TRYING TO FIND- SB
FIVE FIVE SIX BUT I'M OPPOSING.
AND. THANK YOU WILL FIND
PROVIDED SIX TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON AMY
SURE WITH THE STATE WIDE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION EIGHT
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION. CAN YOU CALL
FOR OPPOSITION. THREE FORTY IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
UP S. B. SIX SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THE
OPPOSITION THE. TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION HERE.
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE
FIGURES AT EXHAUST THE
OPPOSITION TO. AND- MODERATOR
THAT THAT'S ALL THAT WE HAVE IN
QUEUE MARC CORRECT. K. FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND KILL THANK
YOU LET'S COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE
OBSERVATIONS I WE HAVE SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU I- I'M I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M HAPPYTO
MOVE IT- I YOU KNOW THIS IS A
IT'S A REALLY CHALLENGING BILL.
BECAUSE UNLIKE IN THE BAY AREA
WE AT LEAST TIED CONTIGUOUS
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD
ON- THIS IS HARDER BECAUSE-
BECAUSE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS ON
LIKE A BAG AND THEN TO SEE IN
THE BAY AREA. IS NOT JUST L. A.
COUNTY IT'S A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES AND SO A NEW STRUCTURE
HAS TO BE CREATED- SO I THINK
THE WAY WE'RE DOING THIS WHICH
IS A SLIM THE BILL DOWN IN
TERMS OF GOVERNANCE- AND THEN
REBUILD IT LATER OR- A WAR WILL
WORK WELL AND I THINK THIS IS
GONNA BE A REALLY POSITIVE.
THING FOR ALLY SO I DO MOVE THE
BILL. WELL THE BILL MAY THEN BE
AWARE FOR THEM TO LEARN AND
MATURE AND- MORE CAPABLE OF.
ADVANCING THEIR GOALS HERE. WE
DIDN'T DO HAVE A MOTION. AND-
AT TEN THIRTY IN THE AND THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OF ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. NO OTHER
QUESTIONS UNLESS PROCEED TO THE
ROLE. AND IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
ON THE BILL AND- WE WILL SEE.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT PERSONALLY
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK REQUIRE FIVE SENATOR
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN. SENATOR
ALSO THEY'RE ALSO A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI BORDER ZERO BORDER
ZERO SEVEN TENDERNESS CHAIRMAN
SINCE THE CENTER HERTZBERG IS
NOT GOING TO BE HERE SHALL WE
JUST ANNOUNCED THE VOTE. WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND ANNOUNCE ABOUT
PLACE FIVE FOUR PASS AND GOES
TO A PRO. ALL RIGHT OKAY RETURN
TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER VICE CHAIR- I JUST WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO HELP REFINE
THE WORK WITH THE VICE CHAIR IN
FOR ALL OF HIS EFFORT AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SERVICE
YOU'RE VERY GRATEFUL ALRIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN GUESS WHAT.
NICE JOB EVERYBODY- EVERYBODY
BEHIND THE SCENES ISN'T WORKING
SO DANG HARD. TO OUR AMAZING
TECHNICAL TEAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. PADDY IS IN LIVING THE
DREAM TODAY TO OUR SERGEANTS.
PATTIES ABOUT THE GRAB A DRINK
CAL SO- I'M KIDDING I'M
KIDDING- SO LONG STORY SHORT
THAT WE'RE GONNA. CENTER DORADO
IN IN MISTER VICE CHAIR. ARE ON
ALL THE VOTES SO- WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT LOOK AT THAT
SANDRA SO HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
WE'RE GOING TO GET THAT CENTER
WIENER ADDED ON SITE THAT IS
COLLECTED PAPERWORK THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE WELCOME YOU BACK
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING SOME
ADD ONS HERE- WE HAVE LEFT THE
ROLE OPEN ON A FEW. OF OUR
AGENDA ITEMS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
WORK CONSENT CALENDAR CONTENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF THREE
ITEMS ITEM THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN. CONTENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF ITEMS THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AT THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR EIGHT ZERO- MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SENATOR WIENER. ALL
RIGHT WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO.
ZERO VOTE LAYS GENERAL GUESS
WHAT THOSE BILLS AROUND WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE DOWN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER FIVE
FOUR ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT AND WE
GOT A NAIL BITER RIGHT HERE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SEVEN
TWELVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS TO
ONE. CHAIR VOTING ON MR NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI THREE ONE
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR HERTZBERG SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI FOUR ZERO
VOTE BIPARTISAN AGAIN THAT FOUR
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS THAT
WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE AND THEY
DID YOU KNOW THAT IF WE GET
DRUM ROLL PLEASE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE IT'S OUR FINAL ITEM OF
THE DAY. CALLING WOULD LIKE TO
STAY HERE TILL SEVEN THOUGH SO-
IT'S SB FIVE FIVE TWO KERN VOTE
IS FOUR TWO ZERO MISTER NOW.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER FIVE
ZERO VOTE- CENTER WINTER'S
GONNA BE GOING TO IS TOWN HALL
NOW SO FIVE ZERO VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT. WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE LAYS THE GENTLEMAN YOU
THOUGHT TODAY WAS LONG WE HAVE-
AN EXTRAORDINARY LONG HEARING
ON MAY SIX SO- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU ON MAY SIX. IN AS WE ALWAYS
SAY BRING THAT CMPING
EQUIPMENT- WILL BE LIVING HERE
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH IT TO THE
TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF. YOU
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING BEHIND
THE SCENES HERE TO MAKE THIS
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL. WEEKEND AND
AT THIS MEETING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. WE'LL SEE YOU ON MAY
SIX THANK YOU.